[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
the top players in the country are
making magic at the U.S women's and U.S
open championships in St Louis
incredible opening concoctions and
clever tactics left us Spellbound
Christopher you is the boy who lived
rebounding from his round one laws like
a lightning bolt winning back-to-back
games to join a four-way tie for first
Alice Lee and Megan Lee continue to
enthrall with bewitching play in the
women's section maintaining a half-point
co-lead over the field Youngblood has
transfigured the standings what sorcery
will they create next day four of
enchanting chess coming up next
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back everybody to day four of
the 2022 us chess championships and U.S
women's chess Championships held here at
the St Louis chess club we start today
in the historical World Chess Hall of
Fame as we are waiting for the players
to arrive and show their prowess over
the chessboard let's go to the studio
and start this exciting day with Yasser
and anastasi
from the home of Chess in the United
States welcome to the Saint Louis chess
club and the fourth round of the USGS
championships and the U.S women's chess
championships
hello everyone I'm Anastasia karlovich
and I'm here joined by my brilliant
co-host Grand Master yasi serwan
Anastasia it's been a great fun love
calling the action with you thank you so
much hello everyone thank you for
joining the show the Millennials have
truly arrived remarkably a 12 year old
leads the a lady section and a 15 year
old leads the open section yes yes yes I
know they're co-leaders but still it's
extraordinary Anastasia do the honors
tell us who our leaders are let's start
with the ladies in the latest section we
have two co-leaders elsely and Megan Lee
they have two and a half points both of
them great results so far
um
and Jennifer you they have two points
out of three and the arena Crush are
eight-time Champion only at 50 with
three draws and in the open section who
are our leaders there
we have four if I'm not mistaken leaders
in the open section uh Fabiano caruana
same Savion Christopher you and Hans
Neiman they have two points out of three
plus one at the moment and a lot of
chasing gangsters to be sure and our
format for these two U.S national
championship events
in every event we have actually 14
players right so it's round robin
tournament 90 minutes for the first 40
moves and Then followed by 30 minutes
for the rest of the game 30 seconds
increment for move one and of course no
other offers and the tournament's been
motoring right along we're in the fourth
round but our remaining schedule
we're in the first round and now and we
have uh two three days the first one
comes on 10th of October the second one
will be on 16 16th of October and if we
need playoffs they will take place on
20th of October along with the closing
ceremony and we're lucky to have
Christian in studio to break it all down
for us and tell us about the leaders and
how they got to their positions
Christian good to see you my friend good
to see you guys great to be back casting
the games of a 28 of the best chess
players that we have here in the United
States and what a fantastic event it has
been so far the first three rounds
definitely produced the goods and let's
take a look at who the leaders are and
how they got to where they are and we're
going to start with the ladies section
and in this one we have an incredible
young lady only 12 years of age Alice
Lee she won in the first round and the
second one as well against two of the
rating favorites going into this event
in round number one against S1 round
number two against Tokyo Nova and a draw
in round 3 against Cervantes sitting
pretty on Two and a Half out of three
and another lady that is impressing and
this one is Megan Lee she came to the
studio after one of her victories and
she was talking about balancing her a
real life job with a playing at the U.S
women's chess championships and she is
playing tremendously well she won in the
first round against Rochelle Wu and in
the second round against Nazi pikizen
third round she drew the eight-time
national champion Irina crash and how
about the open section well that one is
a contested field Fabiano caruana surged
yesterday with a big victory against
Darius zverj in the first round actually
a Topsy Turvy a game against Lanier
Dominguez with the white PCC 4 got his
opening Theory and actually got himself
in trouble in that one but managed to
escape with your drawing round number to
another escape with Ray Robson and
another co-leader in the open section is
a man that well he's making the news
nowadays that is Grandmaster Hans Neiman
he won in the first round against the 15
year old a brewing rivalry with
Christopher you he won that one after
that he drew against Jeffrey Sean he was
winning in that game as well with the
white pieces and round number three
managed to defend a very difficult end
game against Sam Shanklin and another
co-leader that is impressive and this
event is Sam Sevin he won in round
number one against the U.S open 22 U.S
open Champion elshon moradia body after
that in round number two a draw an easy
draw comfortable draw with the black
pieces against Alexander Linderman and
yesterday I have to say he was putting a
lot of pressure on the newcomer Levon
aronian and last but not least another
co-leader going into round four is the
youngest competitor in the US Open
Championship that is Christopher you he
started off with a disrespectful loss
against Hans Niemann in round number one
but bounced back with an incredible
victory in round number two against
Wesley so and round number three against
Elston moradia body guys we have so many
characters and so many incredible
players in this event and so many rounds
to go absolutely thank you for that
Christian as we see the players in the
playing Hall being wanted by the extra
security measures that the club has
installed for fair play competition
Jennifer getting wanted by
Chris bird our International Arbiter
with his latest and most fanciful one
next my
and as we'll we'll wait for them to take
their place let's go to the pairings uh
Anastasia set the table for our viewers
what can they expect from the ladies so
you'll pick Jennifer you will play with
Sophia Maurice Suzuki Jennifer looking
to bounce back after that loss yes and
the leader Ellis Lee one of the leaders
she's playing against through young Jan
and I will also keep my eyes on the game
between Anna zatonski and Megan Lee a
second leader as well as titular
bergerman who play against Serena for
sure and in the open section the parents
Wesley so will face Sam schengler two
former U.S Champions and riding let's
say U.S Champion right yes and then we
also have a nice game uh between Alex
landerman and Christopher you nice
Neiman versus Fabiana that's sure to get
everybody's attention as well a
mouth-watering matchups to be sure
they're going to be fighting for these
three weeks as again you see nice lineup
there for the security measures one of
the co-leaders
enjoying
he's laughing he's putting the players
in a good mood as well
actually it's good to see players
chatting and relaxing before you're
around I tell you we gotta go in there
and wear as many electronic devices as
we could possibly can can and see how
and see if any one of us can get by a
carefully wanding uh Chris bird and
they're going to be fighting for these
three weeks for lots of money to start
with the ladies what's at stake for them
Anastasia so it's 160 500 dollars price
fund the total one and for the first
place you'll get really great price 40
000 Then followed by 30 20 15 I mean
great amount of money all the way to the
14th Place which gets 3
000. nobody's gonna claim the Bobby
Fisher prize for 2022 as nobody has a
perfect score and in the open section
what what's the prize money there we
have 262
000 and 60 for the first price 45 for
second certified for third and for the
last one it's 5 500 not bad at all
everybody will get something for sure in
this event and the total for two events
it's more than 4 four hundred thousand
my goodness
and the question on everybody's mind
what is Lavon wearing today he's got the
blue with the purple
hmm interesting I don't like the purple
that's something that's not matching for
his style is definitely quite tame
exactly I've seen yesterday right there
were some very including patterns on
this one this one seems to be just some
flowers is that it yeah it's kind of
dressing down on this down a little bit
right now once again for those of you
viewers who are looking and seeing some
Empty Chairs really with the 28
competitors I'm I'm thinking they're
getting used to arriving earlier and
earlier because uh once that at 1 pm
that gong that bell sounds uh they're
supposed to be in their seats but again
there's a backup and there you see
linear Dominguez says Sam Shanklin uh
waiting uh we do have Jennifer
you and Sophia at the board because I
see uh yeah they have passed Sam
Shanklin yesterday it came with a
monster novelty Christian
he he put pressure on Neiman the whole
the whole game but he didn't cash in
that that that big chip of a novelty
kind of disappointing
oh must be yeah he has white his on a
little level player he knew and he had
that novelty uh in his Arsenal for so
long and he Unleashed it in general when
you unleash such a new idea in such a
known position because everybody knows
that position so everybody plays it at
the top level as well and to come up
with such a fresh idea and not score a
victory when you your opponent actually
immediately makes some mistakes and it
did feel like Hans was making some uh
suspicious moves bad moves in that game
and got himself into some trouble but I
have to say I'm impressed with the way
he handled himself Hans Neiman with the
black pieces decided okay you know what
you got me out of the opening but I'm
going to do my best to defend this very
passive uh end game and this is exactly
what he did successfully so wow uh boy I
mean talk about starting with a bang I'm
looking at the game of Alice Lee versus
Ru Yang Yang and a young 12 year old
came right right out of the bat and as
making a big challenge this move a7a6 in
the Queen's Gambit declined really being
popularized by one Magnus Carlson of
course in the past everybody would play
Bishop e 7 as well as Bishop B4 those
are absolutely the most standard moves
developing your pieces what's the move
A7 A6 all about well it Intimates that I
want to capture and then play B5 I would
like to see you capture which Alice did
and the result is that although black is
kind of wasted a Tempo he she ensures
that her light squared Bishop will be
developed okay Alice said fine let's go
Bishop Edge G5 Bishop E6 sending D5
Alice said not so fast I'm taking your
knight
Queen takes
I'm hitting your pawns I'm hitting the
pawn on D5 my my ideas Ella says her I
her idea is to take the pawn but equally
the second hit is against this Pawn on
B7 well rouyang said my
uh my um analysis is to play the move
Rook A7
wow yes look at some of the big seeds
every day exactly so this was the idea
of a six movies right and if you take
the pawn on D5 I'm assuming the Queen's
dropping back and after E2 E4 I'm
assuming there's some issue here that
that could go wrong
I have to play Queen B6 right yes
because it's hanging well my king is a
little bit I'm I'm a bit concerned that
there might be some counter attack
coming uh here after a move like this
but check this out this is what Drew my
attention first you have Rook A7 but
Alice went
H3
h
4
ooh this is you don't see this very
often H4 after giving up the dark Square
Bishop she's looking at Knight G5 and
once you play H4 I can tell you that is
like a bell it says to me that she's
looking to play castles and E2 E4 and
wow right out of the opening that says
this is Hot Stuff uh Christian is it's a
is it good though this is indeed a hot
stuff and I was looking through the
variations and actually one thing that
uh I saw uh is the fact that we did out
of eight games we did with the white
pieces played four of them
he's definitely enjoying this variation
unfortunately faster from India he
actually lost three of them so he lost
three of them he won one of them with
the white pieces uh three one with the
white pieces that's not very good of
course so I pretty sure he gave it up H4
H6 is one of the options obviously you
want to play Knight to G5 this is the
idea behind the move H4 and recapture
the bishoper right that that would be
ideal because the bishop pair for black
came at the cost this Rook on A7 is a
bit misplaced and it's going to be not
that easy to get it back into the game
obviously I also have some ideas of
Queen to C2 followed by E4 as you guys
were pointing out so this one is a very
very fresh line H6 is one of the ideas
C6 is another uh one of the ideas in the
position and of course Bishop to E7 but
unfortunately I don't think for uh black
that is unfortunately I don't think
Bishop E7 is the correct answer because
now E4 comes and this aggressive move
actually gives white the advantage if
you take on e4 I will follow it up with
D5 if we start exchanging around here
unfortunately your king is going to get
extremely extremely weak and you're
going to suffer on the light squares the
light squares coupled with the fact that
the Rook on A7 is completely out of play
for the moment is going to take you a
lot of time to get it back in the game
so this one is not looking good for
black after D5
probably you have to play something like
Bishop to F5 Knight comes to D4 Central
Knight I'm bringing my pieces out with
Tempo and by the way check this out yeah
okay yeah it came in handy you cannot go
to G6 because after H5 your Bishop is
going to be trapped so it's definitely
looking like a very intriguing idea
coming from the white side we do have a
move H6 was played defending against
Knight to G5 makes a lot of sense and
immediately responded with a move Queen
to C2 which is indeed the main line it
is uh the move that was played by vidit
twice in the position with it against Le
Quang in 2021 with it against in 2021
June 21 he actually lost both of those
games but I have a feeling Alice Lee
will be coming with an improvement based
on those games we know that she is
working with somebody we don't know
exactly who she's working with but we
know uh that based on her games he's a
very or she's a very good theoretician
her coach in this situation so very
intriguing game guys Queen to C2 played
by Alice Lee you can see the focus on
her face she knows where she is she has
ideas in the position and maybe she has
surprised her young opponent my spidey
sense is tingling Anastasia I'm gonna
say that she's working with ready for it
he did it yes of course that's a good
one don't ask me how I came to that
conclusion it will remain a mystery well
speaking of videos actually yes he's
doing very well now six out of six at
the European the Europeans yes they're
winning something along the lines of 19
rating points at around the 2700 level
that's just simply ridiculous so yeah
his uh he's surging
to Magnus Carlson Magnus star Carlson
started the European Club Championship
with the draw that seemed to get a man
angry as he's gone on the 4-0 winning
streak since then turning our attention
to our other uh co-leader in the lady
section Megan Lee she's up against Anna
zatonski Anna with the white pieces uh
again this uh slav defense with E7 E6
not capturing on C4 Anna said you know
these variations Bishop G5
it's too complicated for my blood this
is this is going to be hard work this
Bob vinic upon sacrifice let me just
capture on D5 kind of like the lazy
person's way out that would be me too by
the way I've done that myself but I
usually have followed it up with Bishop
G5 I find that when I play the move
Bishop F4 I'm kind of on this uh vacated
diagonal and I don't feel that it's it's
possible let's put it that way I don't
feel it's possible to get an opening
Advantage is White against the move
Bishop F5 any Queen B3 ideas are going
to be met by Queen B6 and oc5 anymore
sometimes white wants to push C5 but no
we don't have problems it's not there
exactly you reach for it you can't find
it so I'm thinking that uh with this uh
let's say uh aggressive approach by
Megan like do you want to go into some
really complicated variations and by
docking the complicated variations
Bishop F4 I don't think Anna's really
going to get any opening Advantage mind
you she's probably looking at this
position saying I would just like to
play a very long game with you I have a
much more experience than you do uh
Megan let's play and in the open section
what do you have for us question well
I'm looking at this game between Wesley
so and Sam Shanklin the very aggressive
stance by Sam Shanklin he decided to go
with the Sicilian against Wesley in this
one maybe smelling some blood after that
loss with white from Wesley so against
Christopher you D4 was the response so
no Bishop B5 no checks we're going
straight into the open Sicilian Knight
to F6 Knight to C3 and the Knight of is
on the board A6 was played and Bishop to
E2 was Wesley's response so he's not
taking necessarily the bull by the horns
and going into uh the main very
aggressive lines after the move Bishop
to E3 right he's not even going into the
bishop G5 lines but instead he's taking
much more of a not passive but more tame
approach uh towards than either Bishop
to E2 most likely will be followed with
short Castle so we're going to get
castles on boats on the same side E5
Knight to B3 Bishop to E7 and check the
lifetime between these two whoa four
wins Wesley zero losses and nine draws
so Wesley well it definitely has Sam's
number yeah a good paying customers we
say in uh in the trade
um and Wesley right now is thinking it
seems like Sam definitely knows much
better the intricacies of this position
by the way I just have to get in a quick
comment about the game between tatev and
Sabina uh most of my life I've played
perk defense the shadow of my king side
Bishop as well as Karo Khan okay and
oftentimes I get transposition but in my
entire career
I've never seen such a good position for
black
out of both the perk defense and the
Karo Khan what am I talking about well
it started with it started with the Karo
Khan with D3 okay Sabina said well if
you're going to play passively and not
uh control the center I'm going to feed
and Shadow my Bishop once I put my
Bishop on G7 I'll be able to play the
move E7 and E5 what you're gonna do
about it Tata says well I've got a good
idea I'm going to advance my pawn and he
so she
a tortoise approach right like one step
at a time so it's like very strange
you're playing a Karo Khan perk with an
extra move yes black it's like what like
can you do that here I would I would
imagine that as white is putting so much
um the pressure in the center the most
obvious it's just amazing yeah just the
questions asking questions and I have
played many a game that has featured the
night coming to H6 and then to F7 again
putting as much pressure on this Pawn as
possible I don't know this opening
circus is this actually a variation uh
Christian I was uh actually not sorry
it's okay that one but from to my eyes
yes E5 and D4 go D3 and then D4
yeah well I mean it just felt like an
extra Tempo we'll keep an eye on that
what else do you have for us well
actually I was looking at this game
between Alexander Linderman and
Christopher you because there is a lot
of interesting stuff happening in the
opening phase of this one so we have the
Catalan very regular stuff A6 was played
so not Bishop to B4 not the usual uh
main line with Bishop to E7 but A6
getting ready to defend this Pawn on C4
and fight for the survival of his extra
Pawn with the move B5 now immediately
Castle is the main line by far
3350 something games Knight to E5 was
the move played by Alexander Lennon and
by the way he's blitzing every single
move let's take a look at what happened
Bishop to B4 the main line Knight to C3
Bishop to D2 is also an option but after
Queen takes D4 it does seem like black
uh is uh doing quite well Bishop takes
B4 Queen takes E5 and it does seem like
white has some compensation but perhaps
black uh not enough or more than just
equality now let's take a look at what
happened in the game Knight to C3 Knight
to D5 castle and Castle you can take a
few pawns
you can go Knight takes C3 and start
munching let's go Bishop takes C3 Rook
to B1 yeah sure I'll munch some more
three pawns three extra pawns but this
is actually quite a well-known variation
it does seem like he's giving white the
advantage after Queen to A4 you have to
stop that
B5 and now Queen to A3 you can take the
Knight but your Rook is hanging right
now and I don't even have to start by
taking the Rook but I can gain some more
tempies with the move Bishop to F4 white
is getting uh his pieces out get the
exchange after Bishop takes A8 and it
doesn't seem like this one uh is good
enough for a black actually you can even
start with Bishop takes E7 first I don't
have wow yes you cannot actually defend
that Rook which is quite funny you can
go Rook A7 but that allows me to get uh
the bishop and you're not castling
anytime soon that's the big problem this
queen on A3 is doing a marvelous job of
keeping the king in the center so Knight
to D5 was played castle castle not
taking the bait with Knight takes C3
Knight to E4 B5 and B3 and Alex
landerman has 1 hour and 34 minutes on
his clock number four right by far he's
blitzing out every single move putting
tremendous pressure on his young
opponent I have to say I will give Alex
uh the victory in the opening phase of
this encounter against one of the
co-leaders Christopher you yeah what a
bad attention to is that Christian now
learned from begum that he should
develop your pieces with threats you
know try it all the time to thread
something wait wait I learned from
begging yeah
[Laughter]
campus I mean his rating is
understanding especially his
understanding I'm looking everything has
stayed the same
game in three years right unchanged no
but two it was very funny yesterday when
she kept telling him he was asking her
about development yes and she also keep
kept telling that I developed with this
yes I'm trying I'm trying better it's
better it was great stuff you know like
of course you know the uh being
president of the pond grubbers uh Club I
I was tasered by that that position
where three pawns would be unhappy with
one three uh there was another one too
and again I this is all Theory no doubts
but there was even another way uh if you
were going to grab the pawn and you
didn't want to face the consequence
chances of Queen A4 check you could do
it even yet a second Way by capturing
here one of my tricky ideas
before Knight takes E2 of course you're
not playing Queen take Queen you're
probably playing Queen C2 and afternoon
no
I'll taser you again oh no Bishop takes
C3 yes I'll play E4
ah because otherwise I'm not even
looking at your Bishop I'm actually
going to go E4 whoa
how about them apples okay yeah
some sharpness stuff guys some really
sharp stuff wow it does seem like this
one favors white B takes C3 by the way
it's also an option but it's by far okay
apologies because now I'm just kind of
mesmerized by what's going on if I drop
back with the bishop you take I take you
can't you can't pick up my Bishop right
away at least I don't have to play
Knight C6 I can play C6 and then what do
you do you Checkmate me somehow all
right yeah sir get aggressive Knight
episode maybe very nice very nice
wow I'm not sure until then
you don't have to calculate it so King
thanks so it's just it's just Instinct
yes and now you've got it
I can see this you've got very good
feelings you
exactly I'm Sorry by the way when you
came into Studio were you yes
electronically a check did you pass uh
electronic devices where's your
smartphone I I've seen it around nicely
done uh that uh yeah that that answers
that question uh back over to you
Christian and again uh so many uh big
matchups but what can I say Hans Neiman
uh the toast of the Chess World uh how's
he doing with Bobby well actually he's
repeating this queen C2 line in the
nimso with the reverse colors that he
played against yesterday against Sam
Shanklin but he followed the lead of Sam
Shanklin Sam in general once again he's
considered to be one of the top
theoreticians so if he plays some things
a lot of players will follow right they
will see yeah he's been looking at this
uh maybe I should look at this as well
and try to figure out what his ideas
were so this is what we're seeing from
Hans in this one but by the way he's
playing Fabiano caruana who is also
extremely well prepared and we have a
different line after Queen to C2 Castle
A3 Bishop takes C3 Queen takes C3 D5
Bishop to G5 H6 immediately Bishop takes
F6 Knight to F3 Queen to C4 and Knight
to C6 black is immediately ready to put
a lot of pressure on D4 try to take
advantage of the fact that you haven't
finished your development on the king
side as white you still need a few moves
E3 Bishop to D3 or Bishop to E2 Castle
Hans is looking relaxed shaved he shaved
oh okay yeah it's very nice yeah he's uh
his drinking team he's drinking his
usual tea giving the Death Star to
Fabiano
wearing same jackets actually like a
jacket lucky jacket
before before you came to the round it
doesn't seem like it you're actually
thinking about the position quite early
on Fabiano right what's up with that
right can you tell us
um quick question for you uh here
Christian and again I I have no doubts
that Fabi who's really one of the best
theoreticians in the world
um
this is all a theory I mean 96 to my
eyes has a very clear and compelling
idea you you your Bishop is terrible
let's start there you just don't you
don't want to play moves like Bishop to
D7 and Rook to d8 and then move back
with the bishop the Knight is
interfering with the with the idea of C5
clear time to wait so it's all about the
move E5 where you know that's what
you're playing for it's like a kind of a
a play on one goal if you will okay now
that we know what you're up to uh I'm
just going to ask you
how easy is a Black's position going to
be as you're playing for the move E5 uh
let's say I just make a a pass uh no I
want to start with this actually Queen
to C3 I want you to play rookie eight
because he played Queen C3 he's on the
board oh okay it's also the main line
okay and I'm I'm just thinking that okay
I play E3
ah I see it already well I was going to
go E5 dv5 yeah and I was thinking yes
wow okay Chris bird
microphone I had your microphone as well
okay very nice and by the way rookie
eight so he's on the board uh yes
Anastasia called it as well I was
thinking that if I could get the Knight
to possibly step back to a very bad
Square C7 was hanging but I I caught
myself out 90 for you caught it as well
and the whole point is thanks to the
Rook being on E8 the Knight is
invulnerable
very nice okay sorry I've
interesting tell us more about the
position yes and it does seem like
honesty is probably aware also of what
he should be doing from a theoretical
standpoint in this position because
Queen to C3 is a very important move now
if you do go E3 the problem is that the
main difference between the queen on C3
and The Rook on 8 or the queen on C4 and
The Rook on f8 is that black can play
the move E5 D5 and now follow it up
right with e4n not only that you're
attacking and targeting Knight on F3 but
also the pawn on B2 you cannot do that
if the queen is on C3 and this is the
reason why you start off with Queen to
C3 which was played in the game Rook to
E8 and now we're expecting as you guys
are mentioning after E3 E5 D5 Knight to
D4 is the price you don't want to see
that on the board actually it is black
who has tremendous Advantage already
putting a lot of pressure you can never
touch this Knight because with Oracle
ne8 you're going to get killed on the E
file so don't do that please don't do
that
instead of e3 you have to prepare that
preface it with the move Rook to D1
right very important move because for
example if you go this this this this
this this Knight to D4 yes but I have a
lot more attackers on D4 so I can take
on D4 you take and I can take back
really quickly take back with the queen
I take with the Rook I don't have to
touch the E Pawn so I'm completely safe
Pawn up this is winning pretty much for
white at this point so you cannot do
that
Hans is thinking he hasn't made a move
yet Rook to D1 seems to be by far uh the
Top Choice in the position there's been
17 games 13 of them have been played
with the move Rook to D1 a lot of people
know topalo of the England is a very
recent top level game Jeffrey song
against Hikaru Nakamura is another top
level game that was played in uh this
one and also one Sam Shanklin versus
Hikaru Nakamura so definitely a lot of
top us players have been seeing this
position in their preparation and in
their games and I'm sure Hans is also
one of them uh apologies to our viewer
of course it's Fabiano is on the other
side not elshon there and we do have
surprisingly enough well no that I have
to refresh my board because maybe that's
just my analysis I think that move Rook
D1 is actually a very key move if Hans
is going to get an advantage out of this
particular A variation or not and by the
way as we're starting our broadcast we
just once again want to give a warm
shout out to you our audience thank you
so much for joining us and to invite you
to to join the discussion yesterday's
questions that we received from the
Twitter sphere were very very good uh
put us on high alerts so thank you for
that how do how can our audience join
reach us yes yes
so just first of all follow our accounts
our social media accounts please follow
Twitter account and then go to Saint
Louis chess club and you can also tag St
Louis chess club or our names our
Twitter accounts was Christian and then
you can ask any question you want I know
that there were some questions also I
think we will come back to them and we
will answer also you can check our
YouTube channel if you missed some
interviews yesterday and or the
broadcasts if you want to check
something always remember we have some
clothes YouTube channel as well
wonderful wonderful and again the the
questions from yesterday really were
excellent so keep up the good work there
we haven't seen the move uh Rook D1 by
Hans I just wanted to say that Fabiano
is at 1
30.01 so he actually has one second more
than what he started with whereas Hans
as actually consumed 15 minutes of the
first time control again let's just walk
around and see Wesley so versus Sam
Shanklin this was the I want to call it
whenever I see these Bishop E2 systems
against the Knight of I want to call
them these Geller quiet systems and the
whole idea is it's a far far more
positional approach by white what
White's trying to do is not occupy the
square D5 so much as to Simply prevent
the move D6 D5 for a long term and I
remember
many many great games being played by
Anatoly karpov on the white side of this
variation again Christopher you this
game this variation between Alexander
Lenderman
he's been snapping out his moves against
a tournament co-leader
b7b5 B3 C3 A3
Alex is looking to artificially isolate
this Pawn for example Bishop to if the
bishop were to drop back then we can
pick up that pawn without worrying too
much about B5 B4 uh maintaining it so
okay we'll keep an eye there elshon
versus Jeffrey
oh this is a nice Russell limo oh yes
with A4
okay very different
uh approach by elshon nice I'll come
back to that game darush versus Lanier
don't tell me and another
no it's not a uh a petroth I was like oh
limzo Rubenstein variation
Knight F4
um remembering games of the great Sammy
rashevsky at a top top player in the
United States he he liked these Knight
E2 Knight F4 games a lot okay
you can see and D5 will be hanging as
well as H7 so black has to play
something
it looks a little bit scary yeah the
training look at you going for the Farms
either on H5 or
h73 with a double attack against the
bishop taking a page out of Alice Lee
the queen V3 Hans we just saw it let's
jump to uh Sam sevillana and again let's
talk a little bit about Sam savian this
young man has been you know slowly
slowly moving up the ladder he's a great
talent very very early in 15 years old
he's like a generational talent and
everybody was wow he's going to be 2700.
he's made steady steady Pro progress not
the huge you know earth-shattering
breakthroughs but when he comes to the
U.S Championship he's a fierce
competitor very very tough guy to beat
and very serious player too I mean he he
works hard on his game and
he's become
really excellent excellent player yes he
needs more opportunities absolutely and
he played in the World Cup of quite
successfully I remember a few years ago
and also the fact that he shared first
place last U.S Championship shows that
his results also show his level of play
as well so he's not an easy
to play against for sure and it's no
wonder therefore that he is actually
tied for first and as Christian said
coming in coming on the show he put a
lot of pressure against the debutante
one Livonia Rooney and I like Colin
sure sure that's going to get the
lavonda a Snicker from uh Lavon what is
the position that they're playing
because to my eyes this maroxy bind with
the pawns on C4 E4 black has some issues
here it's not so easy
for black to get active counter play a
Christian I tend to agree with you uh
guys because it does seem like C5 might
be the way to go for black right now but
how do you treat Knight F5 after exactly
C5 are you going to give me your light
score Bishop I'm not sure if that's a
good idea you will have some
difficulties on the light squares
specifically that D5 Square once you
play the move C5 not only that but I'm
going to go B3 I have very easy moves
I'm going to go B3 followed by Bishop to
B2 and that Knight will have to stay on
F6 because if you do open up the long
diagonal you're going to have tremendous
problems on the G7 square and around
your king so it doesn't seem like you
have the right squares in Your Arsenal
as black right now you don't have a good
way to maneuver your pieces to the right
squares this is why I'm worried about
Black's position and you guys were
talking about Sam Seville he's working a
lot and he's working on all facets of
the games as well I've seen him in the
gym countless of times he's working he's
definitely working on his Fitness as
well and it is extremely important
especially in such a long event 13
Rounds right 13 Rounds a very very tense
encounters because you don't have any
rest this is not an open tournament
you're not going to play a player rated
300 rating points or 400 rating points
below you that you can just cruise with
no you're going to play Killers every
single round and you have to be on your
Tip Top game to be able to make a dent
in the standings and this is exactly
what this young man is doing right now
and this is how we learned that
Christian also goes to gym right right
right right right right right right
you caught me but enough about Christian
in his career what about his workouts
H7 H6 uh is that a good move because in
in some ways it's sort of like saying I
am not you know like in these kinds of
positions yeah I might be more like
tempted to play Bishop a f8 and
fianchetto the moment I play H6 I'm less
inclined to do it so I'm just pretty
surprised he plays so fast right he
didn't spend any single minute he
actually gained a minute on his clock a
Wonder Liang so
he knows maybe this he knows what he's
prepared finally no homework no homework
today I don't know I'm just saying Queen
F3 Knight F5 for Sam and I think he's
kind of cruising heavy weight matchup uh
between two Olympians
um Lavon aronian desperately needing to
get back into the event he's had three
draws has live on so is Ray Robson uh
Winds Don't Come Easy in such a such a
field and we do have
a kind of Queen's Gambit decline where
you've given up the bishop the darksword
bishop so this
um pin a little bit awkward probably G7
G5 is going to be the move that's needed
to cure this pin but Ray went with C5
and I'm assuming Lavon didn't want to
see the move C5 C4 appear on the board
he captured and this is intriguing
because I think he's trying to set a
positional threat a positional trap I
beg your pardon Knight takes B4 I'm
gonna play Queen before and you're going
to go what really yeah sir you're going
to allow me to play Knight D3 check and
you force me to take yes but now you're
you as black you're very proud of
yourself you've got this great Bishop in
the middle of the board stopping me from
castling and then I hit you with the
move Queen D4
and you go uh oh if the bishop has to
stop a step back then this double pawns
on the king side are more than offset by
the fact that I don't get to Castle but
Black's King could be uh you know
permanently damaged we saw yesterday how
close Arena crash was to check meeting
Megan Lee once she got her Knight in
that case she was black she got the
Knight to the C4 Square so that's a kind
of a positional trap but of course
there's no
Ray is under no obligation to go 93.93
probably Rook C8
possibly just simply Knight E4 I'm sure
we're still in uh Theory and I'll turn
it back to Christian and ask you what
caught your eye uh Christian I was
looking at this important matchup
between two of the co-leaders Hans
Neiman versus Fabiano caruana Fabi is
still in some sort of preparation still
hasn't spent a single minute on his
clock so take a look after Rook to D1
which was played we were discussing
about this move don't start with E3
reinforce the control over the central
D4 Square E5 was played D5 and now once
again Knight to D4 doesn't work because
that just allows me to win a pawn Knight
xd4 Queen takes D4 I have more attackers
than you have Defenders so Knight to B8
has been played 14 times already so this
is quite well known now the question is
what are you going to do and how is the
position after Bishop to E2 let's say
you have to hook this Pawn on D5 you
cannot allow the Pokemon D5 to stand on
the board because you're going to have
huge problems on the Square C7 so
eliminate that upon unfortunately you're
falling a little bit behind in
development Rook takes D5 Knight to C6
Castle Bishop to E6 this is what I'm
seeing as a very uh normal potential
development in this one but maybe
Fabiano has other ideas in mind Queen to
G6 is is also a very good move Bishop to
F5 has been played before Bishop to G4
has been played before by Hikaru
Nakamura so this one despite the fact
that we're already at move 17 has been
seen in a couple of top level games and
actually as we were discussing it did
seem like Fabiano had other ideas in
mind E3 was played and not C6 but rather
Bishop to F5 this is the wrinkle and we
know that Fabiano will be coming with
new fresh ideas every single time he
goes uh and plays a game and this is the
one wrinkle that maybe Hans didn't have
in his notes Bishop to F5
thank you
the training is working it's so good yes
yes yes yes yes a question has been
asked is the pawn you can capture yes
yes it's definitely capture questions
if you don't see a refutation and you
I'm going to you got to send an olive
branch after Queen takes E7 I'm going to
go 97. don't take my Pawn on B7 no that
that that one that's the cookie jar no I
don't want to get hands caught there but
Bishop wrong the best move is Queen
takes B7 you see
I tricked you here oh you dirty I
tricked you I was afraid of Rook B8 yes
as an answer I didn't want to see The
Rook land on my B8 Queen C6 something
along those lines right and then the
Rook lands on and I thought this was
compensation you definitely have enough
compensation yes yes yes but if you
leave uh the pawn on B7 has wall blacks
will still have compensation because
Rook is coming to C8 the night is coming
actively to C5 or even B6 but probably
C5 because I'm looking at those light
squares that I have control because of
my Bishop is on F5 right right now so I
have a lot of ideas in the position what
I would be worried that hunts as hunts
is that Fabiano is blitzing out yes
that's a problem right and I remember
vividly this game between chakra
mediarov and Fabiano Carona at the same
field cup a couple of weeks ago and
Fabiano was blitzing out he actually
played that whole game from his homework
notes and uh barely chakra with
Incredible moves surviving Jesus
and giving back the queen yeah he said
it's better to be I think with
Pawn down than with extra queen against
the preparation of your opponent it
sounds like this like it's better not to
have this extra Queen yeah well and also
shaqueria said something like uh
Fabiano's preparation was met by
mamidara's defense
okay just a second Queen take yeah he
played Bishop E2 and the Seven
immediately played yeah the sedate move
but once again Queen takes C7 Knight D7
Bishop B5 now the difference in this
case is if you go Rook C8 that's a bad
move Queen takes B7 now I've I've
actually uh benefit uh with the bishop
probably you will play Rook on E8 to C8
okay and again I'm kind of reluctant to
grab this Pawn although I I didn't see a
refutation yeah
ah Knight C5
Queen A5 it's
is this upon or isn't it it's not good
it's not good in in big trouble after
Knight C5 Knight C5 I'm in big trouble
well
decent trouble
how big it is yeah zero zero point whoa
and uh very important to be relaxed you
know you take off your shoes wait yeah
you you set yourself up nice and comfy
basically using like a yoga pose what is
he doing
uh feed up underneath the chair we're
getting a bit comfortable with the
players right now can we take again well
it's really awkward if you bring your
slippers into play Oh Sam yes
no didn't expect that either I'm still
intrigued that uh Bishop E2 wow look I
mean Fabi shopping Castle Rook C8
everything is glancing out his moves 27
seconds from the from the moment they
they started the game so Bishop E2 very
natural natural cautious but
97 castles Rook C8 okay it's quite
obvious that uh Fabi has uh C6 on his
agenda but
it isn't it isn't it going to be uh
dangerous that this Pawn could go to the
D6 Square let's say I make a move let me
make a move what's a good move Queen B4
idea of course to grab one more one pawn
and maybe on a good day also play evil
ah you've got Queen B6 I would probably
challenge you there yeah
Queen B6 and I don't have time to play
E4 oh that's a pity
um and if you come back maybe Knight the
C5
yes yes yes yes Queen D2 Knight C5 uh
let me try a little bit of a tricky uh
move for a moment 92 idea of E4
yeah
D6 now uh by the way if you make a a
non-descript move you could find
yourself in a world of hurt very quickly
I had I had actually uh some ideas let's
say of making a pin but of course you
would play C6 right okay and then my
idea was like go ahead and try to win
this Pawn this Pawn on D6 if it lives
it's going to be very very very
unpleasant so I'm hoping to trick you
with takes takes and
Fork although I must admit I have to
confess Bishop H3 is possible
it's possible three E4 yes or what yeah
yes yeah yes oh boy so this is what we
do is we calculate these crazy
variations right well I think you can
just take only four yeah I take on e4
and take that too much yeah if you take
I could take on e4 and take on H3 and
the game continues right
night is coming to E5 there's some
checkmating threats exactly lurking
lurking
Knight F3 maybe King F2 and you have
some doing okay
Advantage way
after all of these lines uh I was trying
to keep the pawn alive uh on D6 let's
try it differently so c66 and now maybe
go E4
yeah I thought about before even before
but inviting a Trader Queens but I'm not
interested in trade Queens I'm still
hunting uh knight uh B2 is hanging uh in
this case
maybe I'm not hunting very well uh okay
if we get a position like this a
Christian
uh asset or liability that's a good
question yeah it's it's very difficult
to quantify that but let's take it move
by move right uh let's go Rook d8 Rook
C8 DH sure yeah I don't have anything
else to do on the C file anymore I'm
looking at my own Pawn Knight C5 yes
and I'm trying to maintain this fella
and maybe so what if I no Knight to E6
probably you're just going to go back to
D2 yes
yeah interesting position we'll
definitely keep an eye on uh this uh key
matchup
some Twitter yes we're ready just a
second let's get our thinking caps on ah
okay this is a question for me okay best
yes ask me would I would love to hear
from an Elastica on how she started
playing chess Bravo oh that's a question
did you learn to play the game um I I
think I started to play like a ditch of
eight nine something like that okay but
the funny thing is that some years later
like when I was already grown up girl I
remembered that first time I let's say
noticed chess as a game was when I was
like five six years old and I was
watching this movie If Tomorrow Comes by
Sydney Sheldon and in that movie the
main actress she's playing she made a
trick a very nice trick she was playing
against two players but in fact they
were playing against each other right
yes and I was like very small and I was
watching kept watching that movie many
many times and I was so I mean happy to
see the scene that she was she made a
bed that she will win she will make one
out of two no matter what and then she
won this bet of course how can you lose
it if you play against they play against
each other yes right in the yacht I
think it was somewhere there was a big
ship and they were playing on different
levels so she would just go and and show
those moves uh perform those moves so I
think this scene probably was really
impressive for me and later on when I
started to play Chess at the age of like
eight nine in one of this I just started
in normal school and we had this extra
lesson of Chess I don't know I just
continued and then I started to go
attend to normal school we had let me
just interrupt you yes you talk about
the the chess in the school was it a
part of you was it a necessary
requirement class or it was accidental
yes
but but we had we had those classes in
different schools and just I was lucky
that we had it in my school so and then
I think I was the funny thing was that
maybe like about 200 people kids pass
through this class and I was the only
one who later continued continued in the
chest cold yes I continued this and I
used to come and play in this you know
um kind of kind of Soviet let's say
chess club so it was uh
um like a really big chess fans who
would come every Sunday to play this
rapid events 15 minutes events and this
was my practice I would just keep coming
on Sundays like I don't know why I was
doing it nowadays you have so many
different things to do on Sundays right
and that time
were you successful early because
sometimes you get very disappointed you
you lose a game and it's it's crushing
you just can't recover but were you
successful early so that you continued a
lot of people getting discouraged yeah I
was not actually that much I must tell
you that I was not from those
everyone no no no it's not the story
about me but what I remember that one of
the biggest successes I had when I was
like 15 or 14 I won the Regional
Championship for men let's say it was
considered Open Championship where and
the funny thing was that even my coach
was playing there Grandmaster Goodman
and he was third I think and that was
first so I wasn't I was ahead of you
grid Masters I didn't consider like a
big success but now I understand that
actually it was really it was it was big
at that time like at the age of 15 like
then I started to study law and there
was not so much focused nimor but that
that was I think the biggest success
which I had did you consider pursuing a
career professionally or it was maybe
your parents encouraged your school
first yeah how was that yeah it was like
I tried to combine seems like some
players who who played in this
tournament yes like I tried to study
well and also I play Chess at the same
time was Ukrainian champion on the teen
you know and we had so many good players
at the time
yes it was fun nice thank you for the
question I'm learning all about you now
I mean eight years old I were expecting
more come on come on what is this one
more question from uh the Twitter sphere
that is a tie-dye shirt and I remember
that was I don't know what I still have
to do it look at the hair by the way
yeah so this is impressive yes there it
is yeah oh my gosh this is from the
Washington State Championship that was
the open so it's like 1976 uh one of the
Washington State Championship and I had
gone uh later to fill out a application
for the University of Washington in
Seattle
Admissions and it was something like 2
570 dollars for a semester yeah
and I I was filling out the form of this
application and uh and I don't know what
came over me but I put in in the form
that I was also the champion of
Washington state for all ages and the
person that took my application said oh
Washington state champion very nice that
in
2570 will get you in class I was like
you know now you get a full scholarship
you get to go and have Christian uh
teach you how to develop your pieces uh
exactly and they pay so what's it like a
short yes yeah it was a good shirt yeah
yeah yeah a similar Style no well I I
mean his tutorial Splendor I'm not even
close to what Lavon I I I don't know I
mean I might have got in my day they
might have tossed you out of the
tournament
they expected ties what about your tie
and lemons shorts I mean we can go I
mean this is uh according to Christian
my Cobra tie I got my Cobra tie on I'm
ready I'm ready to party I mean this is
good this is good Christian we're having
too much fun what do you have for us in
the Hans Neiman game what I don't have
is a cobra type
but I was actually looking at some uh
some lines in this game obviously
Fabiano very well prepared but there are
still three games in this one one in
particular uh is between brown Eric
Brown Grandmaster from Germany as well
as zvane who is also a grand master from
Germany this big battle actually ended
after Bishop it didn't end but it gave
black quite a nice Advantage Bishop to
B5 was played in that one you have to
attack the bishop get it out force it to
trade for the Knight on D7 Bishop takes
D7 and now you have to do something you
have to relocate your knight because the
Knight on F3 will get pinned if you give
me one more chance to get Bishop to G4
so you have to start with Bishop Knight
to D2 also you're trying to reroute the
Knight where are you going probably to
C5 if you can go Knight E4 Knight to C5
and put some pressure on the B7 and A6
pawns then your position is most likely
going to be favorable not only that but
whenever you land with the Knight on C5
whenever black plays the move C6 I will
play the move D6 and the Knight on C5 is
going to be a great uh supporter of that
pawn on D6 supporting it to go to D7 and
get closer to promotion you cannot allow
the Knight to get to C5 by the way guys
I think we do have as we were speaking
the first the novelty in this game not
Bishop to a B5 but the move A4
this is an interesting one Let's uh have
a look and see Fabiano's reaction is he
going to Blitz out his move or did this
move quite a surprise
I think the reaction was uh this is news
to me let me
enjoy my tea exactly and break that move
down
the levels the discrepancy between the
levels of tea between hansisti which is
empty and Fabiano
now he's going to be thinking it's a
very long time
get closer to hans's levels there's a
hidden message there the psychology
there
could be a movie
and it also has his tea bag I love the
way he put his teeth down now you're
bothering me now it's too hot okay uh
we'll keep an eye on that I just wanted
to go to the game of Wesley so and Sham
Sam shankland again this was a very
positional
approach that that Wesley took
against the nidor of h2h3 and it's
strange it's like it give white just a
few little moves what he would what
white would really like to do is go
rookie to Rook D2 why is that so
important what is it what's up with that
maneuver why would you want to transfer
the Rook to D2 two reasons once again
it's all about controlling the move the
square pardon me D5 you do not want to
see black playing the move D5 trading
everything off and then black will
easily equalize maybe even be better the
next thing is once the Rook is undo to
controlling the square D5 you've
protected the square C2 what does that
mean with the Rook on D2 protecting the
pawn on C2 it means the Knight can move
it's really that simple if simple for
you the if I move the night immediately
the pawn on C2 will get bitten and so
recognizing that it's incumbent upon him
to do something you can't just let white
improve black is
you might say he's achieved everything
he's all developed like like you know
you can go down how are you feeling good
good good good good good
not so good but good good good good good
so it's not like black can makes a move
that radically improves his position he
could move his King white has a lot of
move so that is why we see the move B5
and now we understand why the pawn went
to B5 we can go amp us on improving our
structure a little bit and we understand
this Knight is going to land on C4 it
will be tremendous
Knight A5 stopping the night and
remember a moment ago I said how are you
feeling I'm not so good
ah thank you very much much better much
much better and we see this uh
strategical fight now A Move Like rookie
2 gets met by Knight C4 Knight takes C4
Bishop takes C4 Rook to D2 and haha
phone it wasn't uh it wasn't hanging a
moment before but now that the Rook goes
to B8 it is hanging so it by this uh
very I want to say crafty move order for
black
he's denying white the opportunity of
playing Rook to E2 to D2 now Wesley has
to change plans just as Sam was forced
to as well and back over to you and the
game of Christian Christopher you a
Christian uh we gave a little love
earlier to Sam sevion but after this I
want you to show the very nice finish
that Christopher you had from round
three he sacrificed his Queen we didn't
get a chance to highlight that nice
finish we can get to that in just a
second but let's first see where
Christopher you is landing today right
because it's not looking good oh I have
to say he might actually just be lost
right now take a look at what happened I
think we left it somewhere around here
putting some pressure on C4 opening up
discussion are you going to take on B3
and allow me to get the queen to B3 with
a lot of pressure on your pieces after
that I'm going to move my Bishop away go
Rook to C1 I have tremendous pressure on
both the B and the C files so plenty of
compensation for the last Pawn
Christopher said no I'm going to go C3
but take a look at this and this has
been played in a recent games actually a
recent game between Bogdan Daniel that
from Romania my compatriot and Max
sudulu Parham uh Queen to C2 that was
played in that game 2021 uh September of
that year and it's definitely a new game
it's definitely a game that has been
analyzed and Alex is showing that he
analyzed an improved on that game he
played the move A3 this is novelty in
the position Bishop to E7 and now Queen
to E1 yeah so we checked out
C3 and one guys it's all about the
development what he should have done
Christopher is just developed the piece
Bishop to B7 allow white to take on C3
you're going to lose that part right no
matter what you do you're going to lose
that ball don't try to save it use the
time that's been given by whites hunt
for the pawn on C3 to develop your
pieces right Knight xc3 Knight to D7 and
try to play this game finally you have
C5 coming in the position it looks
pretty decent for black it's not as bad
as the game continuation he played the
move B4
white says sure thank you I'll take that
pawn thank you very much I'll open up my
Rook uh that's an extra Pawn as well if
you want to take back I'm going to go
Knight to D3 I can also just simply
exchange the dark Square Bishops with
the move Bishop to A3 why is it
favorable for why to exchange this uh uh
Bishops because this Knight is going to
land on C5 once you don't have control
of that square C5 with your Bishop I'm
going to land with an either and then
that's going to make life very difficult
for your own night as well to get out
into the game and finish the development
so you're in trouble
F6 was Christopher's decision Knight to
D3 still eyeing the square C5 it's all
about that one Knight to C6 this is what
we have right now but I'm trying to
understand what if I just simply
continue taking your Pawn
right I take C3 you are up upon now I'm
up upon the white respawn on D4 just to
check which one good for you yeah
okay and now Knight to F4 I'm targeting
this guy if you do go Bishop to B7
whoops I have some problems with E6 I
attack your knight somehow Queen to C3
Queen to D1 Queen to D1 seems to be the
best way Knight to B5 Knight to E6
resignation it's painful that's the
resignation time it's game over pretty
much so you don't have that option so C6
if that's the case yes C6 of course but
your pieces are so clumsy this Knight is
defending the pawn on C6 if you move it
I pick up on C6 not only that but I'm
also going to pick up on D5 because you
have to defend in the meantime they're
gonna need everything is falling in
Black's position it's like dominoes
right now the pawns The Rook on A8 is
not looking pretty this is completely
winning for white so so what to do guys
from the starting position one more time
Knight takes C3 yes wow uh this is and
it's a pretty really easy right then I
have to take on B4 Knight takes B4
1966. this Knight takes you B4
completely losing boom night takes
E4 let's go
okay I gotta go back no choice where is
C3
and I just had like the ugliest Pawn
structure ever right it's it's you have
some big problems yes also have Bishop
to a three coming potentially changing
the Bishops and then getting the Knight
to C5 positional Overkill you look at
the pieces whose pieces are better
obviously whites whose structure is
better obviously why look at the time
how is it the time I mean Alex is
catching up but he's catching up on in a
winning position right that's more
pleasant very very very nice and we
promised our uh viewers that the uh
finish of yesterday's game elshon
uh was the victim of Christopher you
Christopher you by the way is
three games three decisive games yes he
got disrespected from the first yeah I'm
very angry and then he won two in a row
including a victory as black over Wesley
so elshon Victory you've got the the
final position well about to be final
position on your board Christian I do
have the fight it's a nice uh finish it
is indeed it's a very nice very
professional finish F5 well let's take
it back a couple of moves Queen to age
six yes
ah Queen takes H2 you cannot allow that
on the board H4 very beautiful defense
F5 and now the killing blow sure I can
go Rook to C7 try to go B7 and pick up
at the piece but guess what I can pick
it up in one moment wow sacrifice the
queen and actually after Rook takes A8
B7 there's no way to stop C7 your queen
is now very far away from the action
you're not going to be able to get back
in time to defend against the promotion
with B8 I'm going to get my own queen
I'm going to be a piece of not only that
but you're probably also getting
checkmated a very nice finish by
Christopher in that game against elshon
and a shout out to uh Maurice our good
friend he pointed out this nice Queen
sacrifice because we didn't catch it on
the live broadcast I believe it was
great that he actually so it means yes
he's he's like trying to get better you
know he's working on his game you know
he understands you know Christian is
great coach you know could improve him
by the way Alex Linderman did not play
the prescribing the night on e4 take C3
he said you know what that pawn the
Anastasia that you and I both wanted to
take yes with relish uh Knight takes uh
D4
I mean E2 E3 but does that move spoil
the advantage for him it spoils some of
the advantage I'm still finding this
position extremely difficult and painful
to play with the black pieces I
understand this movie three because
right now if you continue with your
typical development Bishop to B7 I have
both my Knights ready to jump to C5 so
one of them is going to go to C5 that's
going to put a lot of pressure on your
position you cannot do that so he's just
waiting to see that's what black is
going to do I think also he created this
thread B5 now yes before Knight D4 was
possible now correct he actually
protected his pawn and he wants to play
before oh it's it's an immediate media
yeah he takes D4 would be a
H
not recommended so E2 E3 uh with the
idea V5 that was why you were thinking I
you you better take this Pawn before
before it's too late right Knight takes
B4 and uh where does it all go from here
I assume assume would take and I've got
it so if the bishop takes again Bishop
based three idea of which Christians
shoulder exactly that's the best here no
it looks good I mean there's no way that
this Pawn is going to survive and when
white does Recapture it again we're
going to be seeing a lot of black pawn
weaknesses in the position A6 E7 E6 uh
Advantage Linderman uh right out of the
opening for sure and again I'm just
going to make a quick check oh look at
these what's going on here we left the
game Lavon peronian versus Ray Robson we
took on C5 ah
at G5 because I I had showed one line
where the queen could nicely come to the
D4 square and we take on F6 G5
Knight D4 or things are getting hot but
I'm I'm absolutely confident that this
is all uh theoretically
um I think it's known I don't know if
it's normal so much as it's a
theoretical discussion I mean look at
the pieces that are hanging uh the
bishop is hanging the bishop is hanging
the queen is hanging and I'm assuming
after a move like Queen A3 now the
Knight will be hanging as well uh
we the only thing not on on pre are are
the Kings they're not in check
help clear our cobwebs uh with the Lavon
Ray Robson game because well I I know
it's a theoretical battle but what's
going on uh so what was the move that
you guys were right well we just saw 93
Knight takes C5 we're anticipating Queen
A3 Queen B5 is the move anyway Queen B5
is okay he played it oh this is still
Theory look okay this game has been
played three more times three the most
recent one uh companion versus Mercado
from 2021 I would assume that's a
correspondence game okay um I have not
heard about this player's Queen to B5
attacking the Knight on C5 obviously you
have to defend it you probably don't
want to take on H4 because I'm going to
take either the bishop 0.5 either Knight
on C5 I think you actually might be in
some sort of danger with the black
pieces in this one so don't take on H4
Knight to E4 seems to be the best way
forward
it's a game it's a game guys Knight
takes F5 a lot of things are hanging I
understand that but still black has a
lot of compensation due to the fact that
you haven't canceled yet you still have
the weakness on C3 which if I do take
you're going to be in trouble if I
manage to get uh to C3 with my queen
that's why Queen to F6 seems to be the
right starter in the position Knight to
D4 I'm going to pick up the pawn uh the
bishop on H4 and this is just simply
going to be a game moving forward
last position that you had why was an F3
winning a piece
F3 at this point yeah Knight takes C3
Queen takes C5 yeah Rook C8 I have
enough compensation
no
no of course not and this is the reason
why he actually didn't play it yes
nobody it's like you see that if Queen
moves the Knight takes E2 even you
cannot take with it and it's actually
slow compensation I'm going to go uh
rookie 8 next move take advantage of the
fact that you play the move F3
and if you go here I'm going to go
Knight very difficult to see and if you
don't know the position from home
probably very difficult to calculate so
what he did he actually played the move
Queen to C8 and the question comes what
if I just simply take this one right I
take back I take back you take back
right
or structure but once I get my queen to
D4 so nicely centralized this Pawn on H4
is suffering for a moment
I tend to give a pretty decent advantage
to White at this point wow it just goes
to show that uh the um depth of opening
knowledge that's required because I
looked at that position I saw an extra
piece and I was like I didn't think I
didn't it wasn't intuitively obvious to
me that it was zero zero zero uh you
have to know it's what you were doing
you got to know your stuff tell us about
our friends at Q Boutique and what uh
What uh discounts uh friends and family
discounts yeah five ten percent five
percent right okay what's the special
for today yeah we have today a Champs um
button up dress short for men and women
so you can just wear it and improve your
game immediately immediately worth at
least 20 rating points yes so the
comfortable blend of cotton polyester
and spandex features long sleeves and
comes in both for men and women's sizes
the embroidery yes Chef's logo on the
front and the embroidery Saint Louis
chess club log on the back nice and it's
available in puberty shop you can also
come here and find it in the shop
worldchester Hall of Fame absolutely yes
exactly looks like a very nice shirt I'm
gonna check my swag bag I think I got it
but I want to just double it yes I want
to double check I want to make sure that
I you know you start to play better yes
exactly I feel more confident more
relaxed take off my shoes I'll be in
great shape and as we go on break we're
going to leave you with a feature we
asked Our Ladies what's it like being
back in St Louis playing in these U.S
championships see on the other side of
the break nice
[Music]
what's your favorite part about the U.S
championships being held here in St
Louis I always love playing in St Louis
I always love the hospitality that Rex
and Genie provide for the players and I
always like to come back and to see my
friends at this tournament specifically
it's always really well organized and
runs really smoothly and the players are
always um really nice and fun to hang
out with
I think this time in Saint Louis is very
beautiful I I love walking around and
full time is one of my favorite Seasons
we have a lot of trees around so I love
being in Saint Louis in October I like
how we get treated in sunlords it feels
like home and we get a lot of respect
from the club and all the employees so
it's just a nice feeling to play in a
place where chess is appreciated it's
always amazing to have the tournament
here in St Louis especially since I live
here anyways when I go to St Louis
University I'm very excited to play the
U.S Championship again it's always a
very tough competition and you do get to
see a lot of players that maybe you
haven't seen in a long time and
especially the school I feel like a lot
of players especially the younger ones
tend to be very busy so it's just a very
good task for yourself and to see how
you're doing chest wise I really like
the atmosphere here and like like the
entire city just feels like super
friendly well it's like a really special
thing for me to kind of come back here
because I haven't played um like an
in-person U.S Championship since 2019
um so it's been a few years it's also
the year that I won so it's like kind of
a really strange experience to be back
because it feels like it's been such a
long time
um but I just really love like you know
the chance to play against the top
people in the country and like it's
always such a great experience playing
St Louis in general you know with
commentary and like the play menu it
feels great this is my 14th year I
haven't skipped anyone ever since the
tournament's been taking place in San
Luis it's exciting I did not expect to
be invited once again because I've had
these terrible years of playing and I've
focused a lot of com on commentary and
things but it's great to be back I'm
very excited to play it back over the
board and hopefully it will be a good
tournament I always joke and so maybe if
it's not Saint Louis I already would
stop playing chess it gives me
motivation it's gift like it's wonderful
how organizers treat people and for me
it's also important I like playing chess
like together with the strongest or
players and I like to compete and this
is very difficult to determine just one
small part be it in Saint Louis this is
like second home definitely for me and
I've been here many times
I enjoy being here all the time and this
is just like favorite favorite place to
play chess there's so much chess here I
like I've been here before it's not my
first time here but every time I'm in St
Louis I'm bombarded with chess
everywhere there's like there's a huge
chest piece and like a giant a
chessboard with like giant chess pieces
outside of the World Chess Hall of Fame
there's chess boards like in the hotel
that I'm staying at even like the the
really nice wooden ones there's like
flyers everywhere too and just the
promotion of Chess everywhere I see and
it feels so good to be bombarded with
chess it feels like inspiration
for the actual chest that I'll be
playing in this tournament and it just
it really gets me pumped up honestly I
mean I like the playing chess part of
the US championships for sure I mean
it's like the competition I enjoy uh the
camaraderie as well and like all of our
uh evening dinners with Rex and just
seeing like all the St Louis people
again
um we have the commentators and my
friends here
well I really like obviously all the
events hosted by the St Louis jazz club
uh one thing that I'm really excited
about is to be playing against all these
strong players like many of these
players have been my Idols for many
years and they still are so it's really
cool to be getting the plane against
them the people are like really nice and
and yeah like enjoy all the playing Hall
um you know the places like the food
around here it's always a good
experience I think U.S championship in
San Luis is my absolute favorite event I
always love coming back here
um just the chess club and people who
work around the tournament everything is
just so wonderful
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and welcome back to round four of us
championships we have current standings
they haven't changed that much since
they startled around exactly the results
as far yes so Ellis Lee and Megan Lee
bottled them are leading
um the hydronova baby and also patio
Abraham and Jennifer you they share the
third place with two points each and in
the open section and in the open section
we have four co-leaders Pagano caravanas
Sam Seville and Christopher you Hans
Neiman all of them have two uh points
out of three and a chasing pack of
wolves with a 50 score of one and a half
out of three uh let's just pick up uh
some of the games are really heating up
uh I was very curious to see how Lanier
was going to defend his in the position
against darush when darush played the
move at night F4 we were both very
strongly attracted to the idea of Queen
H5 Lanier ignored the threat said go
ahead head I'm going to play Knight C6
attacking the pawn and darsh simply
defended the pawn and that's fine no
problem with that move but it did you
know you do of course you have to ask
this question like well what would have
happened if I had gone all in on the
king side with the move Queen H5 could I
have essayed a potential peace sacrifice
or even a double peace sacrifice don't
ask me twice to do it but I think rookie
seven defends everything yes problem
that was the problem
yes and so instead what we did have we
had Bishop E3 Bishop dtd6
I think we've all understood that Knight
takes D5 can be met by Bishop takes the
H2 uh famous discoveries that we've all
lost our Queen to by the way myself
included and how funny that uh darusha's
White didn't get in Queen H5 whereas no
and that's the current situation in this
game we had been following very closely
the game of Hans Neiman and Fabi and
this was more or less where I was going
not necessarily with the move a2a4 but
really a384 pardon me but asking the
question when you play the move C6 I
want to play D6 I was trying ideas with
Knight D2 Han started with A4 A4
unexpected maybe he was intimating okay
maybe I want to run rush the pawn up the
board C6 D6 and well I assume he's
achieving what he his goal is to make it
as awkward as possible for uh black to
win this Pawn on on
D6 one of the ideas maybe he had it
might seem at first blush that it's a
good idea to put the Knight on D5
because then The Rook can't
attack it yes but then we kind of start
to understand why the a pawn is on A4 as
we do have ideas
of uh playing A5
um interesting what happened in terms of
the time by the way because Bobby was
playing yes super fast until A4 until he
decided to drink some tea yes tea break
yes tea break and after tea break I
think they played C6
um I cannot see so close 41 minutes and
one hour and 11 minutes and Counting
right now for Fabian half an hour
difference so something like a 15 minute
thing on C6 yes
something like okay so C6 came after
more or less a 15-minute thing and then
came
probably very quickly because you played
A4 not okay I didn't really think V6
came after another 15 minutes another
15. yes and I asked the I posed the
question before asset or liability what
says the engine
um it does seem like it might become a
liability right now and the big question
is how about rookie six yeah how are you
going to defend that pawn on these six
after the simple Rook to E6 and the
engines find a very interesting line
Knight to D2 okay now if you allow me to
go Knight to C4 now we understand also
why that pawn is quite useful on uh A4
you don't have ideas of P5 or at least
they're not coming as easily uh if you
do take on T6 though now I will go Queen
to B4
with a double thread Knight to E4 and
take on B7 Knight to E4 wins an exchange
and probably the game Queen takes B7 uh
invades in your position and maybe it's
going to give you some headaches along
the way so this is what the computer is
recommending right now with a very
complicated position and instead of that
Fabiano says no I'm not going to go for
the pawn well maybe I will but I will
later on I'm just going to set up my
pieces on their ideal squares and that
is my Recon CA that wasn't really doing
much I'm going to put it on d8 I like
that move
yep
yeah complicated yeah but but I think so
much is the you know like one of those
positions you know very hyper dependent
upon each and every Tempo
um in this position I'm well okay can we
pursue uh some variations for just a
moment sure let's suppose
Queen B4 just asking the question would
you like to move your Rook or would you
like to play B6 well perhaps I can take
advantage of the consequences of your
last move Queen to B4 and that is uh you
no longer after E4 have the opportunity
to exchange the Queens also after A4 you
don't have to move Knight D4
that's key because I have the move C5
the queen on B4 is not well placed and
you're going to lose a piece so I think
I'm going to go E4 and you might have
some problems here uh just continue
first night potentially Knight to B6
night and this was the kind of question
that I was asking that or maybe even B6
yeah maybe you put your knight on D5 but
uh I'll trade the D6 Pawn for the D7
pawn and maybe at the end of the day
your structure will be a little bit weak
sorry did you like maybe B6 first B6
first and again I my knight well no just
don't think you can take that but you
can definitely go to C4 right yes
Knight C4 and maybe Knight E5 Knight E5
and again uh by the way A5 was played
none of what it is I was thinking about
this move not to give this chance to
play Knight B6 or maybe 56 is also not
possible yes in this position because
she's six is weak by the way by the
engine quickly played A6 uh white has a
thread yes E5 A6 and give me the pawn on
C6 that would be a great trade for white
is is Fabi obliged in this case then to
play A6
uh I don't think so does maybe A6 and
you never have that B6 move anymore
right so your structure capture on B7
after all these ideas of Queen to B4
A6 is also hanging right it's going to
be a very huge weakness yeah also I have
ideas of potentially rerouting my knight
to C4 so I think A6 is not particularly
good in this case maybe even 65 now
Queen to B4 or maybe yeah Queen to P4
seems to be good in that position so
you're saying black should not play A6
no no no and the recommendation would be
E4 or what would be the record perhaps
Rook 36 right to go for the pawn Rook to
E6 going for the pawn
I'm warming up to White's positions me
too yeah maybe there are some ideas with
not B8 after B takes six quizzes I don't
know it seems crazy I I see what you're
I see what you're saying no you do make
a discovery yes
it looks funny but let's pursue this
okay so Queen C7
Winchester seven book takes D6 yeah
of course I don't want to give my knight
oh so maybe it's holdable so what if I
take on a holdable for sure but the
question is do I have an advantage right
that's what it's all about is let's take
that pawn on A7 yes you take the bond
but what about the bones now we have the
same amount right correct yes slightly
weak slightly weak and rookie well not
immediately I get down get back rank uh
made it but sometimes yeah some some
okay very very interesting uh besides
this game which is unfortunately taking
over our show
what other uh games in the open section
uh caught your eye I'm gonna check out
the ladies the the Ray Robinson well Ray
Robson with the black pieces against
Levon aronian that one is quite
intriguing and a lot of things have
happened actually they were following
the lines that we were projecting uh
Knight takes F5 after Queen to C8 take
take on H4 Queen to D4 centralized the
queen makes a lot of sense we know that
Levon is a very cultured individual how
to centralize he knows how to develop
his pieces he's a good player castle
Rook 28 Rook to B1 and I really like
what Rey is doing as well he's looking
for his own counter chances I understand
you're playing Bishop versus knight in a
fairly open uh position probably the
bishop is going to be preferred right
you have a weakness on H4 sure that's a
big problem as well but I can use this
weakness to potentially uh make your
life uncomfortable around the king side
after the move H3 so what he's trying to
do with the move Rook to E8 is also
include his Rook into the attack with
Rook to E4 I think this is a very
Salient Point that he's making Ray
Robson that is Rook to B5 I'm expecting
something along along the lines of Rook
to E4 you can also start with the move
H3 first G3 and then Rook to E4 and
we're going to see something
like this I will go I don't know about
Rook to B8 Rook to ba seems to be a bit
awkward to my eyes at least and I'm
trying to understand why the engine is
recommending Rook to EA to my eyes king2
G7 makes a lot of sense just to put the
King on dark Square I feel it's quite
well protected I would assume there's
some ideas with Bishop to F3 and taking
advantage of the fact that this pin is a
bit annoying this is the idea yeah C4
yes yes yes and I cannot take of course
because the queen is hanging but also if
you take and the queen wouldn't be
hanging I also have Bishop F3 right with
the Rook on A8 and securing these two
Rooks so still some problems for uh
black but definitely black also has his
own counter play so this one is
definitely going to develop into an
engaging middle game nice uh just uh
going over to the ladies section for a
moment picking up the game between Alice
Lee and Rooney gang when we left it we
had seen this cagey little move by Alice
Queen C2 intimating that she's ready to
break in the center E2 E4 and at the
same time uh Castle long so that she
would be able to play D4 D5 on any
captures after Queen C2 97 go ahead do
your worst said Rue Yang okay E4 takes
takes uh
nice uh yes very serious threat indeed
Knight D7 Queen E3 funny little move
right like you you don't often see
there's rookie Savage like uh pay
attention uh D5 and uh will be a double
attack Knight G4 Queen E2 C7 C6 through
Yang respecting the threat of D4 D5 uh
winning a piece
still different
Alice will not be denied it takes Knight
D4 hello yes ideas of uh smack and
smacks Knight had to drop back ooh look
at this we don't even recapture our Pawn
right away but Alice says you know what
I'm gonna castle
and I am going to is she going to play
F4 that's the question no okay so first
things first uh maybe bishop takes A3 in
Queen takes C3 is a slight threat so she
sidestep that with the move Bishop
resize that Bishop takes A3 that would
probably be by Rook C1 and have we
caught up we have indeed Alice is on the
Rampage she sacrificed upon and she's
looking at on two occasions
she could have recaptured the pawn with
Knight takes E6 followed by Queen takes
E6 she issued at both times and now the
question is
what would have happened after Bishop E7
yeah that's a good question because if
if I also if black will manage to Castle
then it's fine
is not so bad anymore seven next move
exactly so you have to be fast you have
to do something with white if you want
to prove that you have any kind of
Advantage agreed agreed or maybe you
have to create maybe some kind of attack
with F3 g45 using the fact that black
still needs to finish his development
and now before immediately exactly yes
well it looks amazing intriguing Pawn
Sacrifice by one of our co-leaders let's
go to the other co-leader Megan Lee is
uh with the black pieces against Anna
zatonski I'm seeing a lot of Queen's
Gambit declines Carlsbad structures in
the games of the ladies were just also a
reading Crush yeah Everybody Plays the
Queen's
and again the very standard fare I want
to say for these
variations
usually you throw in and move like a7a5
just to be sure that there's no minority
attack then it's all about rookie eight
and fighting for the control over the E4
Square all right let's just see just a
second that was a game yes this was the
other one I mentioned
I like Arena space she's got space on
the king size yeah ending B4 Rook C1
Rook C3 she could get an advantage on
the other hand of shritha is fast enough
to play 94 and C5 she will equalize the
game I wanted to go to the game of Tata
and Sabina because I felt that tata's
Victory yesterday for me tatv's a very
streaky player she can put two together
a number of wins and equally when things
go wrong
it's a tumble it's a tumble this was the
Karo Khan slash perk slash I don't know
what do you even call it uh F6 cc4 okay
wow she's trying to let's go play
Dynamic chess right she certainly
achieved that with Queen B3 and now it
looks like just a French defense some
kind of a tarish uh French defense where
black has already gotten in her Central
break with F6 should be decent for black
I want to say but I would prefer to play
it with white why because I don't know
I'm thinking about some H5 ideas I mean
you like the initiative yes initiative
it looks like it may be a bit easier to
play with white because pieces are
developed to better incentive this
bishop on D7 always has some issues how
to write the protective position so I I
prefer to play but I never played French
with black so maybe if I had a chance to
play I know that you are on the other
side enjoy torturous play and you know
like how how you could defend for you
know six and a half hours then you would
respect and appreciate how truly bad
[Laughter]
[Music]
for me like you say I'm kind of a bit on
the other side if I I never really
um was disturbed by playing uh queenless
middle game French defenses I always
felt that in the French defense when
you're white you've got a space edge
whether it be in the center on the king
side the Queens actually helped white
the the Queens lend themselves to
attacking possibilities so something
like Queen B6 and in my mind's eye any
trades of the Queens will soon be met by
Knight G6 and Knight F5 and I kind of
think the worst is behind me type of
thing so we'll keep an eye on that one
and we'll turn it over to Christian and
see what he's been keeping his eye on
I've been looking at some of the key
games in the ladies section this is a
big one the one between the eight-time
national champion Irina Crush versus Ash
and I have to say I really like what
arena is doing in this end game she's
doing hitting all the right notes she's
taking a lot of space on the Queen's
side a lot of space on the king side as
well putting a lot of pressure on her
opponent's pieces and at the right
moment what she will probably have to do
is transition from this side to
potentially the C5 with the Rook on A3
or put that uh in the back of your mind
or play the move A5 and after that open
up the a file and invade with the Rook
of Yeti a file now let's take a look at
what happened in the game Knight to f8
and now we see the move B4 as I was
mentioning maybe A5 open up the
discussion on around surrounding the a
file as well I think would have been the
preferable option she did not do that
she played the move B4
this gives black a golden opportunity to
play the move C5 what black needs to do
is to activate her pieces and try to
exchange as many points on the queen
side as possible not only that but if
you do play a move such as B5 at least
not only that I can take and create your
own weakness I can also play the move C4
and create my own past Pawn so this is
an option as well I'm not really sure
how to feel about this move uh before
specifically due to the fact that black
has this option of playing C5 and
putting a lot of pressure on white
structures still you look at the
position you see a lot of space Arena
still has the advantage in this one and
what's happening in another big game
between
let's take a look
F4 Knight to B6 Knight to E3 this was
some sort of a groomfeld with an early
expansion by black A5 A4 Group Health
with the move a G3
Knight to D7 looking to exchange a pair
of knights but white says okay we can
exchange a pair of knights but on my
terms that's why she sidestep uh this
queen trade on the D file with the move
Queen to C2 because after Knight takes
C5 I want to take back with the d-pawn I
don't want to exchange uh the Queens
because that will help black and what I
want to do is play against the bishop on
G7 this bishop on G7 fighting against
this beautiful structure for white very
nice controlling structure for white
controlling D5 Square controlling the
bishop on G7 it's not looking good and
if you do go F6 I will take you have to
probably take back with the e-pawn and
I'm going to wait for you whenever you
play F5 I'm going to play E5 I also have
the option of continuing with the move
F5 and actually lock the bishop up like
this not looking good for from a
strategical point of view so let's take
a look at what happened Queen to C2 C5
a very interesting find by a begging
Knight 67 Knight takes D7 and now the
move D5 it seems like this is not
something the engines are agreeing with
what the engines are saying is just take
on C5 take the pawn follow the pawn
rubber Association right
[Laughter]
memberships are uh wanted members are
wanted new members yes yes the engine is
uh definitely making a worthy uh member
uh Bishop to D4 Rook to D1 Bishop to C5
but now you look at the position after
looking to H1
there's not a lot of support for the
King right the bishop is not in the best
placed on C5 on this diagonal it doesn't
have any Targets and what I will do as
white is just go right to D5 next move
if you go E6 then you're weakening even
more squares then Rook D7 version
exactly root 27 is a big threat so I
have to address that as well probably I
have to go Queen to uh A5 it just
doesn't feel like a comfortable position
for a black olive white species are
placed on their best uh squares now she
did not play that she played the move D5
with the intention of still closing up
the bishop with the move E5 and a good
reaction by Tokyo Genova with the move
Bishop to D4 yes protect and C5
protecting C5 but not only that if you
play a neutral move let's say B5 you
want to support the expansion I will go
E5 right and that's going to kill your
Bishop on G7 whenever you play F6 I go
E6 follow it up with F5 you're going to
have huge problems getting that Bishop
out she understood that play the move
Bishop to D4 and now it seems like
the pendulum is swinging in this
position white has a had a good position
after d takes C5 could potentially have
had a pretty significant Edge but after
Bishop D4 sure something like King to H1
but now I'm the one pushing I can go B5
I can go A3 as well I mean I played I
said a with A5 I said B with A4 I might
as well continue right right A3 let's
put a lot of pressure on white structure
Rook to B1 take on B2 is very difficult
for you to take back on B2 you have to
go Bishop to D2 wow no yes not looking
good guys not looking good instead of
King Rook B1 to decide yes to sidestep
A3 probably a good move but now black
has a pretty sweet option
B5 to start the attack and the expansion
on the queen side B5 followed by C4
followed by Knight C5 and eyeing the
square D3 that looks good but also
something like Knight F6 and starting to
look on the other side of the board
Knight to F6 Knight to G4 is a threat
you probably have to go kinky H1 at some
point it feels like I also have the move
E6 in the back so
a nice choice for black at this point
but I still prefer the move B5 it just
feels so natural if you allow me to get
the pawn to C4 and then Knight to C5 and
on D3
that's not going to be looking good for
your situation as white so definitely
still a lot to play for and an
intriguing middle game in this one as
well all right thank you for that I'd
like to turn our attention to the game
between Jennifer you and Sophie Morris
for just a moment because all my life I
have been playing the Bob vinic triangle
system as both white and black and I
think that Sophie has played a very very
instructional moment right here I think
she's outplayed Jennifer you thanks to
the following sequence of moves uh
Jennifer's last move night to a D5
introduced the idea that she she would
like to get rid of this yes it's a big
problem Pawn takes and oops we lose a
piece so Jennifer plays the move Knight
D5 and now it's like if it's my turn is
black upon me is why right I want to
play Knight takes D4 and eventually this
bishop will end up looking pretty
terrible if it's just defending this
Pawn on D4 but Sophie played it very
very well she took on E2 got rid of that
Knight and brought the other night now
in Sophie's mind she has a very clear
idea she wants to play Knight D4 put the
queen back on D2 and then play E6 boot
out this night yeah go away and she will
have a wonderful Outpost and white will
not well Jennifer got a little bit
skittish she said wait a minute
I'm better you know mixed things up I'll
play the move
E5 but that has a very severe
Consequence the consequence is this Pawn
could number one become very weak not
that I want to take it right away
because that would result in a trade I'm
threatening best night takes and queen
takes and white is starting to make some
threats at just the moment that black
isn't ready to deal with them instead
after E5 Sophia's could just say you're
not threatening to do anything yes okay
I'll play the move B7 B6 now do your
worst do you want to take well if you do
then look at this very very nice
gorgeous bishop and black will complete
her development nicely with Bishop B7 I
think the position is preferable not
great but certainly preferable for
Sophie and for Jennifer who just coming
off a loss she started with two wins yes
everything was going really nice
suddenly you know a lot of the U.S
Championship isn't yes please um I think
maybe it sounds like such moves like G4
maybe here
you can see you got up this morning with
a very aggressive very aggressive I
don't know maybe I will take now you'll
take yes okay and I have no time to pay
for because Knight D4 comes yes I don't
like it yes actually yes so it's really
hard to complete
and then the question is I I'm not
really uh eager I want to put it like
that I'm not really that eager to take
this because I will take Bishop C5 right
exactly but I I do want you to kind of
enjoy the fact that you play G4 and
there's no F5 which you really wanted to
kill me with and you know again I'm just
going to play it very slowly as black
fortunately you don't have any you know
exactly
so I'll put up my my Fortress cards and
so on uh so that's very interesting it's
a good actual example that if I try some
side attack immediately you ruin it by
playing in the center yes so like I had
nothing after that it takes C5 uh in the
game of um uh Hans Neiman and Fabiano we
see this white Pawn on D6 yes in an echo
we see between Rochelle and Talia that
after E6 also also and then once again
the big question is it an asset or is it
a liability with this move E5 Italia
says oh I've got Tricks in mind for you
don't even think about taking this Pawn
I have a discovery and I will recapture
by the way that's a white king in the
center of the board you don't want on
the position to open up when your king
is still in the center Bishop drop back
to C2 defending the pawn on D6 and now
in kind of a groomfeld fashion a style
oops whoa F4 uh
uh that's suddenly got very interesting
uh talia's whole idea was that any F3
Bishop H6 ah and then suddenly the
Knight will drop in on E3 but F4 very
brave move I like it very much if it
works
and of course uh there there's a reason
why the Bishops on C3 you can't the
highly desirable e-takes is going to
cost the queen
wow very very very very double edged
stuff now if you want to really up the
ante how about this one oops
exactly exactly okay and again this is
all happening when the king is still in
the center if the king waltzes to the
king side be careful that you're going
to be walking into Queen H4 the king
waltzes to the queen side well there is
Knight F2 and also be very careful there
is uh B5 B4 this one very very very
double edge the the the ladies uh are on
a narrow tightrope I this is one where
this is one of those games where you
have this tight rope but it will only
support one player the other player is
going to snap the rope and fall down
well I'm sure uh I'll be I'll I'll make
an easy prediction I'll predict a
decisive result
yes oh yes I'm thinking somebody's going
to win this one after the move B7 B5
back over to you Christian and uh I see
you got uh Hans Neiman and uh Bobby I do
have that game on my board right now and
a lot of things have actually happened
so after this move A5 I think this is
where we left it off Fabiano thought for
a while and played this move Bishop to
G4 and immediately almost immediately
responded by this move H3 attacking the
bishopone G4 but my question is what if
I continue with what I probably wanted
to do after the move Bishop to G4 and
that's just eliminate the Knight right
simplify the position not only that but
by force almost exchange the Queens for
example if you take with a bishop on F3
right I go E4 I'm exchanging the Queens
I don't think you want to see this type
of end game take take on C3 take on C3
you have too many weaknesses and I
actually don't have any big weaknesses
the Pokemon B7 while you attack it I'm
going to Simply defend it with Knight to
C5 there is no way to attack this Knight
B5 is covered you cannot get the Rook to
B5 because the pawn on C6 is covering
that one D5 is covered as well so the
Knight on C5 is going to be untouchable
right and that's going to be a beautiful
night not only that it defends the pawn
on B7 but also opens up the action of my
rook and that's creating a lot of
pressure on your liability in this case
the pawn on D6 as we enter this end game
so to Maya is Bishop F3 strategically
might already be extremely problematic
so most likely after Bishop takes F3 you
have to recapture with the g-pawn but
this one is looking dangerous I don't
think you wanted to see this one I don't
think so no yes it wasn't what is it so
bad that you have to do it it is it is
it truly is if you take with a bishop E4
this is a very difficult 10 game and if
you do take on F6 first I take back
Bishop to it or Bishop to G4 not only
that I can attack it directly with Rook
to E6 but I also have ideas of Knight to
D5 unpleasant it's very unpleasant it is
playing on one goal and that is not
black school it's a high school in this
situation I don't feel like I'm a fan of
the move H3
yeah yeah yeah no it's all about uh
tempies right now and tempos
um he was supposed to immediately attack
the pawn on B7 and the bishopon G4 take
advantage of uh the placement of the
bishop on G4 with a move Queen to B4 and
this makes a lot of sense
the queen of B4 is perfectly placed you
get out of Dodge of this queen trade
which we've seen definitely favors a
black right attacking the weakness on B7
that you spend so much time uh to set it
on before seven and cement on B7 with
this idea of A4 A5 right so you've been
doing all the right things hitting all
the right notes but the last move H3 I
have to say it's very very bad
thank you for that uh Christian uh
turning to the game of Alice Lee for a
moment again through Yen Yang
Bishop C5 not Bishop takes A3 was played
not Bishop E7 either and here while it's
very nice to play the moves F3 and G4
yeah but it is after all a pawn and you
know you've got a feeling like well you
may but you may not have full
compensation maybe black actually has
the two Bishops as well in her pocket
maybe it's time to just you know
how do you say just pull in your horns
just for a moment and go down this kind
of path where we win back our pond for
the moment we're attacking this uh
Bishop on esav on C5 pardon me we can in
such a case especially with the Rook on
A7 I want to say we will get full
compensation and possibly we're even
better but I think it's uh Alice's you
know time to say okay I mean she does
have her show Alice's Pawn Palace and
it's time to win back the pond we did
the punk yeah yeah for the show maybe
after Knight takes E6 Queen takes uh
perhaps a more uh likely variation would
be something like this one where
remember a rook on A7 is misplaced yes
suddenly actually does some good good
like before I don't know like inviting
yeah I'm trying to find something in
order to use the fact that black still
hasn't developed you know there is Rook
E5 apparently rookie five and rookie
seven we can trade it and take but
unfortunately F2 uh will be hanging at
the end of that all right we'll keep our
eye on that one and back over to you uh
Christian and uh what have you uh the
game of begum I mean again I've been
going into the ladies section right as
well and trying to scoop out the
interesting games and this one is
developing as we expected one of the two
ways either B5 or Knight to F6 and she
chose to play on this side with the move
Knight to F6 and we were discussing
Knight to G4 is a big threat you have to
address that and she did with the move
King to H1 and right now it will have to
be Beckham's decision will she want to
develop her initiative on the queen size
she needs to find a way to develop her
pieces once again we go back to
development how are you going to develop
this bishop on C8 maybe on B7 after B5
Bishop to B7 that's one way you can also
start looking at ideas of Rook 28. and
now you might be wondering why are you
playing the move Rook to EA the pawn is
on E7 in front of the Rook yes but an
interesting idea is not only to play the
move E6 because in a lot of cases it
doesn't work unfortunately E6 and I will
show that in just a second why it
doesn't work for example if you play in
this position E6 there's D6 you cannot
take on D6 because of E5 right so after
D6 you have to stop E5 if I get Five
Pawns connected after the movie five not
connected four connected five that's not
a good idea you can you cannot allow
that on the board you have to play E5 we
could actually be seeing this position
uh definitely an interesting sequence
that begging could be considering at
this point she might be looking at
potentially uh preparing that with a
move Rook 28 saying that sure I mean
show me your uh better moves how do you
improve your position as white maybe
bishop to D2 but then I go E6 and then
follow it up with E5 now once you take I
have the option of taking back with the
rook and looking at your E4 Pawn so it's
definitely looking like uh black is
favored at this point very tense middle
game any bad move and the Pendulum could
swing because if I manage to get the
center going as white E4 follow it up
with D6 you might be in trouble so black
has to do something and she has to do it
quickly right thank you for that uh
Christian boy that's a really really
double edged shark game and I didn't
know what the final verdict was going to
be but we have a question from our
Twitter audience thank you for
participating and
one has a tweet is it with a lot of
Chess Champions have written chess books
style is my number one chess author who
are the best and worst world champions
not based on chess skill but on chest
um authorship yeah
wow uh yeah
oh my gosh I I've read the 1960 World
Championship matchbook maybe five times
and it was an extraordinary experience
for me because I read it as a class
player and wow wow that was such a good
book I learned so much I read it as an
expert
and I thought to myself I've never read
this book before I'm seeing it with new
eyes with a greater understanding I read
it as an I am and as a GM and as a
candidate and I and each time that book
spoke to me something differently some
psychology some training some thoughts
about calculation and it's an
extraordinary book Michael tal for me is
the best chess author I like the books
of Gary because yes
he's been really really good for me I
thought steinits was kind of unreadable
I don't know why science and alakine was
marvelous he was some Fantastical
mythological figure making these
extraordinary combinations and sharing
that how about yourself
I was wondering a lot of his Soviet
writings never got translated we do you
have Bob benick's best games and stuff
like that but uh
I it I actually preferred space Loft
about winning funnily enough I thought
Smith's writings were really quite
enjoyable and swissloff almost always
wrote about every game with the better
ending yes
With A better ending how about you
how'd you like it I'm still expecting
the book from Magnus Carlson you know
I think he never published anything the
books have been written about yes yes
for sure many of them but not from him
but we shall not just came out with a
book yes I cannot say that I read the
whole book but some chapters is really
impressive I like his writings I like
his annotative style Christian jump in
oh Nan's book was great I read it
immediately after it came out and I
devoured it I think it took me like a
couple of days to finish it it was very
very good a lot of stories in uh that
book as well alikine was one of the ones
that I was studying when I was a kid
actually it was one of the only books
that I was able to study on my own I
don't know why I just uh found it
intriguing I think it was my 300 best
games or something of along those lines
and of course Gary's books are really
good Gary Castro a bit more recent but
yes more recent Gary and Anand I'm
waiting to as Anastasia was mentioning
as well for a Magnus to publish
something I don't think is going to
happen anytime soon until maybe after he
finishes his playing career but
um yeah Gary kasperov and alkyne for me
actually I'm guessing from my style you
can also understand that I read some
books of Mikhail tal he was also one of
my favorite players always and like I I
think I really liked the way of course
he was delivering all this attacks and
this is really instructive for the
players who want to become a little bit
more aggressive right for me it was the
fact that Not only was he so likable and
approachable it was his writings were so
down to earth and this is one wonderful
story of this passage so he was white
and he was facing a structure of E6 F7
G6 H6 had like a knight on E5 and a
knight on H5 and he could sacrifice a
knight on F7 and he could sacrifice at
night on G7 he could also sacrifice a
bishop on H6
and while he was thinking of one piece
to sacrifice he began to recite to
himself some poetry yeah I know this one
in Russian actually this poetry
hippopotamus the hippopotamus is caught
in the swamp exactly can't get out so
tall starts thinking about well how
could you get this 2 000 pound animal
out of uh the mud and he imagined some
cranes and putting underneath and
lifting the hippo and suddenly he woke
up he had five minutes on his clock he
had been thinking 40 minutes about how
to rescue the hippo
and he he fantastically he went Knight
takes F7 Knight takes G7 Bishop takes H6
and one brilliantly yes and then he
wrote in his book now you can imagine
how pleased I was to read the next day
in Soviet sport how after a
well-calculated combination Michael Paul
is one brilliantly and I just thought
this was the most funnest thing and the
world champions didn't write like
Michael tal they they wrote like this
was a very important
idea I must win to get the first place
that I had a genius idea and then I
played it nothing about the hippo
absolutely yes yeah I remember probably
from the same book that he had this
lucky pencil he would write the games
players more or less superstitious for
sure and they also had my lucky pants
and we had the lucky pencil and then he
lost it and he was really disappointed
you know like he had to start the
tournament from the beginning right
anyway I mean I mean that's exactly what
also caught my attention his sense of
humor yeah it was marvelous just want to
turn our Channel into the Lavon versus
Ray Robson game for just a moment I mean
from my point of view
I just I'm tasered by what I see as all
kinds upon weaknesses in Rey's position
I'm not sure that uh you know Ray's
position is is terrible terrible
terrible but I'm just looking at it and
I'm thinking to myself okay the last
move was Rook on e4 upon me C4 okay uh
taking advantage of this pin taking
advantage of this pin Ray step back with
the Rook on e4 back and I'm sitting
there going okay I mean this Pawn Yeah
the moment it's a problem but it's also
a real liability it's on a light square
and it's very easy to imagine in any
kind of end game it could be easily
captured but I'm sitting there saying
this Pawn is weak these pawns are weak
H3 is weak uh unless black has some
immediately good attacking ideas I'm
just going to round this guy up and even
you know it's like the funnest thing
even you know a situation where you've
won
um an exchange I've got this great Pawn
structure not the only thing of course
Bishop F3 if you want you can also play
this type of thing it captures but I
like lavon's position very much
Anastasia yes sir I just didn't get it
like Rook came to E4 and then it came
back
well yeah I mean again uh black has
strategically uh speaking burned a lot
of bridges with this whole uh Pawn
structure and he needs to hope that he
hits he hits home with some kind of shot
because you know his structure is really
really broken that he did that he did
guys yes and actually uh with not his
last move but the previous one when he
played the move Rook to d8 that was not
the good that was not a good move he had
a very cool idea uh Rook to C8 it's
obvious what white wants to do yes he
wants to play C4 right so the way to
counter that is with the move Rook to
see it getting ready to meet C4 with A6
and you show this idea yesterday you've
already seen this idea it makes a lot of
sense yes you take on Basics I take on
C4 and now with the Rook behind the pawn
yes not only that with the Rook on d8
you cannot take with the pawn on C4 so
imagine the same uh circumstance but
with the Rook from C8 to d8 you cannot
take on C4
it works but you have to play Rook takes
E3 in fact yes yes and that's okay three
look at this rookie three A6 Rook V6
V6 or takes E3 and this is a very forced
line I take on F6 you take only two the
geometry
I like it but now even if I take on E2
and you take on F6 and I play something
along the lines of uh C5 it feels like
I'm going to have the better option in
this position but also I can take on D5
exactly as well as Queen to G4 and again
this Pawn on page three you're losing a
pawn you're going to have to defend the
position with an extra Pawn for white
and a weakened King for black it's not a
good situation to be in uh and again
both of these players Lavon and Ray
coming in today's
matchup with three draws both of them uh
looking to get into that leadership
position four players tied first with
plus one they're one of these players is
hoping to join them and for the moment
it looks like LaVon after this move Rook
E8 and uh how does the um the computer
evaluate the position because I'm
looking at the structure myself and I'm
just saying oh this looks so terrible
it's giving white a significant
Advantage yes yes not only that but
check the times 17 minutes for Ray
Robson 57 minutes
away with Ray that's something that he
just did he's he's dealt with his whole
life it's great and Darius yes and these
are the guys that are really struggling
with their talk about linear you forgot
about linear
yes yes how about yourself were you in
time trouble always always
I'm the one who likes to think about the
position go deeply and stay there and
forget
my songs remember what they have to do
you know
everything yes yeah homework really yes
pretending that I'm thinking about the
relations I don't know what I was
thinking about but I've always always in
trouble time travel yeah so you
no I avoided time travel but I was like
only later in my career did I have some
time travel moments but mostly I avoided
it one uh postmortem by the way I
remember vividly I played in a
competition in Lugano and is playing
against
um uh Dr John Nunn a famous
mathematician early earliest PhD since
Cardinal woolsley you know 1656 or
something like this and John and I post
mortem and John berated me said you made
a mistake here and I go yeah yeah yeah I
got
uh I lost concentration John I was
thinking about something else and I made
this move it was it was a bad move I
remember exactly what I was doing and
John said what
I said yeah I started thinking about
what I was going to have for dinner and
what I was going to do and I got
distracted John said what
I said John
I was thinking about something else he
said
why would you do that
yes I
I said well it just happens you know
I've not trained my mind
to only think about Chess he said really
but John when he played chess yes he
focused on the board to the exclusion of
everything else and I was in I was in
awe I was in shock that uh he could do
that I I always had the problem that I
was distracted the crazy part is
when my opponent got into time trouble
then I was so focused I mean I forgot
about everything else then I was focused
on chess how about yourself uh Christian
did you ever allow your mind to wander
oh absolutely absolutely it's all uh the
songs that I've listened five minutes
before your Spotify playlists huge
problems huge problems with time travel
addiction I have to say whenever I'm in
good shape and whenever I play uh good
tournaments that's the key factor I
don't get into time travel and I know
very quickly round one round two if I
don't see myself entering those
dangerous time travel situations I know
I'm going to have a good competition
ahead of myself it's so important to
avoid that you cannot play in time
travel your opponent will find some
tricks along the way and will make you
pay for it so try to avoid it as much as
possible what do you have in the back of
you there that was the bacon just before
yeah I mean actually some things have
happened whoa whoa whoa what was that
yeah some things have happened yes
king2h1 E6 was played not the pre
preventive let's say Rook to E8 or B5
but rather E6 D6 and right now Beckham
is thinking if she doesn't play the move
E5 she's in deep trouble right she has
to play the move E5 and follow it up
with either Knight to D7 or Knight to G4
do not take on uh uh E5 because after
Knight to C4 I'm kicking the bishop away
I'm going to follow that up with E5
you're not going to be able to blockade
uh the pawn structure this Pawn in
particular on e4 and once I managed to
play the move E5 open up the light
Square Bishop it's not oh my goodness
she played Knight to D7 allowing to get
a connected five wow not a good idea not
a good idea by begging and I would
assume that Nazi is going to follow it
up quickly with the move uh E5 I
understand she must be thinking about F6
F6 exactly F6 but what if I go B four
what in this position B4 is a move but
what about Knight C4 that's a move as
well that's more human that's more human
yes that's more human and then Bishop to
E3 I can also take on E5
probably F6 is going to happen after E5
this is what we're expecting in the
position 20 minutes for bad game 43
minutes for uh Nazi so definitely uh Naz
pakiza is building up a very nice time
advantage on the clock and we see Chris
bird
uh once again to uh our viewers for me I
always thought of the chess sets as
works of art these chess sets are made
by the house of Staunton and in this
sinkhill cup you could own a piece of
History I don't know if that's true
about these U.S Championship sets but
they're specifically designed for the St
Louis chess club the knights are
gorgeous they're hand carved you play
with these uh triple weighted dgt
enabled chess pieces and you think okay
this is a professional set this is a
chess set for professionals I urge you
to look at the go to the house we'll
start on the website check it out and
give a big shot yeah oh yeah cute
Boutique as well
they're really beautiful we're going to
take a break and we're going to see you
on the other side of the break as no
results in this around down for all the
games that no all the games are in play
this is great see you on the other side
[Music]
you may have heard about St Louis's
world-class Museums Art History Science
even Magic
but you may not know we have an entire
Museum dedicated to play with a 10 story
slide and a ferris wheel on top
don't let all this family fun Slide by
you
[Music]
yes it is
St Lou is always exploring anybody
[Music]
[Music]
dot com
can you hear it
it's the sound of Hope
[Music]
and health
and strength
it's the sound of compassion
of open doors
where people and machines are in tune
and miracles occur
[Music]
it's the sound of personalized Health
Care
[Music]
it sounds like life and it's what you
hear when you really listen
listening to you caring for you we are
Ascension
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to round four we have no
really changes in our standings yes sir
why is it happening no results so far so
we still have ellisley and Megan Lee
leading with two and a half points
followed by a beg him to her Donovan
with statue of abrahaman Jennifer you
who have two points out of three and
then the winner crash for eight times uh
eight times U.S Championship has one and
a half points a lot of people with 50
and in the open section again no results
in the open section either so uh the
same scores as the players came in yeah
so four players die for the first place
Fabiano caruana same Savion Christopher
you and Hans Neiman they actually have a
game between leaders we have within the
fourth round Fabiano Carana faces Hans
Neiman at this moment and there was a
result actually we did hear the result a
draw between Darius rich and Lanier
Dominguez that was drawn yes that was a
draw all right I'll jump right into it
because when when you left it in the
game between Hans Neiman and Fabiano
that eight move H3 Bishop F3
precipitated gf3 what's happening he
played this and he played it quite
quickly and after that Fabiano followed
with nightwear fade Queen to B4 was the
move Rook to D7 defending the pawn on B7
Rook to D12 now Knight to G6 this is the
current position we have on the board
obviously Fabiano is looking at uh
potential attacks on the king side via
Knight to H4 that's going to be putting
a lot of pressure E4 at times followed
by Knight to E5 is also an idea and of
course the focus is on the pawn on D6 as
well Rook to d8 or Rook to E6 with a lot
of pressure on the pawn on D6 so white
has to do something white needs uh to
find ideas in the position and needs to
find Targets in the position as well it
does seem like A6 might be an intriguing
option but how easy it is to play the
move A6 I'm not convinced because after
BC 6 you look at the position and it
feels like black actually improved his
Pawn structure I'm going to go C5 later
on I'm going to cut the action of your
queen the defense of uh the pawn on D6
by the move C5 and after that you're
going to lose a pawn but what if I play
Queen E4 here if you play C5 before B5
Queen to A4 E4 E4 maybe we do E4 maybe
got it got it and uh once I play C5 you
want to go Bishop I don't know maybe
it's not enough but Anastasia you've
been doing your homework
my puzzle Rush all right let's go
rookies
I'm the pawn Grabber guy what what if I
take apart yes you just can take it yes
that's also oh my God I didn't think
about it this I was so tempted with the
idea
glance for me yeah take the pause at
least we have one person who always keep
an eye on very careful I'm watching
those slap him on the wrist
yeah
um I I wanted to say that Christopher
you is not quite righted the ship Rook
fd1 was the most let's take a look oh
sorry oh Rook fd1 now A6 seems to be
giving
black lack the advantage
quite a significant one at that in fact
0.8 1.1 right now and only with the best
move in the position which is Queen to
G4 anything else actually is going to
allow me to Corral your Pawn on D6 and
finally capture it and there's not going
to be any compensation not only that the
conversation is going to be your attack
on the king side that black has on the
king side so
the prospects for wise position are not
looking bright at this point I have to
say if Fabiano plays a move A6 okay uh
by the way we do have Rook D1 again if
we do see A6 I'm looking at this bishop
on uh E2 and I'm going oh my gosh I'm
please please allow me to play the move
Bishop on E2 to G4 so I can hit that
Rook uh Force break the blockade yeah
exactly now I want to essay a pawn
sacrifice with the move F4 takes on F4
I'm really uh exposing my king here uh
so to speak I don't I don't think you
can sacrifice a rook with e e takes Part
F takes E3 because of Bishops B7 and
take the Rook so I'm assuming you have
to drop back
and maybe this is just what I can do is
take advantage of the pin go Queen to G5
and then follow it up with F5
ah that might actually be very
problematic well I'll play that by the
way he played Knight H4
no he didn't play a694 so what is the
difference now he's threats and spawn on
the three he threatens to give Checkmate
maybe sometimes after E4
but what if Queen to G4 I guess that yes
that has to be I mean I'm looking at
that move Queen G5 and I'm saying no I
don't want to deal with that
um
okay I I like Queen G4 Rook d8 is
probably the move right and somebody
whispered in my ear that it's a good
idea to play A6 A6 let's take on A6 you
just take okay how do we uh how do I
take advantage of the fact that this
Pawn
oh
yeah
yeah
definitely F3 is still an issue right
yes
um it feels like Fabiano is definitely
in Pole Position yeah that's nice in
this one unless I have a way of
exploiting this exact moment
um C8 is maybe C8 is old
now C8 is weak but uh I I'm thinking I'm
going to give up the pawn but I I don't
see exactly after you take on D6 how am
I going to exploit the C8 Square it's
just it's just just one checkup oops
sorry that wasn't what I was trying to
call yeah like now black is not really
threatening to take on D6 right because
at the end of the variation the Knight
will be hanging yes yes so we can take
advantage maybe at this moment of and do
something but what we can do thank you
that's a good question I'm dreaming of
the answer yeah
I don't know just to prevent it the
problem is I'm actually driving the
Knight to a square that it would like to
go to because Knight F5 and Rook takes
D6 is on the agenda there I also wanted
to say that the game between Wesley so I
I again it was this positional game
where uh way way way back uh remember
when I said the ampasan moment of
ampissant ab6 that white enjoys uh the
better Bond structure and that if these
pawns could ever you know advance in
such a way as to take squares and be
protected black is going to end up with
a weak Pawn on A6 hold that thought as
we get to the game position at hand yes
I'm just going to go very quickly to the
game position I apologies and
this is what happens this is what
happened you see that the pawn on C3 the
pawn on B4 are nicely protecting one
another suddenly there's this like
little weakness on uh A6 and we can
imagine that after Bishop E3 Bishop
takes Knight takes it's been like a slow
you know snowstorm where you know very
very quietly incremental advantages and
are adding up and I like Wesley's
position he's he's trying to come back
from a minus one score at the moment
let's see if he can do it and we have a
guest with Christian we are indeed with
a linear Dominguez one of the rating
favorites going into this event linear
first of all welcome to the show uh I
want to start with your first round game
a big clash between yourself and Fabiano
caruana you were playing Black pieces
and it felt like you actually had a
tremendous opportunity uh to win that
game how would you feel about it yeah I
felt that I had a big Advantage somehow
after dope I didn't remember very well
the opening but I think I
made some at least sensible moves and I
all of a sudden got a much better
position I uh I knew it of course I was
trying to convert but somehow I think it
was defending well and I missed a couple
of chances of course a big Miss there
but it's it's normal how do you usually
see those type of games you missed but
he also played a great game with the
black pieces equalized not only that but
you got a better position out of the
opening does that give you a boost of
confidence or do you feel bad that you
missed a chance I mean in terms of the
result is fine because it's with black
against one of the one of the favorites
but of course when you look at the game
it also it's a bit disappointing not to
not to win that position but it's I mean
it's something you have to get used to
like especially if I defends very well
it's quite tough it's difficult to beat
him so I think yeah nothing out of the
ordinary absolutely and he came with a
very interesting idea against Ray Robson
but let's talk about today's uh game did
you feel any pressure uh coming from
Darius not too much I mean I I had
prepared this idea with Rook E8 which is
very interesting in this line uh with
the idea to
drop the bishop back to f8 in case of A3
because I think normally they play
Knight C6 instead of rookie 8 and then
uh A3 United Bishop D6 and something
like rookie one and uh it's a
complicated position but Rook E8 the
point is to be able to play Bishop f8 in
case of A3 and then in the future black
can play G6 Bishop G7 and in some
positions playing against the isolated
Pawn so uh but he went for the most
solid option which is to to take on D5
and then after Ed position is is very
symmetrical and it's very hard to really
we hope for for more than a draw I think
there were some interesting lines like
after this queen H4 move
uh yeah G3 I mean Rook E1 is also
possible but then I take on F4
and uh yeah queen of four Queen takes
and then Bishop D7 that's very draw
which because there is yeah Bond before
he's hanging and Bishop B3 there is
night before
um well yeah Bishop one Rook C8 and
black is uh at some point not the worst
in exchange this night for the bishop
right I like it still actually appear
yeah so G frequent E4 uh here I think uh
yeah Queen D5 was maybe an option but
then I thought takes on F4 Bishop takes
Bishop E6
and it could be risky for white because
the G3
uh
made the light squares on the king side
too weak and black and have some chances
there it's probably eight Bishop D5
right at some point you have some
problems on the long Diagon yeah white
has two Bishops but black is too active
and my pieces are really well placed
here you don't have to be careful as the
engine is pointed out between the four
and five and then somehow I'll take on
D4 or put the bishop on D5 and
looks excellent for black so I was
hoping for something like this but after
Queen takes G4 and and Knight takes D5
uh yeah it's it's very
uh yeah I wasn't sure about bgp5 but I
thought that uh that's a beautiful move
yeah probably yeah right initially I
thought that maybe he can try Bishop
takes H7 but it looks too risky for for
white yeah it takes 95 Bishop takes A7
uh but with such
um squares on the king side here Rook D2
of course which page three Knight F3
yeah this will get scary of course I
mean after B3 there's no like a win or
something at least I didn't see but uh
but the position is so great that I I
probably don't need to to win right away
to uh to have a great time here good
luck so and your assessment was correct
because actually the engine is saying
that after G5 or F6 yeah I thought
rookie six but they are basically the
same like my position is is really it's
really excellent here favorite online no
risk at all so yeah Bishop E2
essentially kills the game because now
it's just by force
draw which hand game so yeah linear uh
you have built up quite an experience at
the USS championships but now this time
is different there's 13 Rounds when is
the last time you played such a long
event yeah I don't remember but it was a
long time ago it reminds me of the old
days I I remember I played some
tournaments back in Cuba where we had
like uh it was more than 15 rounds for
sure like something like 17 or something
like that so but it was long time ago uh
usually we don't get more than 11 rounds
nowadays but yeah it's uh it's quite a
tough tournament uh but uh it's a chance
to to to prove yourself and and try to
do well so that's that's what I'll try
are you enjoying this tense competition
for such a long prolonged periods of
time
I don't enjoy too much the the tension
uh I prefer when it's over
all the detention uh is is over and you
can just sleep without having to worry
about uh you know Berlin or Patrol
such things uh I I tend to sleep much
better in in those cases but of course I
I enjoy playing I mean it's otherwise I
couldn't survive
uh for for so many years so yeah it's
it's always nice to be able to to play
against these guys and and and and and
and and it's a challenge that I welcome
Anastasia you have a question yeah I was
wondering how difficult it was for a
year to play this day when his friend
livon aronel and competitor lebanaronian
had birthday and uh what did he what did
they do after the game
I she asked how difficult it was for you
to play against Levon when you had
birthday birthday oh well I didn't know
I didn't remember it in the game so it
wasn't difficult but uh
um I'm glad that uh that the game was a
draw because somehow I of course uh if I
win I spoil his uh birthday and he's
such a nice guy you know a dear friend
and also too I almost gave him a nice
present but but yeah I think a draw was
was a really cool result for for such an
occasion yeah exactly thank you thank
you Lanier and good luck in the rest of
your game thank you good luck indeed uh
Lanier uh just want to turn in the
attention to the game between Jennifer
you and Sophie because uh oh Bishop to
G4 okay uh that was a little bit uh off
the Beaten Track I I thought uh the
gauntlet had been laid down with the
move captures on E5 so the idea is that
suddenly you're eyeballing a potential
pin so that after captures an E6 yes
okay
so your your knight can't move Knight F6
check Mission takes F6 Queen takes oops
and that's very nice I won a piece uh so
before or queen F2 well exactly either
Queen F4 or queen F2 and I take a knight
and then how happy or not are you this
is a good question yes then I can take
on D5 I don't know but then you take on
me five E5 yes and then suddenly it
occurred to me that
after E6 both Queen and F4 and queen F
on on F2 were very attractive until I
remembered that I was the president of
the pond grubbers yes A7 is also hanging
correct Queen takes A7 hitting F7 but
also hitting B8 Rook B7 I have and now I
have a nice surprise and that's winning
therefore we understand why so uh Sophie
did in fact play the move Bishop to G4
Jennifer is snapped off a pawn and
probably she'll just keep it yeah it
looks like a good position for white
right suddenly uh things have uh
definitely uh changed in this game and
uh Christian uh other changes going on
oh a lot of changes and actually I think
is Irina who will be taking the full
point home right now because her
position is just uh crushing at this
point there's no way to stop Rook takes
C4 there's no way to stop Rook days D3
after that I'm going to be two pawns up
not only that but look at this active
Knight on C6 just holding on to every
single key Square in Black's position
and after we exchange the Rooks on the D
file the pawn on A7 is also going to
fall this one is over pretty much there
is no compensation for uh the upcoming
loss of material I really like this
moment after Knight to C5 what white
could have done is to get greedy and
take on d8 but you have to be careful
because after Knight to E4 actually
black gets a lot of compensation King
goes to C1 Rook takes d8 and we see
despite the extra exchange now my pawns
are starting to go down the board c3d2
Knight to F2 is quite scary and actually
also objectively is not as good but she
played this cool calm collected
F3
reinforce the threat I'm still
threatening take on d8 I'm not even sure
if I really want to take that's a good
idea it's a really good night maybe I
will pick up the pawn on A7 first come
back to C6 and then pick up the exchange
uh and uh they followed with Rook to D7
Rook to C1 is on the board I think we're
going to see a resignation very soon six
minutes for ashrita 38 minutes for Irina
crush with still 11 moves to go this one
is all in the back for the a-time
national champion absolutely I noticed
in the game of Alice Lee it's Bishops of
opposite colors uh where a draw can
definitely be expected however Alice is
the one actually in the driver's seat
she has the much more active rook and
much more active Bishop black is going
to be perpetually tied down to the F7
pawns sure you could go Bishop F2 and
take on H4 but in that case uh URL I
wouldn't want to trade off the B6 Pawn
for the H Pawn prematurely Alice has
just played the move King C2
quite possibly hinting at a potential
exchange sacrifice Alice slightly better
I would say a draw is uh
most likely but I wanted to get
Christian a coach coach
of Vegas oh my goodness to explain I
think
what you have been teaching your
students I mean I appreciate Missouri
University of Missouri
the great faculty
staff but did you explain about you know
ponchos oh my goodness five connected uh
pawns like this with this guy inside
your position like that this Pawn D6 I
mean this is not looking pretty at the
same time right I do have a nice
blockading night on 37. it's on the
seventh round it's extremely passive but
at least I have this Pawn shield and I
can maneuver behind it maybe go Bishop
to B7 exchange the light Square Bishops
that's going to make your king a bit
weaker and then you're going to have to
find a way to destabilize uh this
structure because in the meantime I am
going to focus on your weaknesses
specifically the pawn on A2 once we
exchange the Bishops on B7 I will be
able to go Queen B6 maybe get the other
Rook into play via A8 it's still a game
definitely still a game I have to say
white has to be preferred at this point
and this was indeed the critical moment
why play E6 once again why would you
hurry in the position play the move B5
reinforce the attack over the square D5
and do not allow black uh White that is
to play the move E5 I did not like what
she did she played the move E6 D6 at
least follow it up with the move E5 this
was key Play the movie 5 do not allow
white to connect her pawns ft 65 Knight
to G4 was an option as well as Knight to
G7 Knight to D7 the simple Knight to D7
I'm going to pick up the pawn on E5 not
allow you to connect your pawns and then
you're going to have to deal with the
liability the pawn on D6 that I am going
to viciously attack so this would have
been a much better solution for bad game
she did not do that Knight to D7 this is
the current position that we have on the
board and the ladies are dropping in
time as well 19 minutes for uh by kids
15 minutes for Tokyo Nova and this one
is going to blow up at some point
because both sides have to find some
sort of way to make progress in the
position they cannot wait black has to
go and focus on the A2 weakness at the
same time try to defend the onslaught
that is coming on the king side with
those Majestic Pawns starting from H2
connected all the way to D6 that's
beautiful you don't see that very often
no I just feel like a bug house give me
one more Pond
[Laughter]
and the Sunbeam we got that yesterday
the Sunbeam you know from H1 all the way
uh up the diagonal maybe seven also is
possible
just turning our attention to the our
other uh tournament co-leader in the
ladies section Megan Lee she's up
against Anna zatonski Anna just played
an intriguing move Bishop D3 uh Megan
voluntarily weakened the pawn on C6 so
this is a backward Pawn on C6 Megan's
saying yeah it's a weakness but never
mind I've got it easily defended well
maybe not so much so the move Bishop D3
invites a trade and I thought that this
was a very cagey move by the veteran
Anna satonski is she saying go ahead
trade the Bishops a quick question for
you Anastasia would you trade the
Bishops or would you retreat with Bishop
to D7 maybe I would I would keep the
bishop I don't know maybe
let's say you have one more defender of
the C6 uh that's what I'm thinking as
well I mean it seems counter-intuitive
to uh it's like you've got the bad
Bishop yes Michael Marin bad Bishops
defend good pawns you pick up on them
you put the fun on the bishop back on D7
and then you start to think okay I'm
going to do my Rook E8 Knight E4
standard maneuver whereas if you do it
in the wrong way for example you take
take let me just put some moves on the
board for just a moment Knight takes
Pawn takes
forget about your king side attack there
is no kingside attack for black anymore
but there is what does we mean Rook C5
rook and uh I start alakyne's gun on the
C file maybe even tickle you at a moment
when my Rook is on C5 with A4 so Anna
would be very very happy with a bishop
trade and she got it that's the live
position
on the wooden board on the left there
Bishop takes D3 so Megan Lee uh her her
her tie for first is a little bit
tenuous at the moment back over to you
uh Christian while I was looking at what
happened in the Levon versus Ray Robson
game I see Ray down to his last seven
minutes but that's not normal that's not
normal for uh him but the position
definitely improved so we got some on
the board for uh Robson Queen to F5 take
on D5 Rook to E5 Queen to H4 Rook takes
D5 Rook to B4 Rook to D2
well I'm not sure about this last move
which was just play Rook to detail this
second Rook to D2 came on the board but
how do you deal with root 2 F4 what is
the calculator Queen G5 is going to G5
but then I just picked this guy up
is an E2 you do hang on E2 but I can
think
oh that's nice that's a pawn up that's
very beautiful I think that's a
beautiful Pawn
no no no continue the line okay Queen G5
Queen H3 rookie two Rook F6 yes pause
for just a second here I I can't make a
suicidal Rook uh uh you have to think
about it I don't think so you can take
only three but yeah on H6 you get check
made it that's the problem that's for
sure yeah no that's that's the problem
wow not only that but I can also yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah that protects the
Rook
um and you cannot take on A2 because
once again takes H6 is a big problem
right
oh guys I mean if Levon sees and I would
assume he's going to start calculating
Luke 2 F4 is the most forced line in the
position exactly there is no
Alternatives it's not like you can go
Queen to G6 I take on f6. uh the queen
that's the tempo can you go Queen to C2
probably not I would assume you're
getting checkmated Rook to G4 and so on
um Queen F7 check also in that variation
Queen G5 is forced yeah but by far Queen
takes H3 you have to take this Pawn Rook
takes it to maybe not force but if you
don't do it then I just play Bishop to
C4 Bishop to B3 you Rook on the second
rank is not actually as it's it's active
but it doesn't create any immediate
threats against my king I'm super well
protected on the F2 uh square right both
of my Rooks are protecting that square
so a transition of the Bishop from E2 to
B3 that's going to uh laser eye the pawn
on F7 you're never going to be able to
move your knight away so I mean I'm
looking at the position I'm seeing a
clear Advantage for Levon of The Rook to
F4 all right thank you for that taking a
look uh please uh Christian in the game
between Wesley so and Sam Shanklin
because this is really kind of reached
uh critical moment right yeah and uh I
mean uh again I was mentioning that you
know you want to maintain your control
over the square D5 so that this uh move
doesn't come now in the meantime the
double Rooks mean I'm winning the pawn
on A6 but Sam said to move D5 by the way
just just just to mention in passing you
know there there is a lurking Bishop
there now the pro okay so you cannot
take on D5 just before finish finishes
the game so just absolutely that
discovery check end of story there goes
uh the queen but
this Pawn on D5 is actually in a pin
you're not threatening to capture I'll
take the Rook thank you for asking so
let's go down the Primrose path Rook
takes A6 gift meet upon and do your
worst
should you like to play
crickets
there's a very cool at this point yes D6
Rook cd6 uh-huh very cool
Roxy okay so that opens up uh the queen
and then the idea is if I take I guess
you could take or The Rook was that
right I think with the Rook
yes but then you're winning your Pawn
back with dividends but is it dividends
oh I think so
I'm getting I'm getting very close to
your king I think you might be in
trouble
if like sounds like Bishops
yeah thinking the bishop C5 and they
should take I move my queen now right I
see we do have a move Knight to F2 was
played so by the way no Rook takes A6
but just uh re uh refortifying uh
further protecting the pawn on e4 with
the move Knight F2
uh once I see D5 and Knight F2 I think
black is very happy uh regardless now uh
he's gotten his uh much desired Central
Bay break yes I mean typical for
Sicilian if you
define normally and it's it works yes
and nothing by the way good morning good
move by uh Wesley Knight to F2
here yes no taking the pawn on A6 was
just bad news but I mean his last well
five moves have been all uh focused on
that now here
I mean I'm I'm just thinking like if I I
would want to keep this tension I I'm
thinking that if I play D4 somehow that
that comes a little bit without
uh threats I mean I can sidestep this
and so I'm preparing on my next move to
capture and move my Bishop although I
must say I'm opening up some dark
squares here aren't I like just just to
show you yes I'm missing uh the kind of
things that uh
you know something that could go wrong
you know go thump in the night that type
of thing
um I understand why you played the
choice but yes I I just made a pass
evaluation if you don't mind on this
position zero zero zero no way zero zero
zero get lost so he was building this I
was thinking that it was a double-edged
game with somebody for sure it doesn't
seem having a big Edge somebody's got to
have an edge here I mean from a
practical perspective I have to give it
to Black just because I see this uh
opening of the D file potentially
opening of the D5 with d takes E4 but
also the idea of D4 breaking through
like that so I'm seeing a lot of threats
coming from black side at the same time
you also have a weakness on Asics that
you have to uh tend to so it's not as
easy and this Knight F2 followed by most
likely of something along the lines of
Queen to E2 get the queen out of Dodge
out of the e file and then take on D5 or
at least threaten to take on D5 because
E4 doesn't come with the same impact so
before Wesley might not yet be in
trouble from an objective point of view
from a practical point of view I
definitely feel like Sam has the upper
hand yeah like he's losing control over
the position it feels like a little bit
I mean it can it can be yes so it's not
really a good feeling when you think
that you're having everything under
control that you're building these ideas
to take this Pawn on E6 and suddenly
your opponent has this counter play in
the center doesn't Wesley with the white
Pieces by the way he did lose uh well
against Christopher you he's the
defending Champion
um right now the computer is saying zero
zero zero but I can tell you by the
clock uh the 11 minutes or 10 and a half
minutes that Wesley has to compare to
the 22 minutes that Sam has on his clock
and means that Wesley is not really
enjoying the position as much that is
he's thinking a lot more and we'll keep
our eye on this one and turn it back to
Christian to ask him what have you been
looking at
well we've been looking at the game that
you were looking at
um
but I also checked this one for just a
second yes let's check together it does
feel like Fabiano is making some Aden
into a White's defense in this one and
actually picked up the pawn on D6 right
now it's his opponent the question is do
you have enough compensation to save
yourself as white and you have to find
something quick because if you allow me
to stabilize the position right G6 King
G7 get my pieces out uh solve all my
problems around my kingdom you're going
to have some problems and defend all my
weaknesses now since that Queen to B4
was critical Bishop to D3 is already a
mistake now what if you just simply go
G6 right G6 right now is uh going to be
very problematic for black just G6 King
to G7
Queen to E7 defend the pawn on A7 defend
the pawn on C6 and uh I mean take it
from there this is not easy this is just
an extra Pawn not only that but your
king is also extremely weak G6 is on the
board yeah well I mean white is the one
after all with the damage king size
structure the double pawns and the well
I want to say isolated H3 Pawn as well
also the move uh so often almost from
the moment the queen landed on F6 The
Black Queen landed on F6 black always
was looking to play the move uh E5 E4
either trade Queens at a certain moment
and the queen was on C3 or to Simply
trade the pawn on B2 this move E5 E4
caught my attention the moment the
bishop landed I assumed that this two is
better for black but I like I like
fabby's move even better oh it's just
simply G6 slowly don't understand why he
played Bishop see what is the idea
behind it yes why is this so before he
wants to I really tried to understand uh
the reason right Bishop to E4 the
problem is and this is why G6 is such a
powerful move if you play Bishop E4 yes
now I go each five ah where's your queen
going if I drop back well if you drop
back then I can take on e4 and then go
Rook to D6
completely out of play yes they have
very nice Queen and pawn ending uh no
that just looks terrible and and at this
moment uh Hans is to hope that his
Bishop offers some kind of a Solace for
maybe but where's the Solace yeah where
is it I don't know especially the Hans
Neiman game versus Fabiano caruana there
we have it right
from
it was the last round of the sink field
yes he lost yes not the last one because
remember there was not the same number
of the the games for each player because
last rounds
the last round and it was a very
important point that he scored in a very
uh nice Queen ending so we think uh well
Fabby definitely with the extra pawn and
the extra time on the clock too by the
way should be in control of this one we
have a social media let's do Anastasia
let's let's go uh put is on our best yes
yes
how to learn chess the fastest by
watching plane or reading thank you for
your great commentary and the love hands
energy in this time thank you for your
question and your comments uh what did
Yogi Berra say you can learn a lot just
by watching uh
yeah I think everything you just said
watching studying playing uh for me I
want to say say when I learned the most
was from playing from playing yes the
same for me I think I mean I think like
that I had skin in the game I was
competitive I wanted to win and if I
read a book I wasn't sure I was winning
so much as when I was competing but uh
Christian
best advice it's very much about playing
in my opinion because whenever you play
you also study you go to a tournament
you prepare for your games you study
while uh you play there's definitely
um the other side of the coin when you
play too much and maybe you lose some
energy and then you have some bad
results you start getting that burnout
the feel of the burnout so you have to
be ready to balance uh periods of times
where you're playing a lot you're
studying a lot and periods of times
where you're just like let's say
watching a stream watching a show or
training but not necessarily in a
competitive uh mindset so definitely
training to my eyes is the best one but
you have to be ready to stop playing
whenever you feel that burnout creeping
in yes yeah I believe also that the
question is also like how you start and
if we are talking about small kids now
now these days maybe the different
approach works like
um even the fact that I have my small
daughter I mean I understood that just
playing the games for example in the
club or with with other kids sometimes
not helping because they can be really
sad losing and also sometimes they just
give up before they even start trying so
these days you know for example this
program chesky then the other programs
as well applications they're so good for
kids because they're used so much for
technologists these days so they start
playing against some robots for example
those ones which never win against you
and by by playing them feeling very
confident that you always win your games
you somehow learn the moves you learn
how to play and you you stay at the game
and it's also nice it's in this kind of
program you know these robots they're
reacting like you make a good move the
robot is crying so I think that this the
new technologies are helping these days
kids to stay in the game because I think
many many kids would wouldn't do the
same when I used to play like many many
kids would just forget about the game
after something disappointed after a
loss or two or three and that kind of
thing for me uh one of the things that I
really loved here at the St Louis chess
club is I had this Sunday class where
the kids were like four to seven
and uh I I created what I call obstacle
courses so the idea the the whole chess
puzzles was when I was growing up what
was the funnest thing about Chess
capturing my opponent's pieces how much
fun it was to take the pieces and then I
would line them up and they were I would
count because I knew what the table were
and I could see that I was ahead and I
was really very proud of myself so the
idea of the obstacle course was to put a
lot of pieces and pawns on the board and
to give the the child the the object
piece and there's no moves you just have
to go around capturing but you can't put
your obstacle piece on pre okay so the
moment you you put it on pre and then to
count up so I had these kids coming up
and they were getting 17 points and 19
points and 23 points and they loved it I
did too I just really enjoyed uh
watching kids
um
yeah and then they had those Eureka
moments they go oh I could do this it's
so nice but definitely everything you
said but for me it was playing that was
really when I felt I learned the most uh
picking up with Wesley so versus Sam
Shanklin uh we did see the move uh
Knight F2 Rook C8 and then Wesley said
okay once again the pawn on D5 is taboo
I don't want to lose my queen to a
discover check
uh I'll play the move Bishop C5 I'll
I'll cut the action down the C file and
if this bishop remains on this Square
well one day I'm just going to take this
Pawn on A6 I as I was speaking the move
Bishop D6 was played
by Sam Shanklin and crazyly enough what
can I say double triple zeros by the
computer
was shown what happened to the game it's
not triple zeros anymore oh sorry no no
not anymore all right not anymore
what if I just take on these things no
actually Rook to C8 seems to have been a
bad move what if I just take on D6 now
he did continue taking the pawns Rook
takes A6 okay
I like the way
and what if we just take a bond yes what
happens let's keep taking let's take
let's say no let's just go through the
variations what if I just continue
taking probably with a rookie if I you
take it with a queen take with the queen
back and then Rook day C3 right that
seems to be close to equality and if we
just keep we're smashing everything off
the board yes and Rook takes E3 at the
end of this whole show I'm going to take
on E5 and I'm going to be a pawn up not
only that but the queen on E5 is very
nicely centralized also I have this B
Pawn such an amazing Pawn absolutely how
easy it is to convert I'm not 100 sure
nevertheless there's play on one goal
exactly yeah you can be happy with the
best outcome yes that's a great
achievement for Wesley so obviously by
the way uh Rook takes A6 on the board is
on the board yeah as we speak this is
the current game position and Wesley
saying to Sam well you created this week
in this 20 moves ago when you played the
move B5 I finally uh captured it
that move Rook C8 that was a strange
move also to my eyes because it seemed
like white was the one having to address
a question what would have happened for
example Rook D7 I'm threatening to
capture the pawn on e4 again you don't
have time to play six and it was
something like yes exactly Rook takes A6
takes on e4 and yeah you have to move
your queen and remember the majorities
whether you prefer the center or the you
prefer the center exactly uh so the the
move Rook C8 was just wrong on a number
of accounts the that The Rook was
actually doing good job on the D file
and Bishop C5
the bishop on E3 wasn't that great I
think he missed this move Bishop C5 yeah
and by the way after today uh I think oh
my gosh it might actually work in the
shades of Arena Crush versus Megan I
mean we've been we've been seeing these
exchange sacrifices a lot but Rook takes
F6 yes you don't have to ask a top Grand
Master twice
about such they will not hesitate to
such
sacrifices just go and get them
are you sure it all works so immediately
no but it's it's a heroic feeling
yes it is backed by a very concrete
calculation though so you go on ig4 King
G7 the IG for King G7 sure and how do
you continue now okay pause pause
because I see I've got a rook
A7 that's one if I've got my queen
correct on E3 but it's probably better
in fact to go Queen to D2 keep contact
with the phone on D5
ah so that's a threat Almost Queen D2 or
queen E3 in either case you have to play
Rook AJ there's just no yes but if my
queen was on E3 yes I get my Rook to A7
but if my queen is on D2 you think
that's all yes that's that's probably
even better yes this is this is what you
want for yesterday
I understand here I can see you are a
I'm learning great commentator you're
you're making it happen Rook takes epic
that looks like a winner Christian it is
it's usually winning it's plus four by
the Angels plus four I know this is a
golden opportunity for Wesley uh to get
back in this tournament after losing
that difficult game against Chris for
you get back to 50 with the victory in
this one yeah
really needs well everybody
everybody's up this 50 score outside
looking in four players tied for first
let's take a look at some of our
tournament leaders as Sam sevillan what
is he doing against a Wonder Liang we
liked Sam's opening a great deal has he
achieved an advantage you know the first
thing I look at whoa has he achieved a
disadvantage I was about to say why
isn't black better here I'm almost
looking at Bishop takes H3 I think he
could have done that no you cannot I
think it's not right now but I could
have done that the move ago
oh by the way just uh we left it maybe a
second too soon because we did see oops
no I yeah we can see Rook takes F6 of
six yes and Sam with his embroidery
shirt you can see uh on the back there
the St Louis uh logo
um was in trouble yes and he knows that
this shirt didn't help
oh yeah sir
sure didn't help Knight G4 on the board
and Sam realizing that that move Rook d8
really is a a bad one he seems to be
nothing very close to making a move but
he was reaching for his clock
reaching for his kids this move I'm in
The Rook of six okay but I mean King to
G7 he's very interesting it's
reconnected past pawns I mean
that's just one too many yeah
push push push on the king side
and they're going to be easily supported
by the Knight coming back to E3
wow you still have to keep contact with
that H6 Square otherwise you get
checkmated so you have some resources uh
seven of course yes King G7 so I wonder
if Wesley will play immediately 22. I
first calculated everything
I'm seeing that by the way uh a number
of times by Wesley
um Jude he's making quite a number of
YouTubes in general
I'm not a big fan of the youtubeing you
know like uh when you want it when
you're capturing something sure you can
yes at the subject might touch my pieces
but you know all this you do being a
he's done uh can be annoying you it can
be annoying yes a little bit off-putting
uh and King G7 it's funny because again
this move Queen E3 Rook h8 Rook down to
A7 it's also very compelling you you
know you're on your horse you're you're
charging you're charging but Paul is a
pawn
yeah I mean it just feels like you know
you need a follow-up uh in the absence
of the follow-up that's why the move
Queen D2 again as prescribed by
Christian is so very sensible this these
have three connected phones moving
forward exactly right right life is very
good
and is time a PR effector by the way I
think Wesley actually has it is but
there's only three moves to go okay yes
37 right now
um seven minutes for Wesley I think he
has all the time in the world to make
three good moves yes and also look I'm
in this position even white can move
Knight probably to easily than on F5 G4
that's the case holder so the prime
squares F6 e66 and C6 but in this
position with those double pawns the F5
Square as again we saw in Arena crashes
game is so many checkmating uh patterns
yeah abound again I just want to check
in on Sam Savion we were about to say
Sam was slightly worse
no no
no
yes no so perhaps let's go down a couple
of moves King takes Jesus right back
let's go uh back before Bishop F5 I
think he had that opportunity no no no
no go all the way
yes to where we are when he played
Bishop five maybe bishop takes H3 was a
move right right that was my question
and how do we assess this end game
C1 Bishop takes C1 Rook A1 right
now we I only have I moved
92.92 Bishop B2 it's forced
do should I take a pawn I think you have
to I'm losing yeah uh rook and Rook is
not saving a piece
well it can only be
better for black right right
okay but I'm actually winning a pawn no
he missed that Rook F1 just wins the
pawn
ah very nice as king G3 or F3 both of
those moves are about to be met by Rook
B1 that wins a pawn that's very nice
just a simple Pawn I think he calculated
all the way until King to H2 and he said
okay he's coming back to H3 this is a
draw right right so just wins upon it
yeah so a Wonder missed a combination
here and the current position is
probably slightly better for black I
want to say I mean this bishop is
actually one day on a very good day he
gets to tickle all of the structure and
Rook to E7 ah look at this using the
fact that there is this penis
uh-huh
okay did I wonder miss that moment it
looks like his reaction was like like he
didn't expect it yes why is that yeah
yeah yeah
who invited you to my party uh okay but
there has to be a simple way to make a
draw here right well d8 maybe well
there's rookie eight there's Rook d8
because I don't think I think this Rook
is actually going to get hit back Queen
takes E7 King takes and The Rook is
going to be driven back right yeah so I
it's it's but maybe you can play like
Queen E3 now something like that oh
that's a good just let's say to avoid um
but then the Rook is not is hanging
and it appears that Jeffrey and elshon
are repeating in a draw expected in this
game uh by the way although we didn't
pay too much attention to it I had it on
my back burner and I thought elshon was
pretty much a I had a comfortable game
and Jeffrey was the one more or less
that was pressing now Jeffrey's saying
where's the Arbiter come on guys come on
come on I mean leave the snacks alone
for just a little while you know
no I think Jeffrey was they're checking
though if the repetition happened
because there are no offers let's remind
to our viewers we cannot you cannot
offer draw you can only repeat the
position three times so make a Perpetual
check or or stalemate
or 50 moves okay
um and the game between our two
tournament uh co-leaders Hans versus
Fabi Fabi is actually uh the one uh
enjoying uh the proceedings he's a pawn
up a safer King
uh Hans I want to say some there was a
Pawn on E3 now it's going to take you
know a couple of uh illegal moves to to
uh yeah to trespass across the board if
this knight ever ever lands on F4 we can
sign the score sheets yes so it looks
like uh for me Fabi has an extra pawn
and the compensation a big advantage and
also an advantage on time and for falby
that would mean back-to-back wins
lavonaroni and Ray Robson
big big heavyweight matchup two
four versus four yes but somehow the A2
Pawn was missing when we left it we left
it right around these parts and we were
thinking Rook F4 yes but he played
Bishop G4 instead this was this was a
very kind of clear line of advantage uh
and
maybe not as clear
now do we have Ruchi for but we do have
Rook G4 check okay that's a check that's
it but I have a G5 yeah
oh no
um
Ray down as usual
two minutes great time management by Ray
I mean come on yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
he's got that come on luxury
so two draws in the uh open section and
in the ladies and still no results yes
sir any of the ladies any anything thing
happened well this Pawn of Rochelle got
all the way to D7 I wanted to actually
check in in Alice's games I missed it by
one
whoa whoa whoa Alice yes she won a pawn
and I don't know what's happening
her winning chances must be through the
roof at this moment no yeah this might
be very close to equality right what
yeah but I'm thinking uh I'm getting
ready to sacrifice an exchange that's
fine I don't think that's going to help
you too much I I mean I'll probably have
to reroute my Bishop to what king G3
King G3 oh I don't think that's why you
take that I take that also actually
five yes
I would I would love for this let's
assume let's assume your king is not on
B5 that's yes okay you get everything
you ever want oh yes you get this yes
right yes I can go Rook F6 I see
yeah it's not easy I don't think you
have enough no but if you do get Rook
takes B6 then you get some chances right
absolutely that's what I uh absolutely
yeah yeah
I remember
and uh let's just jump in on the game
between Jennifer you uh who lost
yesterday
uh up against Sophie and today Showplace
was white yes
let's try to understand what's going on
I see all pieces
that's a full night yes that's a piece
up what's going on
uh very very good Rook takes F7 not only
that it's a piece up but I go Knight C6
I'm picking some more materials that
could be a rook up that's going to be a
workout yeah no but I thought about Rook
D2 then but you can even take a single
B8 and after Rook G2 so Queen d8 yeah
this looks like an overwhelming we we I
don't know where whatever went wrong
well we left it a little I guess a long
time ago but uh basically Jennifer won a
pawn
that's yeah then it's then it's very
simple for her and now to win the game
what happened with Anna and Megan we saw
the trade of Bishops and look at this oh
everything you predicted yeah the worst
the worst thing that could have befallen
black has occurred uh massive weaknesses
on the
Queen side are being probed the pawns on
A5 and C6 even worse put the pawn back
on H7 maybe G6 isn't so bad this Knight
could easily go to F4 Queen G4 exactly
big big big Advantage for Anna bad news
for Megan Lee fans as Megan one of our
tournament co-leaders along with Alice
looks like she's going down Arena Crush
we left it she was winning right and she
still is look at this two extra pawns
and
my goodness talk about this look at this
every single piece in the position is
better for white the Kings compare the
Kings compare the Rooks compare the
pawns uh there's two extra pawns for
white that's a that's an easy easy win
for
um Arena Tate versus Sabina no pieces
left almost yes
if I've got this right is up a pawn and
she's ready to clip another
yes my big tattoo is doing well doing
very well yes
ah yes gold good for her for her
absolutely and finally uh what happened
to White structure uh naji's structure
no longer exists what what there was an
F4 Pawn
you're a student somehow should get rid
of those through the magic of I don't
know what kind of magic we saw this and
we were just in gleeful we were a bit
cruel right the fact she found the way
look at this vegan
and these ladies are actually going down
to their last few minutes so oh my
what is what are the clock times three
minutes and 30 seconds for a bad game
and five minutes and 40 seconds for
Naji and how many moves remaining in the
time there are five moves to go six for
backing this is move 35. I have pills
yes but that's the problem right well
first glance by the way how are you
dealing with these past bonds B7 well
you can take one of them right Queen
takes D6 oh you can can you because
before is hanging maybe after Bishop
before you have time to take the Rook oh
for sure yes
hold on hold on
778 yes give me your Rook uh-huh and now
are you trying to go I see what you're
trying oops
so you better you have to drop back with
your queen right yes then I was gonna
oh shoot I wanted to get in no but now
Rook D5 whoa whoa whoa whoa Pawn on D6
what is that
uh we have Rook takes B4 we have Rook D5
Rook D5 that's uh well look at that look
I have to say look at it is it the best
move no no no
but she has ideas of Bishop D4 Check Yes
and also the bishop on D2 is hanging at
the bishop on D2 is hanging
B7 what's the problem uh yeah B7 Bishop
D4 check do you want it I don't know I
don't want no no no no uh Bishop C3
should I deal with that this way
maybe computer says that it's winning
for white but try to find all the best
moves it's still oh there it is
no I was about to say there it was B7
Bishop D4 because if you move your Rook
I have this nasty move Rook D6
Rook B6 do you I hope so
nasty move yes nasty move it is because
if you take my Rook I was going to take
your Rook I saved my bishop and
fortunately Bishop D4 check is no longer
a winning threat but what if I still do
it Bishop to B4 and queen takes B7 how
is that in game aha what do we feel how
do we feel about that game I've got Rook
check oh no sorry sorry yeah no I
understood my my finger failure I have
Rook fa check yes
oh may I introduce shall we explain to a
Christian our meeting ideas uh keep
going King F6 it's not made yet yes and
uh so would you like to do the honors
mate in one uh yes okay
renewing B7 wait a minute guys but how
about Rook D4 now come on nice
that's a great move because Bishop takes
Bishop takes and the and the shoe is on
the other foot suddenly
wow it's amazing it's it's really
checkmates
Rook D4 loving it oh I have Queen B5 you
do have Queen B5 lucky lucky but let's
continue right Queen B5 what if I go
Queen E4 yes now you're threatening my
Bishop you're threatening my road
I know
with Note with time travel okay perhaps
I mean come into my mind I cannot
imagine what's going on here maybe it's
not working but just no no no visually
it's a it's a beautiful way
oh man we get the international Arbiter
right in front of it I mean yeah you
know did he go to arbitrating school do
not stand in front of the cameras and
this is a big mistake by begging right
now what happened Queen takes D6 just a
second just a second she was supposed to
D4 yes she didn't find them
not looking good because there's a
couple of options okay Rook to B5 is a
big one this is reinforcing this Strat
of taking on C5 as well as keeping the
Rook behind the pawn okay that's a big
option and the other one I'm waiting for
you to tell me that B7 is a good move
B7 is not so strong it's not so strong
yeah I would just go Rook to B8 after B7
so it's not as clear as Rook to B5
actually keeping the pawn on a dark
Square so that whenever I take on C5 I
defend that pawn
how interesting I why am I so eager to
play the move B7 is because we just saw
already one variation where the active
Rook could Checkmate me on A1 so I'm
always thinking B7
uh is is one of those moves to
deactivate the Rook but that's
interesting Rook B5 right away by the
way our first result in the ladies
section as Jennifer well she was a piece
up when we saw it yes and let's just see
the final position
Checkmate the final position oh that's
not bad that's what it's all about yeah
great great job nice combination there
puzzle Rush uh Jennifer bouncing back
after tough loss yeah before not bad at
all all decisive games by the way no
draws so far and
she gets wandered on the way out as well
uh does Jennifer sorry uh to interrupt
you Chris did play the move B7 she did
play these how can you how could you
resist playing I mean come on and we
know when you have a bus phone you have
to move it yes this is a golden rule
push your past bonds uh B7 on the board
I suspect that
and well again you know you just kind of
follow up with your previous play you
want to play to win this Pawn on C5
yes again I'm looking at the Sunbeam and
for some reason I'm not reminded of
these Dutch Master artists you know that
played with the sunlight in many of the
old uh paintings Vermeer and so on but
are you threatening I don't know maybe
not because Bishop G4 is at the end of
the variation maybe right yes I don't
know I didn't count so I've had a lot of
problems on with my back rank I might as
well try to do something about it let's
go H5 for example this makes some space
for my king I really don't know without
any space or maybe very logical Rook B5
also very logical
also H5 is not a clear move at all right
you might be focusing on trying to take
back the pawn on B7 somehow
can you play instead of H5 like Bishop
D4 just to check
I'll take it yes you'll just take it and
that's it like a rook takes a queen C5
right or what yeah it's just a moment
because I think you kind of exposure
King maybe you know something like Queen
C3 and Rook takes C5 on my agenda but
the thing is the bishop G7 actually it's
actually much more powerful than the
bishop on E3 is defending the king but
also attacking potentially after Bishop
to D4 I don't see a big reason why I
wouldn't want to exchange it except for
the fact that I want to win your Pawn I
want to take root take C5 right I don't
even know before sometimes comes to you
to my mind in order to try to use this
open
Queen and Bishop yes
C5 yeah this is ah come on you don't
even try to take them before
I was waiting for visual before nobody
wants my route nobody wants I'm not
gonna think I'll tease that rep no way
no way uh let me just go back and very
quickly jump into the game of uh Hans
Neiman Fabi okay better Wesley
better Wesley uh in fact just simply
winning he did play the move Queen D2
and he did follow but we have special
guests in studio with uh with Christian
I believe are we all set up I believe we
are set up with Jenny for you after a
brilliant Victory Journey for a nice
bounce back Victory yesterday a
difficult game against tatev but you did
bounce back like Champions do how do you
feel right now
um I mean I feel pretty good I was just
really disappointed by the way I played
yesterday
um I felt like I didn't even really get
a game because I probably did the worst
prop imaginable for that game and then I
just kind of wasted my time beginning
because I just couldn't move
um for some reason so I just like
sitting there and ran out of time and
then just like blundered on move 20. so
it was just a horrible game and I just
wanted to make like play quicker today
and just make some good moves how do you
psychologically bounce back from that
what did you tell yourself
um
probably I didn't think about it too
much I was just like
I think this kind of validated me into
thinking oh if you sit there and think
you're not necessarily going to play a
good move because like what happened was
just so bad like today I was just like
let's just move you know
um like I have
I have an idea what to do like just just
make the move let's go through the game
today and point us to the critical
moments of the game
or would you say you uh let's say took
the initiative in your hands um I mean
so I thought this was all pretty normal
I probably didn't play this as
accurately as I wanted to like here this
Knight D5 just lets like this Knight
takes you to Queen 62 96 I thought this
made sense but E5 I wasn't
um I mean um I didn't really calculate
this too much it was just you know
nothing's hanging and I think this gave
me the best practical chances because
otherwise I don't want her to get like a
piece of night um her piece on D4 and
it's just gonna be so uncomfortable for
me to play so what if she takes you take
back Bishop takes doesn't work because
the bishop takes C4 Bishop C5 is really
nice because like no matter what it's
just um this bishop this dark circuit is
too important yeah and so if you ever
lose it it's just a lot of trouble for
Block absolutely and she played the move
B5 Rook to D1
and at this point it was just feeling
like you're getting a free attack
there's nothing happening on the queen
side she's very far from opening it and
you're just uh destroying her on the
king side did you follow the same way
yeah um I think 94 here she might have
missed
um after Bishop takes e4s he takes Queen
takes E4
um takes he I think she missed like
either after this D takes E5 I takes C5
Bishop obtain or maybe I don't know
maybe
um you can't take on E5 directly one
take take yeah Bishop hanging on G4 and
also I think it just kind of works out
for me because you really want to get E6
to work at some point well not here
before Bishop G4 but I have Queen A7 and
it's really nice because then there's
like Rook V7 and I have six though at
what point like here um take take E6
just like doesn't work Queen takes A7
and then okay I wasn't actually this I
think this is kind of complicated sorry
to interrupt I really not crashed the
eight-time national champion did win her
game against ashrita aswara takes the
first victory in the U.S Women's
Championship
okay let's continue Queen to A7 and then
so yeah so I was letting you Rook B7
um Knight F6 and then okay here yeah and
it just doesn't quite work out because
you want to take and Bishop takes E5 but
I have D4 like just one time pretty nice
otherwise it was a little otherwise
Bishop D4 might be problematic of course
very nice nicely uh calculated she
played Bishop to G4 she was trying to
open you up on this side but at this
point
there was no turning back for her
um very nice of victory for you are you
going to do uh some homework tonight or
what's the plan oh yeah I have a big
deadline I
a few hours before midnight gotta turn
that in
um but yeah it's same thing every day
Jennifer good luck uh with your homework
and good luck in the rest of your games
yeah do you do you don't turn in a
pumpkin if you don't turn in your
homework by midnight right I mean
Halloween is coming Uh something's
happening at midnight uh just looking at
Alice Lee Alice is enjoying an extra
Pawn
um uh Christian felt that the Bishops of
up as a color overrides that and it
draws most likely but definitely Alice
is
um
yeah again our 12 year old co-leader at
this moment but let's jump back to the
open section we have two victories in
the ladies and uh jumping to the game of
Wesley so versus Sam Shanklin we left it
it was three connected past pawns
and it became four no no now it became
four uh for well three connected past
bonds for sure what can be better than
three connected passports four or five
or five
we've seen that in this round uh Rook at
C4 it's still not well it is pretty much
playing one goal my gosh this is way way
way
ponderance guys what take a look at the
rate Robson game oh
that blew up and in Ray robson's favor
oh look at that end game right now
uh one two three four but it was strange
because it was a four pawns like this
versus two that's okay somebody got
traded and look at these guys the
connected passers you have to keep the
bishop on the long diagonal defend the
pawn on D5 in the meantime I'm just
going to push up my pawns this is not
looking good for Lavon
well he has just played the move King F1
and his basic idea uh as far as I can
understand it defensively speaking is he
wants to rush his King to in such a way
that the king will
obviously the ideal square at the moment
would be the B5 Square uh it's it's
gonna it's not getting to B5 but if it
got to B4 or B3 as a blockader uh it
would be fine
um and I see a knight landed on E5
as I understand it there's Rook
unfortunately is simply too strong and
The Rook on A7 or A6 holding up the pawn
so the move Knight E5 which comes with a
gain of tempo against the bishop I think
is a Prelude to playing Rook to D7 and
maybe Rook to B7 but let's see
is is Ray
no I can't believe that this would be
no shouldn't be bad for for for white no
maybe not anymore right but what if
instead of Knight to E5 I would have
played the move A4 just push the pawns
A4 logic logical
seven before you simply so that you have
to do something with those bones right
okay so king um
King uh I'm I'm angling to to blockade
let's go B4 and King
so wherever you put your Pawn I'm trying
to put my king so let's go might be 96
was the idea to take on D5 sometimes yes
yes why not
pick up the pawn on D5
okay fair fair
Rook C6 no I don't do I want
am I losing
am I losing oh this must be lost yes it
can go comes
I take on C6 yeah let's say even though
actually no sorry sorry sorry no but
it's not the correct move I should go
King E5 okay you want to exchange on
your turn yeah absolutely
again this is what I learned yes exactly
exchange on your turn Okay uh I don't
know but then I take on D5 right ah you
want to go receive five
but then I go King D4
this is not looking good the answer I'll
tell you that much no me gusta no me
gusta probably uh maybe 95 was uh a
wrong move Bishop E4
and is time a factor yes I mean they put
the in in font of two
times
and not a not a factor because they
passed 40 oh they passed 40. so half an
hour
um very very good actually 95 was uh
41st move even yeah okay so Ray could
have actually studied that position
maybe missed an opportunity there and we
have a guest uh with Christian we are
indeed with the a-time national champion
Irina crash Irina first of all
congratulations it felt like you were
getting so close each and every game
through that Victory but it was just so
elusive
oh yeah I mean it was pretty depressing
um to go three games without a decisive
result and
um it's my first time earning the right
to see you guys in the studio pretty
happy about that and uh you know yeah of
course
um the way the tournament started I
don't think I've ever had a U.S
championship start like that without you
know three games without a win
um it was quite disappointing I mean I
was definitely so close I had good
positions in all the games and I mean
against Sabina it was like almost there
and then such a promising position
against Megan Lee after the exchange
sack and even that kind of escapes me
when she found the draw in the king and
pawn end game even without even the
first round you had a better position
maybe a bit worse after that and it
finally ended in a draw is it something
about the length of the event that makes
Players let's say play a bit more
conservative well the thing is I'm not
playing very conservatively I'm just
actually like even yesterday
um I had like a pretty safe option to
trade Queens out of the opening and I
was like well that's perfectly fine from
a chess point of view but
um I chose to keep the Queens on the
board keep my king in the center and
obviously a lot more risky so I wouldn't
say that I'm actually playing
particularly conservatively but you know
I just didn't um capitalize on those
advantages I had
um and yeah I mean it feels really good
to get that win to play like a pretty
clean game Let's uh go through the game
actually and take us through the opening
phase yeah so well she always plays the
NIMS though so this opening is not um a
huge surprise although it might be one
of our first names against each other
like I don't think I've ever played into
the nimso against her
um sorry to interrupt I do think we have
a result Wesley so has won his game
against Sam Shanklin
let's continue yeah
ah so Wesley is that another person
who's getting a win for the first time
defending Champion yeah and um okay so
she played this B6 line I think you know
this first part it was kind of obvious
it was my preparation right because I
played quite quickly absolutely
um A3 Bishop E7 yeah
Knight to F4 and we don't want to go too
much into the details of the opening
phase Queen to G yeah Queen to D7 I mean
yeah that's kind of the idea that black
will eventually have to do so the
position looks very aggressive right
when white starts pushing these pawns
but in fact it's it's uh you know the
queen trade is is almost inevitable it's
only a question of like in which you
know should she do like another move
here or do it right away so she played
very naturally I'll tell you like what
was the key moment we'll keep going sure
yeah so I have this plan of trading the
Bishops here I was wondering I was like
should I go should I move my knight away
or should I go just for this uh night
seating along with the trade of nights
one pair of nights at least and so when
I played Bishop A3 and then she took and
I thought you know okay I got what I
wanted but I was like wow this is not so
simple because she's actually pretty
close to playing the move C5 right I
mean she has to go like Rook md8 which
is what she did right
and so this was pretty much the most
challenging uh moments of the game I
think for me right interesting because I
was I was like I was gonna say because I
have A5 I have B4 and I have King E2
like all these moves are possible
um and ultimately I chose King E2
thinking that you know she has so many
plans in this position right one of her
plans is A5 the other plan is Knight of
Fate 96 and the other plan is king of
fake King E7 to D6 so I kind of just
wanted to give her a chance to choose a
plan and I thought my king on E2 would
be you know like for now let's wait
although yeah I mean it's true that if
she plays A5 actually I lose these ideas
of playing A5 or B4 right so she maybe
she should have done that
um but once she didn't so she went for
the night of Fate plan and somehow like
B4 turned out to be quite good
um okay that was I was happy with this
position with the queen side majority
um yeah I see the computer's Edge is not
so big but certainly you know my king is
better my Pawn structure is better and
she has to be extremely yeah she has to
be very precise after 96 Knight D3 okay
well here was the key moment yeah she
had to play F6 right did you see this
movie yeah yeah she can't let my knight
into C6 because actually when I was
playing Knight D3 I was like calculating
all these lines where she plays D4 is C4
because it's quite critical but I
realize it just doesn't work like the
pawns don't really go anywhere and the
Knight on C6 is so strong and the final
moment I'll just show you and this is
what happened in the game yeah this was
the final moment I was like deciding
where to put my king should I go to F3
so that there's not any Knight C5 or
should I go to D2 allowing Knight C5 and
then playing F3 and basically I mean
it's kind of like a beautiful position
here because the king is so good on D2
and when she let's say she plays
something like rookie AIDS right right
so I go uh Rook C1 and all of my pieces
are just on perfect squares like the
pawns are about to go and okay Knight B3
doesn't work because of this kind of
important forcing line very nice yeah
king of Fate uh Knight C8 B2 Rook B1
Rook C8 and rugby two like everything is
in the perfect position for A5 B6 so
that was kind of the last uh critical
line of the game she played Rook to D7
yeah and then you just pick up the Pawns
and this was smooth sailing for you
Irina Irina congratulations a big
victory for you uh how are you feeling
about the tournament oh we're using all
your chances so much better you know I
really just needed I needed I needed to
win a game just to get that taste of
Victory and just to get that confidence
and I also feel like in general I'm
playing you know better game after game
so the first game was a bit shaky
definitely against tatv
um but you know I feel like as long as
you keep playing well like eventually
you should get the points so this was an
important game for me guys
wonderful congratulations Arena
definitely the sun shines a little bit
brighter after Victory ice cream tastes
uh much better as well uh the results
and they're coming in uh hot and happy
let's start with the ladies uh how many
results so far Anastasia we have two
results and both of them are decisive
which is great yes we've been seeing
white washes we're seeing we've been
seeing in the previous rounds uh
excessive number of wins by white yes
today the same same Trend we have so
Jennifer you won against Maurice Suzuki
and in the opening the open section we
have a couple of few results as well so
Wesley saw delivered the point and he
has a victory against Sam Shanklin and
then two draws Darius was
against Jeffrey exactly with lots of uh
very important games still going on
tournament leader Sam sevillan Hans
Neiman Fabi still at a play Christopher
you as well
and we have our defending U.S Champion
Wesley so with Christian Wesley finally
a victory for you comes in round four
yesterday it felt like you were a bit
upset about the whole uh situation but
now finally you broke through how does
that feel yeah I mean who wouldn't be
upset losing to a 15 year old but as I
said now at least I know who I'm playing
and uh no longer playing a teenager but
I was wrong yesterday I still have to
play Hans Neiman 2019.
well I guess I've known Sam for many
years now he was the youth champion in
2018. I played a lot of games with him
as part a lot of games with him and uh
you've sparked as well with him you've
trained with him yeah
I think if I
went with his place in San Francisco
once in 2015 before the U.S championship
and also we were working 2014 before in
Europe preparation for the Trump
Olympiad and then
after that we played here and there like
online practice we were teammates in the
online Olympia in 2020. and uh often
many olympiads so you know him quite
well how do you generally approach this
type of games when you know your
opponent well you know his repertoire
you know his Tendencies as well well I
don't really know if Robert or but I
just uh it's a nice feeling when you
know someone well when I study these
games I kind of know his likes and
dislikes what he's capable of and
whatnot uh so just you know you've been
around for many years
and I remember
in 2000 2011 or something he was
wondering if he should be a jet
professional or do something else and
he's a very successful player I think he
would have done well in any field that
he'd gone to like he like I think he was
if I was correct he was thinking both
uh to have a career in finance or
something like that yeah I think he
would have made a lot more money but but
he chose Jeff and you know yather and I
also chose Jeff it's quite fun too
sometimes you have to follow your
passions for sure and he's definitely a
very passionate uh individual when it
comes to chess yeah that's true I mean
if you're 2700 you can definitely make a
good career absolutely and let's talk
about the game he started off with the
Sicilian did you expect the neither of
uh are you expecting him to play the
Berlin something a bit more tame or it's
hard to predict yeah I mean it's in a
given day he played the neither of many
times last year but uh
been playing guitar sounds very hard to
predict because also played the French
or tarugan but anyway you cannot uh spot
any pattern in his opening play well he
generally plays similar openings in the
same tournament but I think no one has
played uh wait what happened
uh no Darius played D4 against him yes
first yes yeah it's hard to predict I
think generally he plays similar systems
once in the same in the same tournament
yeah so he prepares a certain system for
the tournament at hand and then plays it
throughout it yeah that makes sense
because then you can be more familiar
well probably he's listening to the
interviewer he's like no no I have other
things in my bag the thing filled Cup
last year he was playing the night or
regularly the whole uh the whole
tournament yep yeah you came with this
idea of playing the more
uh peaceful let's say Bishop Tui do not
go into the main lines after Bishop to
E3 how do you like that decision I've
never played this before but I prepared
some lines like this in for the Olympian
and uh
I thought just play what I preferred but
objectively it's nothing because here
uh the reason why I played Rook E1 so I
make officially often white plays Bishop
F3 in Phil Brook E1
but anyway the reason I played rookie
one signed some lines uh like if black
plays Knight C6 then at least my Bishop
can stay on the FM F1 yeah yeah yeah and
he played Knight bd7 A4 yeah I mean here
okay it's quite confusing
and stuff and then and no one really
knows what to do but it does seem like
you guys are following some uh top level
games as well I see bruzzone I see yeah
as well so this has been played before
maybe such a weird movement yes yes
protects the pun but but I was slightly
better here at some point but then like
like Bishop E2
takes yeah a little bit yes just
slightly better yeah but Knight D1 is
probably a terrible movement maybe the
idea with King H2 is terrible uh
a computer likes Knight D5 takes takes
Ed fibers and then follow it up with C4
and Rook V5
yeah
V4 yeah C4 Queen G3 V4 and white
slightly better like Fey Rook V7 let's
get these three pawns connected like
that
um yeah 91 is too passive I didn't like
like black has some D5 ideas I probably
even D5 works here so yeah and you were
also spending a lot of time up to this
point falling behind 20 minutes on the
clock was time for the concerning factor
for you during this game yeah and for
every game this tournament yes two low
on clock I mean it's a bad sign that
that means you're not in good form when
you spend too much time but uh as I said
yesterday it's quite confusing also
having different time controls because
like C determines this thing is an hour
40. take some time to adjust from from
one to the other yeah I think here we
have one of the shortest time controls
which is 90 plus 30. but obviously I
have to speed up just but 91's not a
good move like I thought seems like it
and then you guys got to this position
yeah he could play D5 too yeah Bishop to
C5 B4 F3 look to the bishop E3 and this
moment when he played the move D5 were
you getting concerned at all how did you
assess the position at this point well I
think sure I mean I wanted to try to
play for a win but obviously I'm risking
stuff
yeah it's a scary position for white
because after Rook takes A6 I assume he
has Rook cc8
rcd6 seems to be the right move yeah and
probably white can equal life so I play
Knight F2 obviously not by Rook defe8 is
a theory of error but it is it means
Bishop C5 it seems like yeah I don't
know what he missed but Queen V7 is much
simpler huh and like it never loses or
maybe he can
but I was very I was very surprised by
Rook defeat because I think black I
think famous playing well until then and
I think after Bishop C5 you're
definitely gaining a pretty serious Edge
yeah I mean I'm up on up yeah and after
oh he just made through takes
yeah it's just winning
and once you guys got to this position
yeah it was a smooth conversion I would
say Fed Up on if we go back and move 38
after Queen D2 Rook h8 yeah I spent all
my time figuring out whether ed5 or 90.
I think D5 was correct yeah getting
three points is not
in one side it's no question that you
should just play it Wesley
congratulations an important Victory to
get back to 50 for you and start a new
yeah tomorrow it's my birthday and I
really don't know
an early happy birthday for you yeah
to you as well tomorrow yeah last year I
also played the again the youth
championship for my birthday again
I do I was I was winning but you know
it's not so bad and everything how do
you usually approach those games uh on
your birthday
yeah then I don't like is there anything
different to them
no not really I just
don't I think it's not a good idea to
play in your birthday I I played several
tournaments before on my birthday and uh
um I'll just keep my best button for
it's clearly not ideal I don't know what
the author thinks if it's played and
after your birthday is actually the rest
day are you going to party at home
tomorrow night after the game or yeah
that that that's the plan I have a
birthday cake and birthday cake yeah
yeah and actually we celebrate my
birthday in Minnesota already before
this Thurman I had my breath infant and
stuff
it's uh
because right after this is one
tournament after another but yeah but
it's it's nice it's uh it's
it's it's fun Wesley congratulations
we'll see you tomorrow thank you yeah
quick question for you Wesley uh it's
one of those things that you match up
very very well with Sam Shanklin you
have a marvelous score you've won four
eight draws today you've got your fifth
Victory against no losses uh can you
explain why the match-up is so favorable
for you
uh
I I don't really know I can't really
explain maybe I just know him so well I
played him many games yeah I didn't even
realize that but
um
I I think
also family fun expert opening but I I
try to avoid his preparation mostly when
we play
I I think I just know his style very
well like uh he's an excellent player
but he's also very uh
um
how do you call it he get he's very
streaky like he can play really well or
you can play really badly at some point
so
I just I I guess I kind of know how to
push hit buttons better than others and
uh when he gets slow on time or when he
gets too ambitious and then he makes uh
some oversights that's
when you pounce
all right uh congratulations uh
congratulations happy birthday no
presents from us
yeah I think I think every birthday
after 21 is pretty much the same but
right yeah
very good uh good luck uh for the rest
of the tournament more results uh Sam
sevion a Drew with a Wonder Liang Sam
came in as one of our tournament
co-leaders uh that game between Fabi and
Hans is looming very large these are two
players tied for first coming into
today's round and
um well when we left it some time ago
Fabi was the one nursing an extra pawn
and what happened seen that seems like
uh with this move well somewhere around
here
Knight C8 F4 wow wow that was a move
that came out of the blue takes takes
and well for the moment one two three
four one two three four five still that
extra Pawn in uh fabby's pocket e-force
hanging
four is hanging uh feels like
definitely uh Fabi is in great position
to take it clear
yes yes it's it's sad it's very very sad
but uh this is a passer great position
but maybe not as uh great as it was a
few moves ago right well right here this
is actually a key moment uh I'm a little
bit surprised by the move at night to C8
to be honest I was thinking okay if I
play rookie seven you go Rook C6 and I
do believe that was actually move 40.
Rook C7 and I suppose you go B5 now I
take a bond I just like take a bond
invite you like this is actually a
position I would rather Embrace as black
the Knight is doing a great blockade of
the pawn this is a passer the surpassers
and maybe on just a good day I can come
over and collect so I thought that Fabby
was cruising
is he still cruising Christian oh
absolutely not no no absolutely not
actually not at all right now his wow
Hans is very very close to equalizing
wow the position yeah and how to do so
you take only five perhaps take on A7
just take on A7 immediately yeah if you
take on E5 I think I take back with the
rook and I Target that Bishop on H5 and
you don't have time to take that pawn on
A7 I see which might become a bit
uncomfortable for you later on in game
still plenty of pitfalls in the position
for uh Hans even in this situation so
let's take a look F3 sure let's defend
let's do 24 okay
six
let's go Bishop back to well sorry I
think no no no no no one second uh what
did you expect
uh take on C6 yes I can take on C6 I
think yeah okay so what is the body
count as we go through all of this so
let's say I take
it's funny uh that two versus none
yeah what to say about this one yeah but
you're quite Advanced though so I didn't
have to be quite careful because that
King is coming in Fast and this ZIP
seven Pawn controls G6 Square very
important no no checks from behind so
let's go Rook F6 all right it's a very
tricky end game I have to I would like
to see your Rook actually
Square five and then I go King F2 okay
or maybe B5 yeah even though I don't
want to allow you to go King F3 I
understood okay understood yeah now do I
want to take the pawn or do I just want
to
try to
yeah it's it's dangerous it feels like
there's still chance for okay five
yeah but hey I like it I like it so
anytime I try to go on a on the file oh
that's actually a good point this is
funny I'm kind of uh how do you say
follow me uh across the board think
maybe it's winning still I don't know so
let's go
I might be I might be in the uh Square
no but then I go B5 and that's kind of
like a standstill right exactly
you're right go B6 and then I just
simply Rook takes A7 was played
and what is this draw this is a draw
yeah I just go king of two King F3 yeah
yeah wow wow uh but that's that's not an
easy concept right
wow I'm I like the the move that I found
very visual was right here this move uh
I must say the move F3 F4 came as a big
surprise whoa uh again as you were you
you'd mentioned yourself Anastasia you
know you don't these unusual Pawn breaks
when normally it's so protected you
don't think about it that this move F4
maybe it was brilliant timing by Hans if
he saves his positions save this
position and we do have F3 on the board
by the way uh Mazel Tov I mean hats off
just good good play uh it does get
rewarded another move that we didn't
really talk about too much this bishop
looks so strange uh rookie seven and if
you go Rook here and once again
I mean I feel like I'm going to try to
explain yes not so many squares left for
this bishop but maybe still I can
survive like Bishop G4 let me go here
maybe uh just kind of
trying to waltz into the position with
you know a very stately March King D4
King E3 for sure this king is more
active yes but maybe interesting we'll
definitely keep our eye on this uh We've
made time travel and uh time pressure I
think maybe is a good time for us to
recharge our batteries and take a break
go through the security checks
that are required
yes very important and we'll see you on
the other side of the parade
thank you
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
United States
the St Louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant Central West End has
established itself as a premier Global
destination for chess and is comprised
of two unique non-profit institutions
the chess club and Scholastic Center of
St Louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays hosts to
all major tournaments including the U.S
chess championships and the sinkfield
cup one of the strongest chess
tournaments globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries led by an expert
commentary team of grand Masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess with a specific focus on
bringing the benefits of Chess to
Children throughout the St Louis area
research shows children who play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence the chess club is
highly engaged with the local community
bringing Scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 Schools providing hundreds
of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club is the World Chess Hall of
Fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the U.S and World Chess Halls
of Fame
Cutting Edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts paired with
world-class art Innovative programming
explores the intersection of Chess art
and culture
visitors can enjoy interactive programs
designed around the exhibitions and
monthly music in the galleries the World
Chess Hall of Fame is nothing you expect
and everything you love three different
Galleries and a premier gift shop
highlight the culture history and
creativity Behind The Game come visit
play chess leave enriched to learn more
about the St Louis chess campus visit
stlchesscampus.org
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back everyone here we are around
four of us championships and we have
results yes we do and the ladies what do
we have so far Jennifer you made one
against Sophia nice if I keep they made
the draw with against baking and even a
question won her first game in this
championship against the threeta exactly
and the four games remaining a key game
is between Alice Lee and Roo Yang Yang
and Alice has been nursing an extra Pawn
in the Bishops of opposite color
position we think it's a draw but it's
nice to be nursing the extra Pawn in the
open section we also have a lot of
results uh only two games remaining if
I've got this right we have a very
crucial game between uh Hans Neiman and
Fabi Fabi has been on the better side
but those two players entered today's
competition type for first so uh the
winner of that game will be our clear
leader in the meanwhile Christopher you
also tied for first he won two lost one
he's up against Alexander Linderman but
it's actually Lenderman who has a
winning position despite the very scary
looking Bishop on F3
uh looking at that position there can we
check the position yes absolutely so the
this bishop on F3 is really nice right I
mean you know it's an automatic that you
go Queen to H6 and H1 equals mate the
problem is that the queen can't move it
has to defend uh the d8 square for
example Queen H6 Rook uh d a eight and
white is the first one
as we'll see just a second sorry yes
this one and this one that's clear King
G7 oops excuse me King G7 and this one
and this one that's clear
or is it yes
it's very nice uh you were about to ask
me okay after Rook d8 King G7
immediately yes let's say if I try to
move right then I could check unpleasant
check yes yeah and then I'm not gonna
let you deliver mate I'll take the queen
before uh so the the problem is in the
current position Christopher is actually
stuck after the move Rook d8 he can't uh
bring his Queen away from the control of
the similarly this Rook would also love
to Checkmate on the background The Rook
can't leave even if it you know even if
you had some ability to play Rook H7
again I would
um win by playing uh to the d8 square in
the meanwhile I'm ready to take this
Pawn I'm ready to take this pawn and
deliver it take this one is it just
let's say that despite all the threats
the white skin we have to admit that
black king is also kind of naked yes it
is yes it is Rook takes E5 Rook H5 will
show why the missing H Pawn so uh
Christopher you uh two victories uh
Bravo Chris defer but one defeat and it
might be a second defeat and all
decisive games uh 15 year old doesn't
like draws no no no he doesn't like
drugs black and white uh Ray Robson
already made a draw but uh back over to
you Christian and the Fabi game what's
happening yeah I'm looking at this one
and I'm trying to understand what's
happening in this end game thus farby
Harbor any uh hopes of potentially
converting this one and it's all about
the next move what is Hans Neiman going
to do is he going to go Rook to C7 or
Rook 2 A6 a critical choice you have to
attack and create your own counter
chances by attacking the pawn on C6 if
you start with Rook to C7 the problem is
this end game is actually lost because
right now I'm not going to take your
upon I'm not going to go after your G4
Pawn what I am going to do is defend my
Pawn on C6 and we'll understand the
difference between rookon C7 and Rook on
A6 in just a second king to F3 for
example is followed by H3 and with a
rook on the a file you would be able to
capture that on H2 and then catch the
pawn with a move Rook to A1
unfortunately with the Rook on C7 you're
very far away from the action and you
cannot do that this is completely losing
right now for white if you try to go
Rook to A7 I'm going to go H2 I'm going
to use this Pawn as a decoy and after
King to G5 you pick that guy up I'm
going to take on G4 and I'm going to be
able to actually convert that position
this is not looking good but
what if white goes Rook to A6 right this
seems to be very actually close uh to a
draw after King to E3 by the way with
the bishop already on G4 you don't have
the option of Defending that pawn on C6
with the move Rook to E6 so you have to
eliminate the bishop first Knight takes
G4 take on G4 and now maybe Rook to E6
the problem is after King to F3 once
again we understand you do this I can
take on F4 I can even go Rook to A8
first and this is just a simple draw so
everything is in the balance right now
will he find Rook to A6 Hans Neiman that
is or will he go Rook to C7 and actually
probably lose this game big moment right
now it's all in the balance and the next
move is critical
time a factor at all uh Anastasia is
this very important decision uh the game
seven minutes yes some time right 14
minutes
enough time to pick up the right move
but still I mean it still can do any
mistake it is not an easy situation
right now let's not forget the players
played this long game already and by
this moment you still have to make
really difficult decisions it's
frightening to think that you know you
play these six five six hour games and
then you get to a moment where it's just
this is it this one move uh makes all
the difference in the world Rook C7
versus Rook A6 it's not easy to spot
that difference but once you calculate
it then you become aware that Rook A6 is
actually the mandatory move again I'm
expecting Christopher to lose this game
after Rook D5 and again how so how
serious or not is Alice's Lee Advantage
I've always felt that Alice had real
chances whereas well you were less
enthusiastic about her no it cannot be
serious
why why why so um
how do you say uh the sour this looks
really good I mean if I'm in Alice's
shoes I'm putting the bishop on e4 and
and I'm pushing the pawn and I'm going
King B5 and I'm taking I'm laughing at
you yes oh I was the
authority
[Laughter]
excellent decision yes I think it's like
you can still keep changes at least you
can keep trending it after again so all
right let's try to give you everything
you ever want okay okay all right let's
go Rook D3 Rook David oh sorry no no
[Laughter]
should we explain to uh Christian the
idea of a double attack this is very
important so the double attack occurs
when we hit the road
okay okay
I told you I'm going to give you
everything yeah we appreciate we
appreciate it look to D3 is everything
you ever wanted correct so I'm not going
to give you let us help King G7 thank
you yes King G7 and you're giving us
everything we ever wanted King B5 all
right let's go Rook D3 now Rook David
three now got it now you can do it okay
now it's funny because I actually
thought Alice should have just put a
picture
a long time ago but we can do it okay
Rook to E3 B3
to B3 whoa whoa whoa I know he's
additional stupid Bishop B1 uh
don't say a word
uh now
um
we need uh we need both
our Bishop on we we need to combine our
Pawn to F6
and okay so let's put it let's put it
here Bishop to C6
and we're going to go very slowly F 4 F5
so I do have Bishop C5 but that's
probably not going to help me too much
just it's a temporary yes yeah
some yes
rugby two I just want to have all my
pieces on dark squares yeah you know
what I'm afraid being F6 I will tell you
later
that we will see Bishops
now I wait yes
Rook boy one yes now I wait
okay I I
um okay
do you have a threat well maybe Rook
takes C5
I'm not sure but uh it that's the basic
idea that I'm going to put my Pawn on F5
I'm gonna secure my bishop and then I
want to sacrifice an exchange for this
guy and that guy
that's my only goal I mean that that
makes a lot of sense all right I'll let
you do that sacrifice my Rook forever
too okay let's see if that gives you
everything you ever want okay let's keep
going Rook B1 okay so now I've got my
Bishop anchor let's go I'll let you take
on C5 and I've got everything I've ever
wanted I go Rook B1 let's see and look
at that even when it gives me everything
it's still zero the table base goes zero
I will let you go to B7 wow and then I
don't see a way for you to make any
progress I'll keep my Rook on B1 just
because I don't know I don't want to
have it on on the second I understand
but so yeah once you get to B7 I want to
have it on the first rank yes and this
is drawn according to the table base
you're right yes well you go King C7 I
give you a check that's clear you go
King d8 I go back you go King V8 I go
back
so I always give you check or go back on
the B file
and if you try to block with the bishop
the problem is I'm going to have time to
sacrifice on B7 and the bishop is not
going to be connected to the F5 Pawn
right if like if I if I get this well
let's just say a moment ago uh excuse me
pardon me in this position if I put my
Bishop here
and you had given me a check for
argument's sake
and another check
and another check you yeah right even if
you get this excuse me I'm ready to take
this Pawn
um
now it's winning how about that uh the
difference is I've got Bishop E4 and I'm
covering the pawn oops I just did it in
the wrong uh moment right here I guess I
had to go Rook here
and that's strong
yes Bishop C6 to take the pawn yes ah
you take the bone and no Bishop before
you exactly all right well uh I try yes
yes no no we have to try and it's I also
depend you know practical game has
different yes exactly most players are
very tired by this moment and still you
have to find them defending defending
defending the whole game not always
sorry uh we left Anna zetanski versus
Megan Lee quite some time ago Megan uh
was really on the back foot she was
defending A5 she was defending C6
um
A5 is gone but maybe she's got some
counter attacks going on on the king
side yes I think so some of four
some f4s even though like G6 Square
seems squeak could not just covering it
right Brooks as well
maybe she has this chance to try I can
see that Anna is anxiously ready to
bring her Knight back guys yes blunder
alert blunder alert the Hans Neiman
versus Fabiano caruana game really
he did not play route to A6 he played
maybe something else King Kings King G2
but after Rook to B5 which was
immediately answered by Fabiano Fabiano
right now has a winning position the
Knight Will land on E5 defending C6 and
attacking the bishopon G4 as well that's
his dreams right now for Hans Neiman and
Fabiano might have gotten a golden
opportunity to win this one wow by the
way Knight E5 is like the picture
perfect square it defends C6 as you were
mentioning hits G4 also defends F7 yes
and hits F3 so that if the bishop ever
were to run away uh there's a rook takes
oh oh we just saw 24 was played but
that's not happening that's not
happiness Knight to E5 85 guys
and
even three
okay King G5 yes okay this is it holds
yes King to five Hearts you don't take
of course this bishop you take it after
yes and even there's ideas of C5 and
Rook to B3 check
uh in the position uh wow big big big uh
opportunity here for Fabi as he won
sometimes like when uh Arena just came
on she's so experienced once you get
your first win it's sort of like those
butterflies kind of go away and you
you're reminded that you're in a
tournament I mean still the covid uh
pandemic you know not playing there's a
lot of rust though going not amongst
these guys but uh that first win really
does sometimes open up the floodgates
and uh helps a great deal uh wow uh
I didn't expect that it's still not over
there are still some conversion
difficulties but it does feel like
Fabiano has all the chances in the world
to take this uh full point home wow and
again now I see the clocks are
yeah we can't spend a lot of time
actually on this move he probably felt
that he has to have that was a critical
moment yes he felt it but he made the
wrong decision yes
no we're playing 95 95 is not as yet to
be played uh alternative now that I'm
looking at it there's an altar I can't
believe I didn't think of it right away
Knight B6 would Chase The Rook I sub so
that I want to take this Pawn obviously
maybe Rook A5 and Rook F5 is is uh
trouble yes
maybe you know Roxy for there okay
but that square for the Knight on E5
that is just a gorgeous Square the fans
attack it's ready to go Knight D3
attacked upon on B4 there's so many
ideas with this Knight on E5 that's why
it's a good idea to put the knight in
the center because it looks good there
but this night I like this expression of
a Thor uh you know Norse god of thunder
this night on E5 just is just ruling the
board for me it's like octopus more
octopus
legs tentacles yes oh
and by the way the other remaining game
also features a co-leader as Christopher
by the way 95 is on the board game 95.
Christopher you we just excuse me uh we
saw the move Rook D5 rookie eight Queen
D2 uh oh it's getting really bad now
because Rook is coming over uh Bishop
takes E4 Rook Queen G7 doing his best to
yeah
exactly you can't go to uh to G8 you
have to put the bishop back in the
morning remember that Bishop was so
beautiful on F3 now it's kind of like
cringing in the corner uh but uh
Alex actually saw even a a better way of
finishing the game Rook d8 and that is a
very very powerful move as well because
any trades or is it going to feature
Queen H4 checks at the end of the day
oops yes and queen H6 is the only move
where is my mate
I see some options
I thought I was mating or winning
material easily
um I could just play Bishop D3 and play
Queen and Parliament game but I thought
I had something more concrete than this
just a second
had scratch what
no
this should be well I could just go and
do a bishop ending right
shouldn't I just go into a bishop that
should be winning oh also okay because I
always uh will be able to escort
the past passer pass this B7 square but
what if I go Rook D6 right now by the
way we have Bishop C6 on the board yeah
and what is
[Music]
right it just repeats the position
well here I'm more tempted by Queen D6
dare I suggest the slow study and
finally can I just exploit the back rank
for a moment
uh how do you uh you have Queen D7 well
that's the bishop ending or if I say
he's on the board
what's on the board
and by the way I'm probably not forced
to go into the end game right I can go
Queen to F6
after Queen V8 Queen D7 Queen F6 check
28 Queen D7 queen of sexual Queen G7 and
queen H4 and now I'm winning another
Pawn
that's what I wanted to do is to find a
way to take the G4 Pawn yes exactly I
was very uh greedy H7 pick up the G4
pawn and I mean you do get a check on B1
but okay we'll still take time to
four minutes and 40 seconds but for uh
Chris for you six minutes and 50 for
Alex landerman but the position is so
simple
and this is just going to be a win for
Alex I think Alex is a little bit
nervous it looks like yeah yes a little
rocking back and forth going on there uh
by the way I just like to Echo the words
of Wesley so for just a moment because
it's been a pet peeve of mine for many
many many years this idea that the time
controls are different you can go and
you can play a different rapid chest in
for example the grand chess tour then a
rapid chess in the feed a and
he was complaining rightfully so in my
view that these different time controls
make it really difficult for the players
to adjust for themselves and here he
called this classical chess event a fast
fast
time Control meeting candidates probably
yes compared to example the candidates
yeah and I think that for the play
players that's that's really really
off-putting you know it'd be like in
track and field that you have a hundred
meters but then the next race 110. and
then the next race is 120 you know just
standardize it just across the whole
board three plus two and five in Blitz
et cetera Etc and then you have also
Bobby Fischer chess you know just if you
to attach the normal ones right
classical ones okay let's also play 960.
right yes and then also let's go to the
back house chess oh yes and then you
have different rooms in the evening uh
Queen H4 check immediately just saying
hey I I want to pick up the spawn if you
play King G7 which which is actually on
the board I want to play Queen G5 check
now where would you like to go
all that
asks a version
came to age seven King to H7
there there has to be something Queen G8
check right
I'm making some very very nice inroads
uh I like this he's just gonna take the
pot yes he'll just stick with me
no but it's still I don't know I don't
know I no no no I would play Queen you
well no I am going to take the pawns but
I'm going to take them all but first I'm
going to stop you from playing Queen D1
then I'm going to set up nicely some
Checkmate patterns uh like for example
queen h8 king G6 Bishop E4 types of
patterns
uh but this is one I've Overkill the
vultures are watching uh let's go back
to this all-important match between Hans
and uh Fabi Fabi just picked up the bee
Pawn I think uh Hans suddenly realized
after Rook A4 Knight E5 King H3 King G5
he's out of moves yes the pawn on F3 if
you move the bishop there goes the pawn
on F3 even move the Rook which actually
occurred there goes the pawn on B4 and
we're up to date with the players a
dirty little trick by the way
Rook H5 check and Rook uh F5 so King F6
right away
so he's like provoking him to take the
bishop maybe but I don't think three
minutes for a Fabiano I think it's I
would just be like hey man I like to
keep all my pawns but what if I go oh
look at five now after oh sorry six okay
five yes and then King Joseph
said right okay because King is six is
like no King E6 is 10.
your king E7 is a decent Square yes
yes Rook C5 King D6 I like that and what
if I go Bishop H5
7 instead of king after King E7 Bishop
page five Bishop so I'm kind of
encouraging you to capture this Knight
right yeah yeah
I'll take it look I'll take that night
has been giving me the whole game I'm
gonna take it the the nightmarish night
yes
okay uh a fair that's fair uh we do have
this position on the board Rook H5 so
what is a concerning Factor right now
for Fabiano caruana is his time he only
has two minutes on the clock
I think the one thing I want to avoid
was when I ever took your Bishop I
really wanted you to have to recapture
with your F3 plus recapturing with your
king really gives you great chances to
save the game very good point yes
okay okay basically saying if you go
hunting
for my Pawn
you may be trapped
this is
ugly
uh Bishop I mean uh suddenly it's not
going to be easy for your uh so
Rook B5 and nicely laid a trap uh here
no absolutely very good move by Fabiano
so what to play now Bishop [ __ ] fire
what this is actually the position so
let's go Rook F5 maybe yeah
and I will not 100 sure of where the
king should go King G7 or King E7
um I I pick one for now but I reserve
the right
so let's say I go wish page five yes
okay with the idea that I want to take
now only four right and if you go Knight
G6 well wait a minute
there's a yeah so no Rook takes F4 don't
think about Rook takes F4 two
uh that's why King is seven
[Laughter]
so let's go that's a good point finally
now we understand the genius of King E7
but I like the way you think yesterday
King E7 is critical actually yes at the
engine King seven is critical okay King
G7 allows what we just H5 what we saw
and that's problematic right now
again
I remember what Petra where did he play
it
well that was not a good time
to focus on the there's the clock that
it was very it was a very nice picture
of the clock
was played the right yeah
courtesy of our production team
I remember Petra uh liverwick who was
the wife of Victor korchnoy she said a
woman is always right yes and always
it's not
and she has a right to change her mind
but also Metro
yeah
what if we call Bishop H5 now guys
Bishop H5 well isn't that the trick that
I was just uh saying that now I'll go F4
and what if I take on H4 no no no no and
this is the trick no that's fine but I
think on H4 yep you're welcome
so
and how are you going to stop that my
Pawn very good question
um your Rook is am I even close
wow
it's not getting the C2 anytime soon and
The Rook well it's pretty entombed that
is a depressing looking position it does
it isn't it yes you just watch the pawn
forward yes go a little one yes she's
storming down the board yeah bring glory
to you and to me
mm-hmm and sorry but
wait what if I take on F4 after F6 uh
pardon me uh
but we discussed 93 Rook takes h4s ah
I don't know why we weren't seeing this
uh rip takes should we explain uh King
opponent games basics
[Laughter]
oh wait I think I'm in
in the Square no how was fun seriously I
mean the square yeah no yes
is it true yes he's right
he certainly is oh my goodness I thought
this Pawn was but wait wait wait wait so
you take on H5 yes and now can you stop
me from going to the score with Kingston
please yes
now I'm afraid of my body say yes my uh
my table base
is saying it's drawn so C5 King G4 yes
yes wow remarkable
no it was drawn it was remarkable so
Bishop h
5
35 seconds for Hans guys how much you
need two minutes and 35 seconds he needs
to make a move soon
and happy though but Fabby was under one
Bobby one minute and 49 seconds
so actually it's a draw yes if he finds
it no no no no well that's the Rook
takes there for yeah yeah yes yes yes
after which page five uh F6 is probably
I was being yeah
is actually King to E6 oh come on
yeah it's just a good way to pass the
time well you defend it I mean you want
to play C5 yes but you cannot do yes
because so King E6 okay we take apart
C5 or what C5 and what else we take upon
no no no no no no go back go back go
back go back go back apologies go back
and that's the difference now Knight D3
it's too deep yes now Knight D3 yeah
you're dropping this guy with check
um King E7 oh oh King E7 and then I
can't play Rook F5 because so now if you
take on H4 yes now we're going to go for
the same game and I have King E5 can you
imagine away we do have Bishop a H5
there wasn't really too much choice for
Hans in in any case Fabiano finds King
E6 right now this is the money move
wow channeling uh Maurice Ashley there
with the honeymoon
oh my goodness but he only has one
minute and 25 seconds to calculate
everything we just did in the past 10
minutes exactly exactly that's why he is
yes in the world so I will have to
but he has to show once again
his skills if he wants to win this game
yeah it's not an easy task it turned out
to be really really difficult yeah it's
really tricky oh my word is it ever
I really didn't expect that no no no
seriously and by the way sorry if if I
just play the mundane move here is this
I take yeah I I assume you have to take
right yes
um this might be enough
I might be able to escape oh my goodness
what a tense moment right now guys
because this is 25 seconds for Fabiana
make a move
will he find King E6 I I like how the
fans say always
no he plays six Knight G6 so what I I
was just in bed it takes the night I was
just investigating Knight G6 because
this is a draw now this is attractive
it's such an attractive looking move
Rook takes F4 and this is what we
discussed right now right this G5 Rook
G4
still plenty of opportunities for white
to go wrong of course King H4 for
example in G5 but can I play King E6 yes
and wait
uh yes this idea is really cool yes and
I'm going for that same but I'm not sure
if you are so King G4 but aren't I
aren't I uh playing uh but I go from
behind
I was going to go King E5 to cut you off
from F4 yeah
but when even that no but I have the
e-pawn he did play G5 by the way Rook G4
and now
and now king of six probably I don't
know and then trying to push this Pawn
exactly we have six and you do have to
be careful because if you do play F4 too
quickly I have Rook B3 check yes so be
very careful
King F6 you have to drop back with your
Rook or Rook G3 check oh my God if I go
think it's two or I don't know then he's
saying you can take and go King and uh
you can have six on the board guys
you're saying Rook G1 is box as enforced
no Rook G2 is yeah
don't ask me why oh my God no no please
do not ask me why no no
by the way just uh breaking news uh
taught to have won her game and uh
against Sabina Bravo but how is Rook G1
losing in Rook G2 wrong that's
impossible with no time I mean even if
it was a correspondence game I want to
say it would take days to understand
why Rook G because Rook G1 it's an
automatically yeah if you're not playing
F4 if you're convinced yourself that F4
loses to Rook G3 you say to yourself
well I'll drop back with my Rook put my
king on G4 and play Rook to C1 this is a
ridiculously difficult end game
and Christian did you get it why what's
happening let's just go for towards some
lines I can try but it's better to just
wait and see what he's going to do right
now right F4 that's the wrong decision
Rook to B3 now wins yes
yeah that one is actually easy and
understandable why you would do it so
great that we didn't need to understand
the difference between well thank you
exactly I mean as an author we don't say
unclear as a commentator we say only
time will tell
stop it stop it oh my goodness F4 okay
so let's understand it uh Anastasia
check now presumably we don't want to
allow a G3 so we've got to go King H2
and presumably this is uh where you know
to be three King to H2 and because your
king is so
yes it's far away far far away something
like either C5 immediately or Rook F3 in
order to cut off the king along the file
and then this King Controls this pawn
and this Pawn Motors up the board at
least that's the plan
now uh after Rook don't tell me you have
to play another Rook check or something
Fancy no not C5 not C5 not C5 Rook B2
does that spoil the advantage no
no that's just for it does no it's no it
just says now my king gets closer yes
yes no he played King H3 he's losing
again yes
Fabi just thought he'd gain uh you know
a minute on the clock that's what Rook
B2 was all about
oh my God
no but it's the same note it just
repeats the position right and he will
play King H2 of course
there's nothing else to do don't worry
don't worry Kristen it's okay okay so
the point is Christian after King H2 G
takes F4 Rook takes F4 King C King E5
yes you're not supposed to play C5
you're supposed to play King King D4
clear and you maintain and now the king
should
and we have again the king H2 let's see
Fabiano right now he's pretty much
forced to take on F4 because exactly
Dugo Rook to B3 I can claim after King
H2 if you go Rook B3 3-4 repetition with
King H2 right he will take on F4 so he
has to take on F5
yes that's clear and easy up to a minute
because I'm looking at this it just
looks like he's got two seconds or
something he's up to a minute right okay
one minute for Fabiano and you have to
go towards the center of course
yeah no that's on automated
take on H4 this is the key moment once
again so you're saying C5 draws but do
not play the move C5
remarkable because I've looked to see a
rook to H5 yeah
and I force your king in front of your
pawn and that's going to slow things
down for you
okay this is kind of instinct because
you just don't have enough time to
calculate them three three that wins
this is the best one okay not the best
one but that wins
the best with enough I mean anything
that wins is pretty good
on this one definitely wins yes wow a
great move by Fabian so for example
ah yes now it's time to take the pawn so
what else time to collect
Ive
okay so help us out if we go Rook saying
that's probably the best move yes C5 no
check no no C5 C5 makes a draw no yes
okay fantastic so and we have a
handshake uh
I
as Alex Lenderman Knox
off uh one of our tournament co-leaders
Christopher you uh all the size of games
poses the biggest problems right now
it's so difficult not to play King G2
though to get closer to the pawn right
Rook H6 on the other hand this is the
key move right now yes
it's the key move in order to keep the
game going yeah he plays the through
cage six
okay and now it's Rook C3 that has to be
played no come on wow
this is crazy so now first of all you
know but but I could I could easily find
the move C5 not because I necessarily
knew what I was doing but just from the
simple idea that I could be four C3 is
on the board guys he found it yeah I
could be forced to put my king in front
of my pawn and then I would get worried
that I don't have the resources to win
this so I would find the move Rook C3
out of fear
that uh and by the way now I'm
threatening to pick up the pawn with the
king so far away I have to convince
myself and that's an easy thing to do
that Rook C3 is the right move I mean uh
even though it's a fantastic moving
problem well uh the deductive reasoning
says that's the only move yes so what
about now look at work
H4 now I can go C5
now we're allowed now we're allowed yes
okay but still I mean this game it shows
that it's not an easy walk for five but
I mean it has to find lots of well it's
not just that it's it goes to show how
difficult victories are in the in this
year's U.S championships uh you know
getting a winning Advantage is never
enough I mean actually winning the game
and
you know you it's only one when they
signed the score sheets too by the way
exactly yes cannot relax you have to
keep your concentration all the time and
like remember all these technical
positions the king is far away we have
to cut it right still I mean it still
takes time
uh by the way another breaking result is
Talia made a draw against Rochelle uh Wu
that was a very interesting uh grunfeld
with the white Pawn getting the D6 asset
or liability but a draw on that game
by the way uh I think for tell you
that's four draws in a row and she'll be
like
um Arena was kind of getting nervous she
needs to get some victories here we go
King G2 okay
take the pawn
but now I think he oh very very big
result uh Megan Lee lost against Anna
zatonski one of our leaders yes one of
the co-leaders so that means for Alice
if she could win
a big Point ahead of the field King
takes E4 let's just uh let's put that on
the board I refresh my
you feel that already Fabi knows this
energy yes he technically is aware of
the fact that he's winning because he's
playing fast already yes
there's no more hesitation
the idea that the king would step in
front of the pawn and now uh that's an
easy escort then we instantly understand
that the pawn goes home therefore Rook
to D6 to cut off the king but the nice
part is a move like King E3 cuts off
whites King as well that's a nice one
yeah yeah there's no there's no way for
white to get closer and then I'm just
going to chaperon that pawn all the way
down right and you you don't I mean you
don't want to blow a hard earned Victory
by allowing the white king to Simply get
in front of the pawn and that's why King
E3 of course is on the board yes
he's decent at this game
King is going to go to D2 and park
itself nicely uh along the C file no
more checks the pawn will
um
you can't stop the pawn from advancing
either I think he'll resign soon the
Feeling by the way maybe we'll play a
couple of moves
were expecting
you can do
I think you have two maybe two yes
they're still going to play King of two
it's
still a technical task but
Fabiano should have this one in the back
I think your water bottle just exploded
I was jumped out of my scene on that one
was that yours
I think so
foreign
Don't Be Afraid everybody's safe
everybody
I've never seen this under control good
good good okay
but now we know there's the king going
to go to C2
hide the king hide the king indeed
here I actually would hesitate because I
might convince myself that C1 is
actually even a better Square
good enough I suspect that this moment
that there's a number of winning uh
lines for uh Fabi okay C5
cushion baby push them baby
check
five
oop excuse me King F2 on my analysis
board in C5 so now we're actually
threatening Rook to D3 and then the pawn
really does get uh there so I suspect
the best chance that white has it this
is that moment is King E2 to stop this
Rook D3 if it even if it's only
temporary
yeah it's not it's not going well for
hands in this game but yeah still
sometimes
and by the way this will be our first
win with black in some time we've been
talking about white washes uh our
victories and the many victories that
we've been having in the last two rounds
we're really we're really dominated by
uh White pieces
I'm still impressed that uh Hans is
still in the game I mean yes of course
it's already lost but I mean there were
a few moments he could actually lose it
very quickly but exactly still stayed
Rook C6 by still fighting yeah
I was one this critical moment none of
these guys go down easily no no no and
they'll come in and they'll say I wanted
to resign on move 12 but never did yeah
sure yeah we don't believe you nobody
believes
right Rook C6 okay so he's trying to say
like your Rook is a little bit funny if
the pawn was on C3 there's nothing to
discuss but because you know you've got
to move your pawn and get your Rook out
of the way uh some there there are some
technical uh issues that you have to
deal with yes but the problem is I'm
gonna go C4 yes and I'm going to
make them most natural movekin to be to
by the way guys with a victory here Fabi
is actually going to go in clear first
exactly uh the Christopher uh
Christopher you use laws by the way
um makes it uh that these two players
uh financially for the first spot for
the first place yes exactly and he will
be a sole leader that's important yes of
course now it will bring
lots of confidence to Fabi right the
last two were especially a win with some
black pieces that's true and happiness
not to mention his uh you know friends
also and right seconds
Alejandro was helping him right now
right right and Christian who is always
rooting for his speaking is his friend
it's good for the podcast guys it's good
for the podcast that's exactly right
exactly right so pragmatically right who
speaks about friends
let's not forget why we are here right
I'm joking of course no we appreciate it
but this isn't actually I I must say I
really do like this move best King D2
it's such an annoying move for Hans
because obviously White's King wants to
get as close to the pawn as possible
whereas the black king just rules that
out and any Rook check is going to be
met by Rook d 3 and that's the nice way
of building a bridge so Rook C8 on the
board we now expect C4 oh boy that was
played so quickly
Rook C7 and on the board and Han says
okay try to promote this pawn and let's
see
of course but now I'm just keep playing
exactly so we're gonna play Rook to C1
so that the idea is that after Rook
check King here King here now we get our
Pawn to C3 and now we can kind of
release the room somehow I never like to
see this like for example
after King C2 maybe I can go King E3 ah
but then you go rookie one track okay
that's not good
so I wanted to have the second rank open
for my Rook that's why I wanted to go
King E3 here and C3 Rook H7 that's
interesting uh he actually played Rook
C2 a kind of a cagey move kind of saying
okay uh when I do move my king I'm gonna
be able to do it with a discovered check
precisely whether that's meaningful or
not I think it
not that meaningful in fact the I'll go
King C3 check and what were you saying
about the you wanted to keep the second
rank clear well now that's not possible
anymore
um so King goes to 21 okay just as I
expected they're still considering maybe
to go to E3 what
King to E1 okay has a chance to
well it I mean The Rook on on C2 is just
like the worst what's happening what
happens yes doubting his decision at
this point
so probably he thinks also about King
history right now but okay the end of
the day but you saw it okay everybody
should know this right to come back with
your king to the place you you have been
and think again right for the second
time maybe you made a mistake and you
can do a better move
Rook H2
o about to fill it or building a bridge
the detach this game uh-huh
not that it matters too much at this
point
everything is losing yeah this is uh we
used to say as at least class players
that this is a book
yeah the same expression
you know which expression we had also
like this position I can win even
against Kasparov I don't know why we had
this but but this like it's so waiting
the position Gary Casper yes
if it's changed you know after Gary
which is
I don't think so but I could win this
position against Magnus Carl yes for
example yes but but they used to hear it
this way interesting oh come on stop
playing this position I could even be
Bobby fisher fisher right okay I I do
remember them saying that in the New
York chest Circles by the way I could
even be Bobby Fischer in this position
Rook check King the end again we're
looking at King C2 Pawn comes to C3 and
uh inevitably the black pawn will
promote and uh well I think that the
Fabi could win this uh with almost no
time on his clock now and also without
the pieces wow
let me just check on the ladies to see
what games are going on there's a single
game the Alice versus Rue yang
wow she did sacrifice an exchange but
she didn't get both the bishop and the
pawn which means that that game has to
be now drawn rugby too well let's
calculus for young lady who is trying
and trying to use all her chances that's
also a sign of uh of a really good
player yeah in future great she could
have done it long time ago just make it
so and go home no no she keeps playing
the size for King B3 rook d8 and was
ready to go to C3 push the pawn yep
that would be the best
Pawn you have to give a check not
allowed upon the C2 and then I give the
king to Sita
[Music]
and
Fabby has actually been picking up a lot
of time over the course of the last half
dozen moves I mean one moment he was
under a minute now it looks like he has
comfortably more than two and we might
actually be seeing a resignation soon
yes yes of course because it's like
kinds of course understands your hands
might have even up at this point
come on you got to give a spike check
of course right right he gave so many
spices
they're not very pleasant to give yeah
your opponent only has one way and it's
winning
so the idea is that uh black will want
to drive this King away from the pawn
and a nice way of doing that is to drop
back with the rook and check so that you
will get your Pawn
exactly what father is doing okay
okay now here is
wins this game and pancakes clear lead
he's in clear first uh thanks to this
back to back uh wins in rounds three and
four quickly turning our attention to
the soul remaining game uh in the ladies
section Alice Lee versus Roo Yang Yen
and strange let me just see how she did
give up the exchange
because uh okay she kind of got the best
she could hmm and with this she gave up
and she's hoping that the Rook will come
to the B file so she can you know block
okay but no The Rook came back
and
this is how we've got this position
and
yeah no no
uh although a lot of games a lot of
moves have been played it's not enough
Alice will make a draw and uh back over
to you Christian with a special guest we
are indeed with that
back to back victories for you how do
you feel right now I feel great
the energy levels are up you're not
feeling tired at all uh no I don't feel
tired and we have one more game and
today off so this is going really well
so far what was uh the strategy going in
today's game
um
I didn't really have a any specific
strategy I just thought
um I I wasn't
um
I thought you would play the Petrov and
I played this line I thought if we play
the end game in the car road then I'll
just play like a long game and I thought
in a long game I can do better than her
absolutely a lot of things happen in
this game they got through the critical
moments because it wasn't as easy yeah
so if we go once yeah if you keep going
forward she decided to avoid the end
game with AC4 I kind of thought she
might do that yeah so if we keep going
so here here
so I thought Queen v36 my position
should be good like her Bishop's locked
in
but then we keep going and then things
get a bit complicated
maybe H4 is unnecessary I don't know I
like H4 take a look at that because like
I don't really want to go H5 because H5
G5 I don't think it's good for me
because my D5 font is hanging and then
she went this should be so on Bishop D3
Queen V6
and I feel like yeah somewhere around
here how did you assess this end game
I thought I still should be good but
she has some concrete play like she goes
like 96 95 maybe get a bishop and um
yeah I played Rook C1 because not before
he's coming Knight D6
yeah and here I got a bit stuck because
I wasn't sure which pieces I'm supposed
to exchange because obviously I want to
leave her with this D7 Bishop but I
don't know which of my Bishops I should
be exchanging and then whenever she
plays Knight yeah so I went uh age five
and then I was thinking Knight F5 even
immediately I wasn't here I was thinking
Bishop G5 but I'm not 100 sure it works
okay I guess not
yeah but okay it's not yeah
seven and it's yeah yeah and then but
okay I'm like okay she still has a bad
Bishop but I think we're exchanging too
much absolutely but again I'm not sure
if I should take on file or let her take
on E3 and
in this position it seems take take and
perhaps you can actually go for this
hey continue taking okay so that's fine
just yeah this is another thing I
consider okay I'll go the other way so
give up my lights yeah I mean it makes
us to give up my light Square Bishop in
the structure of course and I guess once
she goes to F7 you also have ideas
six perhaps
um she went for King F7 yeah here I
thought yeah so here's uh probably felt
her position is getting worse well they
need to do something with tactically it
doesn't work out
and then so I went upon
and you guys got this position yeah but
here
at three four she was getting some
counter chances against your king yeah
and I think were you concerned at all at
this point no I mean I calculated this
and I think her King is also a bit
sketchy but she does have to yeah I mean
she obviously she has some play and then
here I'm gonna take on C7 because yeah
rookie seven so I exchange of for 93
first exchange of Bishops and I feel
like here maybe things could have come
better for me so she checked I want can
give four which I think is okay yes
yeah no uh after this it felt the
transition was quite good perhaps here
at this point
after rotates B3 Bishop to E3 perhaps
yeah I thought about it going into this
Rook end game but okay through again
game seven
and then take on E3 I would assume is
the idea and play two versus one and but
okay two versus one another again that's
not an easy decision commitment to make
right because I thought the scent came
even with the bishop like her Pawn looks
kind of dangerous because her Bishop's
covering B2 and I think she could have
played it better she like just let me
have a lot so she pushed down the board
but yeah she could have gone Bishop C3
here I think or maybe even King C4
instead of King E6 I mean okay during
the game it kind of looks scary I mean I
understand my pond is running but if she
can't give up her bishop and like this
one runs I don't know after a king to E4
yeah
maybe my assessment is not right but
yeah and here I've I don't know I just
kind of missed something I thought this
was just easy for me and then I started
playing and something so it's even
Bishop C3 check King I thought I'm
queening my opponent and I didn't oh
Bishop H6
oh that was my move and then I forgot to
play it no Bishop Basics immediately and
I'm just threatening
just your rubish basics
that's so
just broke the G1
and then just came to F5 yeah now she
can't move Bishop takes before is coming
yeah this one is at the end of my game
was actually really nice because I set
up a little truck because I was also
getting low on time now I don't think oh
my God no I think I did yeah she did but
really smooth King to D5
yeah I think I have to go maybe we
should
Rook before Rook F2 wow
that if still after that she did not
believe it
we have a lot of people love it's a
Lobby full of players thank you very
much for joining us congratulations
back-to-back victories thank you good
start torment we'll see you tomorrow and
our congratulations as well very very
nice uh well I mean those brace of winds
but let's take a look at our standings
after all the games of round four in the
books that start with the Open
Championship
leading he has three points out of War
so neat really impressive Sam Savion is
on the second place clear second place
and followed by Wesley so linear
Dominguez song and Ray Robson as well as
living and Alex Slenderman and the
others who will have two points I was
about to say uh a gangster is all uh but
let's quickly go back to Christian uh
who's with guests I am here with
Alexander lenderon Alexander first of
all congratulations big victory against
a very difficult opponent Christopher
was surging through the rankings won his
last two games but you came out with
this very intriguing idea in the opening
take us through that yeah I mean I was
trying to prepare the best I can before
the tournament
um you know in general I always try to
save my best ideas for a tournament like
this um
so yeah because I think yeah if you
don't have good prep it's very difficult
to play against all these very strong
opponents so at least I wanted some kind
of an advantage
um yeah I think it worked out pretty
well this 95 move in the Catalan it's
like it's not your uh
yeah not not so common I've never played
it before my my friend gave me some
ideas here
um well if you don't mind maybe I guess
you do maybe if I uh you know uh top
three in the tournament I can reveal or
something absolutely but yeah for now uh
I'll keep it secret we'll leave a
friend's secret yes yeah but um yeah but
I mean the most common move instead of
95 of course is castles and then usually
Knight C6 and there's like lots of
theory I've played games on the white
side before yeah 95 is more ambitious
line you know you're sacking a pawn
usually here and actually go back
um it was uh interesting because
actually during game 995 castles and
Christopher was hovering around the B
Pawn and I thought maybe he maybe he'll
play B5 but no I didn't get such luck
because okay 95 ed5 uh Knight C4
I was just to interrupt you for a second
Alice Lee uh the last game pending uh
ended up in a draw let's continue yeah
so it was a bit pity that that didn't
happen but okay it's uh it's it's it's
it's fine yeah uh and it's not like
you're completely winning right I mean
obviously yeah a very good position but
right so so yeah he played the main line
castles 94 B5 B3 and the main line is
cb3 of course
um ab3 and then you know yeah there's
like a lot of theory after that uh
probably black should be sort of okay
but he needs to know a lot a lot yeah he
played C3 I vaguely tried to recall my
prep here and I think I recalled it
correctly and I guess I got a pretty
good position but maybe I misplayed it
so you did actually you were it felt
like you were completely winning at this
point almost
um yeah I was I was told after the game
that apparently nights at 63. yeah
basically what I missed was that after
Knight takes D4 Knight takes D5 ed5
Knight F4 C6 yes I missed Queen C3 ah
got it yeah although apparent the queen
D1 was also good but I mean I did spend
time calculate but unfortunately that
was like a Miss for me in this game
thankfully didn't end up costing still I
mean it's not that easy and you're not
spoiling your advantage with the movie
that you played not completely I mean I
I felt like this should be very good for
me but I just I was spending a lot of
time I just couldn't quite find the best
way did you feel like you let him back
in the game at any point or yeah for
sure at some point I thought it was like
very much close to equal
also I also can we go back a few more
sure yeah so on move 21
194. yeah instead of Knight F4 I was
kind of kicking myself for playing
Knight F4 I was wondering if Knight E4
was the move also absolutely yeah yeah
and then because then C2 maybe I can
take enough six
uh oh but it's actually not good because
the night before oh wow good thing I
didn't do with that I mean night before
is also such a crazy movie yeah I I
didn't see yeah I was kind of I somehow
I just missed C2 it was a bit strange
but I felt like I was missing a lot of
stuff here and no 94 Knight A4 actually
was the best move according to the
engine so okay so Knight C3 and Rook C5
I didn't see at all but yeah I guess it
transposes to this position anyway which
I thought is quite a bit better for me
but I uh definitely no risk for me but I
didn't really see how exactly to plan
the limited material I mean if he
exchanges one Pawn then
yeah I guess somewhere here I okay
Bishop is six rookie five yeah and here
my original intention was something like
uh Bishop F1 or Bishop yeah but then I
realized Queen B3 just doesn't uh Queen
C5 Queen B2 somehow yeah uh and I think
I also calculated something with uh
maybe bishop E4 instead of Bishop F1 or
maybe Queen C3 instead of Bishop of one
Queen C3 yes I was looking at that but
then still yeah he's been taken yeah and
I just realized it's not that great
because there's always pressure on F2 so
yeah I kind of reluctant to play Rook B1
but apparently it was a good move I
still keep the tension and still a
little bit better so yeah I mean I was I
was kind of hoping for the best I mean
his King is a bit weakened and what was
the last mistake that he made
uh what do you feel like the last you
know I'm not really sure because it was
uh or it was just a build up I thought
it was like heading for toward the draw
and there was like neutral time scramble
but then like by the time we got to move
40 I thought I might already be winning
concretely so I I think you were indeed
uh yeah so I'm not exactly sure
especially this move G5 which so yeah G5
looks very interesting but I guess I
calculated well here that I mean I
thought H5 also maybe should be very
promising and well G5 H5 yes but uh but
I think I calculated well here hghg yes
and then uh I think that it's important
instead of Bishop C4 if I go King G1 I
tends Rook C8 and so that's that's why
it's important to start with Bishop C4
um yeah so I was happy that at least
that in the end I played precisely but
yeah it was a great battle Alexander
congratulations your first victory at
the 2022 USS Championship thank you so
much congratulations Alex indeed as
quite an eventful round uh this round
four and let's uh let's check in on the
curtain standings uh with the ladies yes
so we're Leslie just made the door in
her game so we have three uh leaders
that's it from Brahman Jennifer you and
Alice Lee have three points and tie for
the first place leaving a crush and um
beg him together
all of them they have two and a half was
just half a point behind the leaders
bouncing back to 50 thanks to her
victory over Megan Lee and she is with
Christian wow on a a difficult start for
you to this tournament but now you
played one of the co-leaders going into
this round and you were dominant how do
you feel right now okay of course so I'm
very happy to win my first game in the
tournament and I hope not the last one
and I hope to show like this quality of
Chess I was
performing today so I hope to continue
this and how did you approach today's
game what type of positions were you
looking to get out of the opening I
thought maybe it was a little bit
drawish but I then I saw that now uh
Carlson bit me up on this line so I said
probably I can play this line as well
and this one with Queen to C1 no no no
this one this one I meant I meant taking
on D5 taking on D5 first 65 it looks
like uh I'm allowing her to
get her a light squared Bishop out but
then there is still like many chances to
fight
and this is
maybe maybe I have more experience what
are the details of this position oh this
is I think like uh in um
H3 right Bishop h7h3 something like
Castle G4
and then it was something like Bishop he
took when the six Queen B3
if I'm not mistaken yes
yeah and um
so this was my uh
idea approach so it's possible even if
it's not a computer doesn't give
Advantage right here not on this line
but I mean like in general you're
looking for some end game with a little
bit of pressure I didn't know like I had
like a different line and the big like
this morning like I wanted to play
different but then I changed it like uh
15 minutes before the game before I
changed my mind and I decided to play
this one well it definitely worked today
why did you feel like you're taking over
the initiative actually like she played
like very well and it took it was equal
position but I think like in certain
points she's just what I don't know what
happened she starts playing like really
taking a lot of time and playing not her
like best chess definitely like her
quality and first two rounds was much
much better and here was many
interesting options for example if you
go back couple moves so I think was
interesting okay before before it's
interesting but you need to secure your
night on ec4 so here B5 esb5 Bishop D3
maybe take take and um like try to move
A4 was interesting yes therefore with
the dn97 97 96.
I was thinking to play Rook C2 if a
knight to the seventh and E4 it seems
like you also have maybe the idea of
writing no but but she will block it she
will block it first I think it's Knight
A2 97
that's the night before
a Rooks
yes yes and now get night before yeah so
that's why we're thinking maybe
and E4 so that was like very concerned
about move A4 here
because yeah
she was starting to look at this side of
the board and rather uh yeah so it was
like positionally she was just a
misplacing her pieces was that a little
optimistic for her to no I think she
just simply didn't know what to do
probably so definitely she doesn't feel
connected right yeah so this is 97 A4 so
this was important of course very
important to play four and I'm like just
much much better after this move because
now you have full control of the C5
Square managed to get Knight to B3 yeah
and after that it felt like quite a
clean game you were building up and
building up your initiative it's
interesting the variant like if you go
like in the variant was very nice some
tactics I was likely to play Queen E1 I
I saw it um at this point yeah to this
point I was calculating also night night
F4 instead of Knight d4s was also
interesting for sure but I think it was
like the same idea take take and play
Queen F3
here
so that's why you're talking of one and
then and then the same idea since I have
my phone on A5 I have this A6 and you're
running yeah yeah and in the game was
also I I like her to grab my Rook but
okay it's like it was the same once
again yeah once again yes
and just in case calculated Knight B3
not just one Temple she's not enough
V6 but unfortunately for her it did not
uh work out Anna
um for the first time or at least in
many years this tournament has four 13
routes that's a very very long
tournament I never played 13 Rounds in
US championship
special uh maybe in preparation maybe
it's good for me because I came here I
was in Germany so I still have uh yeah
and maybe I will play better in the rest
of the game so it's
I don't know what is better I will tell
you after the tronum excellent Anna
congratulations for the victory we'll
see you in the rest of your games thank
you indeed our congratulations
congratulations as well
I'm I'm sorry I was still trying to make
heads and tails of the Hans Neiman
Fabiano Affair and why on that Rook B2
check King H1 uh could have held the
game versus what was played it's uh it's
it's confounding let's just say that
chess is very very hard and when you
don't have much time this check
apparently is a very very bad one and
the King age three repeated the position
whereas King H1 with somehow magically
made uh Black's life pardon me King G1
would have made uh Black's life
magically harder but the man who will
explain himself our soul leader
is with Christian Favi welcome back to
the studio congratulations back to back
victories and quite an important one
with the black pieces against the
co-leader Hans Niemann how does that
feel
I mean right now I feel exhausted I was
hoping I would give you an interesting
interview
um I was hoping to keep the trend up but
I don't have enough energy for that how
come did you feel disrespected in any
way coming into today's round on every
level
no I I don't really I mean it was a very
difficult game but it shouldn't have
been because
I got such a dominant position at some
point let's talk about the game out of
the opening it did feel like okay I
don't know what he was preparing because
I played this line in the last game
against Hare Krishna in the Olympia so
he seemed surprised I mean
it's not like I had some new idea in
mind I was just repeating exactly my
game uh Harry played e35 and we made a
quick draw yeah and it looked like Hans
was somewhat surprised that I played
this so I I don't know maybe he missed
did you get to chat with him after the
game at all I don't think he wants to
chat him with me anymore okay okay I
think we're no longer on chatting terms
okay Queen C3 uh Rook D1 E5 and you were
mentioning that you had this prepared
and you were playing quite quickly he
wasn't were you surprised by that yeah
he was thinking I I was actually worried
I thought he might come to this game
with some some prep I didn't remember
the line too well and but I thought
um anyway I should play it and say
principled and then yeah I played a rare
move Bishop F5 I was hoping that even if
he knows the line of it that this would
be a surprise for him because Bishop G4
I think is the main move for yeah if I
remember before C6 Bishop there was this
important game Sam against Hikaru it was
uh last year in I think the rapid
um St Louis rapid
and and they made a draw it was a very
correct game but
black suffers a bit there and here it's
more of a fighting position and yeah he
played a very surprising move A4
I thought that Bishop B5 is the correct
move I couldn't remember exactly I think
that was correct I think Bishop E5 was
the correct one of course white does
have some freedom of choice I mean
particularly white is marginally better
here but uh yeah here I was going to
play A6 take 92 and I was not sure if I
can play E4 here one option so you were
out of this out of your book at this
point I mean I I have some like fake
general knowledge not very
I don't didn't recollect it so well I
thought E4 was played in this game
bronze funny because and it looked very
logical but of course it's a bit
positionally risky maybe I'm just mixing
things up completely I think it is
yeah that's a better version yeah so
this was the game but I was wondering if
I could instead of instead of this place
C6 I was trying to figure out this
position here instead of uh Bishop B5
C6 yes I thought D6 is forced
and here the problem is Queen D6 he has
not Knight E4 but Knight C4
and I can't go to G6 because well root
t7 Rook takes seven so
so I was going to play while I was
thinking about it I wasn't sure I was
gonna play C6 but c66 I was going to
play Queen G6
um yeah I thought F3 is very logical
Rook cd8
and this position I was trying to figure
out it didn't look clear to me see the
computer really hates it
maybe Queen G6 is not accurate maybe
Rook cd8 first but I thought that I
should
yeah I wasn't sure I would do this but I
yeah Rook CA first ah this is 94 Queen
G6 F3 I I was looking for another move
order but maybe I get it here and then
Bishop F5 I thought I should be okay
Knight G3 yeah and yeah then I forced
him to take the bishop with H5 at some
point he'll take and then I just block
hate his D pawn and I thought
yeah take take he plays
yeah and I also have some
uh H3 ideas at some moment so I thought
I thought I should be completely fine
here
um but then he surprised me A4 I got
very ambitious suddenly
okay he played C6 immediately D6
and this is the move that surprised us
H3 yeah I didn't I I didn't expect gf3
I mean which was probably the best path
forward that this yeah yeah actually
came as a surprise I was thinking some
other move like Queen before was
interesting I think that was the best
movie in the position some sort of mess
after e494 maybe he just saw a C5 here
and thought uh thought he shouldn't do
this
um but yeah but it doesn't work
especially before and D7 singing yep but
I don't like if I take only two B6 his
Pawn is not so dangerous
um
but yeah he was also getting low on time
so I understand why he started to play
rather quickly but but probably not very
accurately and he played H3 and at this
point he felt like you're slowly taking
over but he was still fighting yeah
something maybe rookie 6 was inaccurate
or something because I thought I had a
better Advantage than what I got
Square to put the Rook
yeah I think
at this point it felt like you were
completely done maybe kimchi thought it
was bad I was not hesitating I thought
maybe four
I mean okay it can't be a bad move but
actually 494 I thought this
yeah Queen F4 and now maybe I take take
and Rook D6 is this uh
is this just winning King 2 Knight C5 I
trade
Bishop C2 I wasn't 100 sure take take an
F5 but it's of course a bit difficult
which would be one of five he puts a
county three my pawns are on light
squares it might be difficult to win
this yeah uh I wasn't sure and I thought
okay I'll just make a safe move King G7
and then he played a very good good
movie E4 and it's suddenly difficult for
black to
um to handle this position I mean of
course I should be winning but the path
wasn't clear I mean Knight B5 I I was
thinking take Rook D5 I mean all my
pawns are really I'm really tied up yeah
A6 but I just wasn't sure after King G2
how I continue this yeah and it's not
clear at all yeah computer says Queen F4
but I mean yeah I was a bit worried that
maybe this weekend is a very trash in
general so I wasn't sure yep yep
and you played Queen to E7 trying to
escape the queen trade Queen G5
and then you guys got it yeah
maybe this was inaccurate but I was low
in time I just I thought okay I'll
create a passport and try to get the F4
Square for either my king or Knight yep
and it was this moment yeah I should
have played of course Knight B6 I was
trying that's what I tried to get but it
was like the time control so I thought
it was like B6 yeah this this is of
course a better try than
and if he goes back to
e27 yeah
this is what I wanted what I was going
to do after the time control but then he
played F4
um if you played Bishop A6 back I would
have gone to B6
and then yeah this is took
and then this was the critical model
Rook to E5 yeah C4 uh he's okay here
I thought I was winning only with Rook
A6
oh yeah Rook A6
um I thought 93 is winning King F2
yeah take take rookie four
maybe king of
it this is a draw
maybe maybe
I don't
if I was winning
ah but he just has Rook h8 yeah maybe
okay yeah yeah okay I mean it's well
draw is like you know two poems kind of
draw yeah in time travel but F3 yeah but
it is a drawn ending with the two pawns
yeah
um I I just didn't see this work h8 I
thought I'll get my Rook to the side and
then his B Pawn is less important than
my three pawns if I could keep all three
then I would win
um and he didn't probably assess it
correctly either uh because he did play
this move King to G2 after a long thing
yeah 15 minutes I think I think he had a
lot of time I had like seven minutes I
don't remember what he had maybe 25 or
so 22 and he dropped down to his last
seven yeah he went he got eagles with me
on time and then I thought maybe King G5
wasn't the most accurate I was
hesitating like Rook B8 is also very
very strong I thought
but then I was like okay King G5 is more
natural let's and I saw this whole Rook
a rook h8
and when I played King G5 I thought yeah
Rook H5 Rook B5
and I was really counting on F6 here
Rook F4 yeah Knight D3 yep Rook H4 Rook
H5 yeah okay 12 Knight of four yeah King
G4 we looked at this line and yeah and
the King comes back after C5 but then I
was like yeah this is a drop but I was
thinking maybe King E6 F4 F5 but then he
has King G6 which is a draw
because if C5 he just gets back yeah and
then King G6 take F5 and we get the C
Pawn which uh yeah can go somewhere
which
I don't know like some of these
positions are losing somewhere a draw I
assume the C Pawn is actually winning
for black usually like the central pawns
are are better winning chances but here
of course the pawn isn't very far
advanced
but like a and b are it's difficult to
win yeah on you get some trouble like D
or E if it's Advanced then it's just
apparently it's winning yeah yeah the
central pawns are really hard to defend
but then I couldn't like decide on this
I had just a little time I mean I saw
that I could go for this but
there was I thought okay The Rook ending
feels like it should be winning but I
was really unsure and of course
surprised me a bit actually yeah
it was a draw but only with yeah smooth
F4 surprised me I mean Rook G1 I was
gonna play Rook C5 I think G2 was the
best move I can't imagine why would yeah
I understand okay so rookie one let's I
mean let's try to stay with a human
Rook C5 I need to go because I can't
allow Works you're planning on playing
this yeah King G4 work C2 and F4
I thought this was winning take King
takes H3 but I wasn't sure it's very
you know his work has to go behind the
pawn yeah but how he does that I don't
know
and it might turn into some sort of race
so and he played he made this final
mistake F4 but I wasn't sure this was
winning I mean it's like it's easy of
course when when you see the engine but
it's very close very close to being a
draw I assumed he he thought it was a
draw yeah but yeah it's Fabiano uh plus
two after four rounds how are you seeing
uh the start to this tournament so far
how are you feeling about it well it's
good but I I am exhausted now I mean
this was a tough game and uh
the first three games I wasn't like
under time pressure but once you get a
long game where you deal with time
trouble then
um then you really feel it the tiredness
so and I think tomorrow I play Wesley
which is a very important game big round
tomorrow we'll let you go get your rest
and we'll see you tomorrow thank you
thank you okay congratulations uh Fabi
absolutely and just to review let's take
a look at our predictions as we get
ready to say goodbye after four very
eventful rounds uh who do we like
yeah here we are
it's not bad it's not bad
about it I understand you're in Pole
Position
I've got uh uh you have good
competitions yes
and in the oven
and in the open actually it's Christian
yes
thank you guys thank you for playing
thank you guys but c squared podcast you
have to go with your partner I knew
there was no choice and we're gonna see
you all tomorrow for round five of these
U.S championships happy weekend
everybody it was great Anastasia we'll
see you tomorrow good night everybody
see you tomorrow
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited